>> O no lo sé o no.
Para.
Un.
A.
Muy buenos días.
Recibamos en Jalmo 28 para comenzar a
Hugo Salinas Sada.
>> Buenos días a todos!
Cómo están?
Pues estamos de vuelta aquí en Jalmo
28 y, eh, estamos muy contentos
porque creo que este Jalmo va a ser
especialmente interesante.
Vamos a hablar de inteligencia artificial,
que no sé ustedes, pero a mí me vuela la
cabeza.
Cómo va evolucionando y cómo va avanzando la
inteligencia artificial y invariablemente me
siento que estoy atrás y no sé suficiente.
Entonces creo que este va a ser un buen
momento para aprender, para, para preguntar
y y y ver de qué manera podemos integrar.
Eh, esta esta herramienta a
nuestros negocios, eh?
Y bueno, como todos los Jalmo para empezar
vamos a a empezar con con con los nuevos
integrantes y les pido por favor que que se
presenten, que digan brevemente quiénes son
y de dónde vienen.
Y empezamos con Braden
Cazares, Braden.
Eh, please you can do it in English, If you
like just introduce yourself tell us where
you came from
>> We are a US based cardiac diagnostic
service where we both develop, manufacture
and offer a service base for the electrical
current.
On what's going on with patients hearts.
Okay.
Married.
Got two kids.
Got a ten year old daughter.
A six year old son.
We're all very avid outdoors, folks.
I'm a huge hunter.
And Fisher.
I actually hunt and fish all around the
world, and it's a huge passion of mine.
I just want to thank everybody.
Thank Ricardo for the opportunity to be here,
and I look forward to getting to know some of
you better.
>> Thank you Brandon.
También viene con nosotros. César
>> Bueno, Bueno.
Buenos días. Buenos días a
Rosalina.
Senora. Maria. Laura. Muchas gracias
Este lugar está espectacular.
De verdad estoy muy contento de estar aquí
con todos ustedes.
Ehh.
Rápidamente les cuento.
Yo desde hace apenas unas semanas estoy.
A cargo y dirigiendo ADN
noticias y estoy casado.
Tengo dos hijos, Diego de siete y María
Regina, de cinco.
Ehh.
Tengo 14 años de casado.
O sea, ahí voy poquito, pero ahí la
llevo, eh?
Mi carrera ha estado, eh, muy muy apegada a
los medios de comunicación, a la comunicación
política, a a las campañas políticas, al
servicio público en su momento.
Y ahora pues estoy acá agradeciendo mucho a
Luciano Pascua, a Benjamín, que me hayan dado
la oportunidad de de estar en este, que sin
duda es uno de los grandes retos
profesionales más importantes de mi vida y
pues como detalles llevo yo ya tres campañas
en contra del tres campañas presidenciales en
contra del inquilino de allá de Palenque, dos
ganadas, una perdida, ahí vamos eh?
Les les, les reitero toda mi mi
agradecimiento, mi mi lealtad al
proyecto.
Y señor Salinas, aquí estamos el equipo de
ADN para dar la batalla.
Buenos días.
Gracias, César.
>> Eh, Gerardo Pizarro.
Gerardo.
Dónde?
Dónde andas?
>> Hola.
Hola.
Aquí está.
>> Buenos días a todos.
Ricardo. María!
Laura.
Gracias por recibirme en su casa.
Cecilia.
Gracias por la invitación.
Trabajo en Upac en la fábrica de software.
Hace cuatro años que ya estoy en el grupo y
bueno, nada, un placer estar acá con todos
ustedes.
Seguro que voy a aprender muchísimo y a
disfrutar muchísimo también.
La única meta que tengo es creo que ayudar un
poco a hacer software más barato.
Gracias.
>> Gracias Gerardo.
También démosle la bienvenida a Jaime Ávalos.
>> Acá estoy.
Hola, buenos días a todos.
Mi nombre es Jaime Avalos y yo soy director
de Marketing United en Upac eh.
La verdad es que para mí es un honor estar en
este foro aprendiendo los mejores.
Gracias a mi jefa Ceci por el apoyo y
la confianza.
Gracias también a María Laura y a Ricardo por
toda esta eh.
Pues todo este evento que nos están haciendo
aquí, la verdad es que me parece que para mí
va a ser algo muy muy importante.
Yo estoy aquí principalmente para
entender, escuchar y aportar.
Así es de que para mí es un placer estar
aquí.
Gracias, gracias.
>> Jaime.
Juan Pablo Delgado.
>> Muy buenos días a todos.
Señor Salinas.
Señora María Laura, muchísimas gracias por
habernos recibido aquí en su casa.
En verdad es un verdadero honor estar rodeado
de gente tan distinguida.
Yo actualmente soy el director general de los
noticieros hechos en Azteca Noticias.
Empezamos a trabajar gracias a Luciano por su
confianza.
También a Benjamín.
Desde hace un par de meses en En esta nueva
etapa de los noticieros hechos y llevo 13
años en el grupo, siempre en el área de
noticias, acompañando aquí también a mi
querido Nacho Suárez.
Hemos estado enfocados siempre en la
promoción de los valores, de los principios,
de la ideología de Ricardo, del grupo, cosa
que se ha puesto cada vez más divertida desde
que empezamos la guerra cultural en contra de
este régimen.
Y entonces estoy seguro que vienen muchas
nuevas oportunidades para promover, para
cambiar la mentalidad de este país, para
formar y para informar a la audiencia.
Y estoy muy emocionado.
Vamos a darle con todo.
Luciano, Ricardo, cuentas con
todo mi apoyo.
Gracias.
>> Gracias Juan Pablo.
También está Norma Hurtado.
>> Hola, qué tal?
Muy buenos días.
Este primeramente muchas gracias señor
Ricardo Salinas eh hermosa Ana, Laura, María,
Laura perdón y eh, tengo 17 años en la
empresa, mi nombre es Norma Hurtado, estoy a
cargo de Grupo Elektra en el territorio
Oaxaca.
Apenas estamos por allá y la verdad es que
me he encontrado en un territorio con
muchas necesidades.
Hablando de la parte cultural, hablando de la
parte de la batalla y creo que estamos en un
lugar en donde vamos a aportar mucho, vamos
por muy buen camino y estamos seguros de que
juntos somos más como bien nos nos los dicen
aquí y lo tenemos súper tatuado.
Muchas gracias por su hospitalidad.
Gracias.
>> Gracias Norma, Yo un comentario.
>> Segunda mujer de la historia territorial de
la red de canales.
>> Por último está Raúl Guendulain con
nosotros.
Gracias Hugo por la presentación, eh?
Muchas gracias Ricardo y María Laura por
permitirnos estar hoy en en su casa.
Tengo siete años en el grupo llevando
mercadotecnia para las marcas Elektra presta
prenda y Banco Azteca y a lo largo de estos
siete años he podido conocer gente muy
interesante que siempre me ha apoyado y
quiero aprovechar por por esto.
Muchas gracias Alberto.
Mario, eh, Fabri, Elena, Carlos muchas
gracias.
Hace un año Alberto me invitó al proyecto de
Jesse Motos, un proyecto que tenía muchos
retos y les puedo decir que después de un año
sí tiene muchos retos, hay muchas cosas por
hacer, pero también es un negocio muy
divertido y con un gran potencial, eh?
Me siento muy orgulloso de estar hoy aquí con
todos ustedes.
Muchas gracias.
Gracias por estar.
>> Aquí.
>> Gracias Raúl.
Y bueno, como siempre, las recomendaciones de
de Jalmolonga mantener mente abierta en todo
momento.
Atención y presencia,
participación activa y respeto.
Y ya para para dar inicio a estas sesiones
vamos a darle la bienvenida a mi papá Ricardo
Salinas Pliego.
>> Muy bien!
>> Buen día!
Qué gusto verlos aquí a todos.
Una vez más el equipo potente de Grupo
Salinas se junta y estoy seguro que
van a salir cosas muy buenas de esta
reunión.
Justo la semana pasada estaba grabando un
comercial de 120 años de Grupo Salinas.
Cumplimos 120 años cumpliendo y que
me quedé pensando qué barbaridad!
Escogimos la fecha de 1906.
Arbitraria, como todo, pero había que escoger
algo, no?
En 1906, mi bisabuelo,
Benjamín Salinas
Westrup, inició una
fábrica de camas en
Monterrey.
Justo acabo de estar en Monterrey la semana
pasada y me impresionó como ha cambiado
Monterrey y una cosa tremenda.
Pero en aquel tiempo, en 1906.
Estamos en el final de la época
Porfiriana y antes de que comenzara
la Revolución y México había
finalmente alcanzado 30 años de
paz.
Continua, cosa que no se había
visto en México desde desde
1800, eh?
Diez Cuando comenzó la revolución
tuvimos una paz, digamos, bastante
sólida por 300 años durante el periodo
virreinal y a partir de 1810 México
empezó con estas convulsiones.
Primero de independencia y luego Guerra
Civil, hasta que finalmente llega Porfirio
Díaz y se establece una paz de 30.
>> Años.
>> Y al final de ese periodo es cuando el
abuelo, el bisabuelo, decide poner esa
fábrica.
Y ahí decimos que nace el Grupo Salinas,
porque la fábrica se llama Salinas y Rocha,
fábrica de Camas.
Y hace 20 años aquí con Mario San
Román, se nos ocurrió hacer la
celebración de los 100 años de Grupo
Salinas.
Hace 20 años era el
2006.
Y en el 2006 se estaba acabando
el periodo de Vicente Fox.
Que finalmente había logrado sacar al
PRI de Los Pinos, a pesar de Mendoza.
Pues que lo saca a patadas.
Y debo decir con mucha ayuda nuestra.
>> Eh?
>> Hicimos un evento en el.
Creo que fue en el Museo de Antropología, no
me acuerdo por ahí en Chapultepec y ahí va
Fox era, era muy amable con nosotros y se
cruzó en el camino con Calderón.
Este desgraciado Calderón ahora lo
prefiero como lo los cuatreros, los
narco morenos, lo los los los, los
satanizan a Calderón todo el día, que
era lo peor y que era lo peor.
Ahora resulta que es un héroe.
No, nada.
Un desgraciado resentido.
envidioso y resentido.
Felipe Calderón.
Y nos hizo mucho daño porque lo primero que
hizo entrando fue la reforma electoral que
nos impidió.
Nos dejó impedidos para siempre como
ciudadanos.
La participación en la política, y esto es
muy relevante porque lo que estamos viviendo
hoy, gracias a Calderón, no podemos comprar
ni vender anuncios políticos.
Gracias a Calderón, la partidocracia se quedó
con el monopolio de la política.
Gracias a Calderón no hay participación
ciudadana.
Entonces, hay que decirlo.
Pero me quedé pensando qué
barbaridad!
Es que realmente el tiempo pasa demasiado
rápido.
Ya son 20 años de eso ya ni quien se
acuerda de Calderón si no es porque el
loquito este.
De AMLO se la pasó invocándolo y ahora la
señora igual.
Pero si no qué?
Cómo ha pasado el tiempo, no?
Y yo digo qué barbaridad!
Y ni qué se diga de cuando compramos la
televisión azteca.
Ya en la prehistoria,
en el 93 no ya 33
años.
Y claro, me quedo pensando qué distinto
es el mundo y qué igual es el mundo.
Todo está igual.
Hay muchas cosas.
Que este igual, por ejemplo,
el fraude de la moneda fiat,
fraude sigue igual, o sea,
peor que nunca.
Nunca nos hubiéramos imaginado la cantidad de
dinero falso que están produciendo los
gobiernos de todo el mundo en perjuicio de
los ciudadanos de todo el mundo.
Es una cosa épica.
Ustedes se rompen la cara todos los días para
trabajar, para llevar unos billetes a su casa
y estos cabrones del gobierno nomás le hacen
así y lo fabrican.
Algo tiene que estar mal.
Esto no está bien.
No es posible que uno tenga que trabajar para
ganar el dinero y ellos nomás le hacen así y
se lo meten a la bolsa y se lo gastan.
Este increíble.
Pero no crean que es un problema de México,
es un problema de Estados Unidos y de Europa,
y de China, y de Japón, y de Reino Unido y de
México.
Y de todas las todos los países que
viven hoy con el la institución perversa
y nefasta de la moneda Fiat.
Y ahí podríamos extendernos a por qué esto y
todo, pero nada más.
Quiero que se graben, que eso hace 20
años era igual, ahora está peor, pero
igual.
Y hace 40 años era igual.
Todo cambió en 1971, cuando
el presidente de Estados
Unidos, Nixon, defaulteó
sobre la promesa de convertir
un papel, un billete dólar
por 32 onzas de oro.
Este.
Increíble.
Está igual.
Está peor.
Y claro, como el gobierno, los
gobiernos tienen esta facultad
increíblemente injusta de fabricar
billetes, pues hay una explosión de la
del gasto y de las deudas.
O sea, no les alcanza para fabricar, sino
además piden prestado para seguir gastando
una cosa.
Es la explosión del gasto público, del gasto
de los gobiernos.
Ha sido una cosa espectacular.
Y qué sigue?
Igual.
La mala, las malas ideas
siguen con una distribución
sorprendentemente amplia.
Las ideas de los zurdos de
siguen teniendo demasiada
distribución y demasiada
aceptación.
Y la primera mala idea de los zurdos de
es este concepto de la igualdad como un
objetivo deseable.
La igualdad, la.
El militarismo que todos vivamos
modestamente iguales.
Eso es una de las peores ideas que hay por
ahí.
Y nos llevan, claro, a tratar
de hacer iguales.
A quienes somos desiguales porque al
contrario, nosotros defendemos la
fantástica individualidad de cada uno de
nosotros y la fantástica diferencia que
hay entre cada una de estas personas.
Y es precisamente por las diferencias que hay
que podemos hacer un equipo complementario
que es mucho más exitoso y no tiene ningún
chiste.
Tú lo ves en el fútbol, este lo ves en la
música hay distintos talentos, verdad?
El vocalista y el baterista son hacen cosas
distintas y el el portero y el delantero
hacen cosas distintas y es un equipo de
grandes talentos diferentes, lo que nos saca
adelante.
Si todos fuéramos enanitos chaparritos.
y jugando el mismo papel,
pues no, no, no entiendo por
qué no?
Sí entiendo por qué estos monos que nos
venden la idea de la igualdad y el
militarismo lo hacen porque vienen de
una, de una posición psicológica muy
mala.
Dios los hizo envidiosos y los
hizo resentidos.
Y encima póngales la ignorancia.
Pero lo importante es lo envidioso y lo
resentido.
Entonces ellos lo que quieren es echarnos y
hacernos iguales a todos y nosotros tenemos
que resistir a eso.
Sigue después de 20 años, esta ideología
increíble.
Hoy nos va a comentar Agustín Laje que está
con nosotros.
Algo de eso estoy seguro, y por eso es tan
importante seguir con esta idea de la batalla
cultural, porque hay que partir de las ideas
y de los principios.
Eso es lo que manda la acción.
Después, por otra parte, en los
últimos 20 años ha habido grandes
cambios, enormes cambios.
Algunos muy particulares que nos
afectan a nosotros, por ejemplo, está
increíble ambición imperial de los
Estados Unidos siempre ha estado ahí,
pero ahora exacerbada, claro, por el
liderazgo de Trump.
Y cómo se manifiesta?
Pues que por primera vez en la historia vemos
que un gobierno extranjero va, monta una
operación pepena, captura a un criminal.
>> Pero era el presidente de Venezuela y va y lo
refunde y estaba dormido en su casa a las
00:00 de la.
Noche y.
>> Al día siguiente a las 00:00 de la noche.
Está en Brooklyn, vestido de
anaranjado mocos.
Eso sí que nunca lo habíamos visto.
Y entonces uno dice bueno, pues es que a lo
mejor los americanos nos van a salvar a
nosotros.
Aquí de los problemas que tenemos.
Y a lo mejor hace una expedición punitiva y
pepenan a Rocha y los diez.
Pues puede ser, pero yo diría que no hay que
confiarnos y no hay que esperar que alguien
más haga las cosas por nosotros.
Y lo que sí es que nos toca vivir con un
vecino muy difícil.
Por ejemplo.
Pues debido a que aquí hay un
narcoestado moreno.
Que tiene vínculos clarísimos con el
crimen organizado en Sinaloa, en
Tamaulipas, en Tabasco.
Y que se dedica a robarle combustible a Pemex
o a extraer combustible de contrabando y a
venderlo a través de la red de distribución
del crimen organizado y el crimen organizado.
Le da dinero al narcoestado.
Debido a eso.
Pues estamos en un una ruta de choque
directo con los Estados Unidos y lo que
pasó ayer no es casualidad.
Después de que Estados Unidos lleva 20 días
diciendo Entréguenme a Rocha y a los diez el
gobernador de Sinaloa.
Y después de que llevamos 21 días donde el
gobierno México dice no, no, no, pues qué
crees?
Nos publicaron ayer en Estados Unidos
una orden ejecutiva diciendo y los que
están en Estados Unidos de forma
ilegal, o sea los paisanos mexicanos,
les vamos a prohibir el acceso al
sistema bancario, no van a poder pedir
préstamos, no van a poder tener
depósitos, no van a poder tener acceso
al sistema de pagos.
Y qué creen?
>> No van a tener forma de mandar remesas a
México.
Ya.
>> Y el tema de las remesas para México es
fundamental porque son 1.000.000.000 de
dólares por semana que entran al país, que
nos mandan los paisanos.
En Estados Unidos, 40 millones de mexicanos
que trabajan allá, y debo decirlo, trabajan
de manera legítima y honesta y es una China.
Chingadera con todas sus letras.
El que los quieran expropiar allá.
Pero cuál es el problema?
El problema es el conflicto político aquí en
México, si no hubiera habido este conflicto
político, pues igual no hubiera pasado esto
>> Pero.
Hemos sobrevivido muchas cosas y como yo
digo, el empresario exitoso es el que se
pueda adaptar a las circunstancias para
seguir operando.
Entonces yo creo que vale la pena.
Articular una visión para los próximos 20
años, no?
Entonces.
O sea, lo fácil es decir bueno, pues vamos a
seguir haciendo préstamos y vendiendo motos y
haciendo capta y haremos el negocio en
Estados Unidos y en Guatemala, y en Honduras
y en Panamá.
Y vamos.
Sí.
O sea, los negocios van muy bien.
Tenemos buenas ideas, estamos bien
posicionados en todo lo que hacemos en las
tiendas, Neto, en en la telecomunicación, en
la televisión.
Estamos bien, pero qué clase de
entorno nos espera?
Entonces me preocupa más.
Claro, será porque ya estoy mucho más viejo y
los próximos 20 años se me van a ir muy
rápido.
Tengo 70, seguro en 20 ya no me va a tocar
el Jalmo 59.
pero a lo mejor ustedes si.
Y entonces qué?
A qué le tiramos?
O sea, hay que poner como una, como una
ambición grande, como un anhelo.
No.
Que valga la pena para nosotros y para
los hijos también.
Que aquí están.
Y después para los nietos, No.
Que seguramente estarán aquí pronto.
Yo creo que vale la pena luchar
por un entorno donde podamos sacar
a estos zurdos de del poder,
liberarnos de una buena vez de
este narcoestado Moreno.
Y la primera ventana se abre en el 20 30.
Falta mucho tiempo y quién sabe
si con votos se puedan sacar
estos desgraciados del poder y
quién sabe si sea yo, eh?
A lo mejor hay otro candidato mejor, pero
creo que debemos de ponernos esa meta el 20
30 en la elección, sacar a los zurdos de del
poder.
Y eso pasa por el 27, que es el año que
entra.
Quitarles la mayoría del Congreso.
Y por qué no?
Porque nos guste la política.
No nos gusta, pero porque si no lo hacemos el
entorno se va a descomponer más.
Y quiero platicarles un poco del entorno.
Ahorita, ahora, teniendo esa
meta de largo aliento y
articulándola, es interesante
como primero tienes la idea y el
sentimiento y luego como que lo
empiezas a visualizar y luego lo
empiezas a hablar, a platicar y
luego si lo escribes se realiza
porque así es el ser humano y
esto nos los enseñó hace muchos
años.
Es la idea, la pules, la
escribes y ahora si la
realizas.
Yo creo que esta es la primera vez que la
digo así y la tengo escrita.
Pues ni modo.
Y eso nos lleva después a una acción
constante, constante, constante, constante
hacia esa dirección.
No es un pico y un esfuerzo y ya no es una
dirección constante, es un gota a gota.
Ahora, qué riesgos hay?
Pues hay mucho riesgo, hay
riesgos personales, hay riesgos
de negocio.
Valdrá la pena? Claro,
uno solamente
El resultado de las decisiones después.
Pero yo creo tenido bastante
Tomar riesgos.
He tomado muchos riesgos y hemos salido bien
y pues con el campeón hasta que pierda y si
tomamos el riesgo y se chingó pues de
cualquier forma nos íbamos a morir.
>> No, No, O.
>> Sea, hay que ser optimistas.
Tal vez es la de la deformación profesional
más importante del empresario.
Es ser perennemente optimista
a pesar de las tempestades y
el entorno.
Y si, hay que ser optimistas pero no
pendejos.
También hay que tener la cautela necesaria
para sobrevivir.
En este Jalmo vamos a hablar mucho sobre
inteligencia artificial.
y hoy quiero tocar dos
temas, más bien un tema el
empleo.
Y la inteligencia artificial y el empleo Y el
gobierno.
Y fíjense que está muy triste la
situación del empleo, no nada más en
México, sino en todo el mundo.
Puedo decirles que el empleo es el blanco de
ataque más grande de los gobiernos.
Fíjese bien, el Gobierno se dedica a
atacar el empleo.
Parece que el Gobierno quiere, los gobiernos
quieren que no haya empleo.
Y por qué lo dices?
Si siempre están diciendo que hay que
promover el empleo y.
No, no, no, no, porque el empleo
es la actividad más
agresivamente.
Gravada por impuestos.
Así como ponen impuestos al chupe al
tabaco, eh?
A todo lo malo, a los juegos y sorteos,
así le ponen impuestos al empleo.
No me creen?
Ahí les va.
En México.
El robo, el despojo del
gobierno al empleado es
del 40%, o sea, del 100%
del valor que genera un
empleo.
El gobierno se queda con 40.
Está altísimo. Bueno, sí, bueno, comparado
Quiero decirles.
Qué
Es del 60% seis cero
en España.
El despojo es del 50%.
Aquí Carlos me ayudó a sacar.
Y cómo estamos en Latinoamérica?
Pues del nabo en Panamá también es 40%
de despojo.
En Honduras, donde está nuestro amigo de
Honduras.
Ahí están mejor.
Es el 25% y en Guatemala?
Está acá.
Aplauso.
El despojo en Guatemala solo es el
9%.
Entonces el ataque de los
gobiernos al empleo es brutal.
Y en qué se manifiesta?
Bueno, déjeme darles otro dato interesante
México tiene una población de 130 millones.
De personas, de los cuales hay
70 millones inactivos.
O sea, ya.
Por qué están inactivos?
Bueno, hay muchos jóvenes, menos de 14 años.
Son 40 millones.
Hay ancianitos como nosotros, varios
de más de 65 años 13 millones.
Y otros entre 14 y 65 que son
huevones naturales y no
trabajan 18 millones.
Y ellos también se dan con maceta, verdad?
Entonces inactivos que no
trabajan 70 millones, lo cual
quiere decir que económicamente
activos tenemos 60 millones en
México 60 Pero qué creen?
De esos 6 millones son
gobiernícolas
parásitos.
6 millones, o sea, el 10% de la fuerza
laboral trabaja en el gobierno estorbando y
robando, porque productivos nada.
O sea, si mañana se desemplean todos, no pasa
nada.
6 millones.
Y luego hay 21 millones de empleos
formales como los que tenemos
aquí, que son las víctimas del
despojo al 40%.
Y luego hay
33.000.033.000.000 de
informales a Qué raro,
verdad?
Por qué creen que hay tanto informal en
México?
Pues porque está duramente gravada la
actividad de ser empleado.
33 millones de informales.
Y claro, entonces el paradigma Y por qué
México no crece?
Bueno, pues porque el PIB y los
economistas sacan ese esa medida que es
una porquería, pero no registra todos los
informales, porque los informales son una
solución.
Bravo por la informalidad.
Y quiero decirles que cuando te atacan
de esa manera con los impuestos, nos
vemos obligados.
Tenemos la necesidad de repeler ese
ataque y defender lo nuestro.
Y nos van a acusar de ilegales, no ilegales.
Son ellos ilegales, inmorales, ineptos,
corruptos y mentirosos.
Es lo que siempre les digo.
Son lo mismo.
Ineptos.
Número uno, corruptos.
Número dos.
Mentirosos.
Eh, No me vengan con que tenemos que venir a
cumplir con sus e indicaciones para ser
esclavos.
Tenemos que defendernos.
Es defensa propia.
Y claro, estamos entonces en este
círculo vicioso de no inversión, no
empleo, no crecimiento.
Entonces.
Qué raro, si en lo formal, pero acá
abajo en la informalidad está todo lo
que da.
Entonces para nosotros como grupo que siempre
hemos estado en contacto con la informalidad,
se avecinan tiempos buenos.
Ese es por el lado del ataque al empleo de
los gobiernos.
Pero qué creen?
También hay otra cosa la inteligencia
artificial.
O mejor bien.
O sea, cuando uno dice inteligencia
artificial.
No, no es muy descriptiva, la verdad.
Se me hizo una mala, una mala frase para
describir esto que está pasando, lo que está
pasando.
Estamos viendo unos agentes.
Listos?
Agentes listos.
No es inteligencia artificial, pero agentes
que es un agente, Pues es un ente que vive
ahí en la computadora y que es muy listo,
porque si tú le dices ciertas cosas, lo lo lo
entiende rápido y entonces te ayuda.
Y a mí me parece que en lugar de verlo como
una amenaza al empleo, de que o es que vamos
a desemplear a mucha gente por la
inteligencia artificial?
Hay que ver lo diferente.
La gente que tenemos va a ser mucho más
productiva y va a ganar mucho más dinero
porque va a contribuir mucho más valor usando
estos agentes que por cierto, no pagan
impuestos al empleo.
Porque si yo contrato un mono para hacerme un
excel o le tengo que pagar por nómina y 40%
se roba el gobierno, Pero si mi agente lo
entreno a hacer el excel a pagar nada más que
la cuota del.
De la gente, verdad?
Entonces esto cambia todo eh?
Si ya se, ya se abrió una una
asimetría tremenda a favor de la
gente.
Listo y en contra del
empleo normalito.
Y los que ustedes, ustedes que están aquí y
que aprendan a poner a diez agentes a
trabajar con cada uno de ustedes.
Se van a ir a la luna y los que no se van a
quedar ahí sobre el camino.
Pero es una cosa dramática.
Como dijo Google al principio, sabemos que
está en la inteligencia artificial y es más o
menos lo hemos usado ahí, pero es
impresionante.
El otro día que le puse un pequeño informe
ahí sobre Pemex y le dije hazme un resumen,
me una pinche presentación increíble.
Aquí los monos de noticias se hubieran
tardado tres semanas y no hubiera quedado
igual.
Es impresionante y cualquier
cosa, temas de salud.
Le abres una carpeta, pones tus expedientes
médicos y luego le pregunto Hiciste hoy?
Híjole, pues sí.
O temas de negocios o temas de
de política.
Es verdaderamente interesante.
Entonces en este Jalmo vamos a
gastar mucho tiempo en eso y yo
creo que es una herramienta
poderosísima que tenemos que
aprender a usar todos al más
alto nivel o quedarse obsoleto
y pasar.
al retiro y dejar que los jóvenes que sí
saben usar esta herramienta pues tomen las
decisiones.
Eso es lo que hay.
O usamos la herramienta o nos retiramos.
Entonces, bueno.
Creo que.
Tiempos interesantes es poco.
Les dejo algunas ideas.
Para cerrar esta
introducción.
Un poco de todo.
Primero es la batalla cultural y luego es la
batalla electoral.
Muy importante.
Primero lo cultural y luego lo electoral.
La palabra mala es la igualdad.
La palabra buena es libertad.
La función del empresario.
No es cierto.
No es invertir y no es crear empleo.
Esa no es la función del empresario.
La función del empresario es servir mejor
a sus clientes con mejores productos y
servicios, mejores que la competencia.
Y así es, porque como se llega a la
prosperidad, el círculo virtuoso es
innovación.
Competencia, prosperidad y eso solamente se
puede dar en libertad.
Muy fácil.
El empresario exitoso no es el que tiene la
mejor idea, sino el que se adapta mejor a las
circunstancias, porque todo el tiempo cambian
las circunstancias, cambian los competidores,
cambia la tecnología, cambian los productos y
si no te adaptas al basurero de la historia.
No se puede hacer un buen negocio con una
mala persona.
Entonces, la calidad de nuestros
colaboradores es de suma importancia.
Por eso no podemos
tolerar.
Ni la ineptitud.
Ni la corrupción, ni las
mentiras.
Cuello No se puede hacer negocio con malas
personas y por eso tenemos un sistema de
honesto y de investigaciones.
Y todo porque tenemos que cuidar la
integridad ética de toda nuestra gente.
No se puede hacer buen negocio con mala
persona.
La chamba del líder.
Es escoger el camino correcto.
Y ni modo, ese es, eso es.
Es por aquí y seguramente
No,
Por los zurdos.
No.
Nuestro querido México no necesita más
regulaciones.
No necesita más control.
Si necesita más seguridad en nuestra
vida, más seguridad en nuestras
propiedades y más libertad de acción.
Y los dejo con esta última meditación.
Qué clase de futuro le van a dejar ustedes
a sus hijos y a sus nietos?
Porque se viene, se viene el tiempo
rapidísimo encima, eh?
O sea, parece que no, pero sí.
Y hoy, las decisiones que hoy estamos tomando
van a afectar a nuestros hijos 20 años más
atrás, como las que yo tomé hace 20 años.
Fue lo que nos trajo hasta aquí.
Y parece.
Hay decisiones que son muy marcadas para acá
o para acá, pero hay otras que se van
construyendo golpe a golpe, verso a verso,
como dice la canción y haciendo el camino al
andar.
Y frente a los cambios
tecnológicos.
Frente a los abusos del gobierno en
con el gasto, con la creación de
dinero falso, con la depredación
fiscal frente a la inestabilidad
social y política.
Qué cambios tenemos que hacer nosotros para
que nos lleven a mejor camino más adelante?
Y la cosa no es que si tú BAZ a a, a a
tomar la decisión o no la BAZ a tomar
implícitamente, sino la decisión es.
Qué les BAZ a dejar a tus hijos y a tus
nietos?
Ellos qué van a decidir?
En fin.
Hay mucho que hacer y hay que ser optimistas,
pero no pendejos.
Muchas gracias.
Bienvenidos a Jalmo 28 y vámonos para
adelante.
>> Muchas gracias, señor Salinas.
Realmente un viaje larguísimo.
Y ahora nos toca escuchar a Agustín
Laje con el tema La batalla
Cultural.
Vamos a darle la bienvenida, por favor,
Maestro, Muchas gracias.
>> Muchas gracias.
Bueno, muy buenos días para todos.
Es un honor para mí acompañarles esta mañana.
Gracias Don Ricardo por la
invitación, eh?
Veo que acá hay un gran compromiso de más con
el tema del que me toca exponer el día de
hoy, que es la batalla cultural.
Eh, Antes de arrancar un breve comentario
sobre mí, yo me llamo Agustín Laje, soy de
Argentina, soy licenciado en Ciencia
Política, Máster en Filosofía, Doctorando en
Filosofía.
Me dedico a escribir libros de filosofía
política, Eh!
Tengo una raíz en algo vinculado con el grupo
que es Caminos de la Libertad.
Participé muchos años en el concurso de
ensayos que hacían para jóvenes desde Caminos
de la Libertad, un una fundación que conocí a
través de las redes, a través de Internet,
allá por el año 2010 o 2011.
Vine en cinco oportunidades a México por
premios de Ensayos de Caminos de la Libertad,
Así que es un honor para mí estar acá, porque
mis raíces están allá.
Digo, a veces uno esparce las semillas,
no sabe cuáles van a germinar.
Bueno, en mi caso, créanme que Caminos de la
Libertad significó muchísimo para todo lo que
vino después.
Qué es lo que vino después?
Yo me dedico a impulsar las ideas de la
libertad a nivel continental.
De hecho, mañana me tengo que ir a Colombia,
donde tenemos elecciones el 31 de mayo.
A impulsar a nuestro hombre allí, que es
Abelardo de la Espriella.
Y después paso a México, donde tendremos la
segunda vuelta también dentro de muy poco
tiempo, en junio y en Argentina tengo un rol
relacionado con los esfuerzos que está
haciendo Javier Milei, con quien tengo
amistad desde hace más de una década.
Yo soy director de la Fundación Faro, que es
el tanque de pensamiento que le brinda las
ideas al gobierno libertario y que da en
Argentina lo que llamamos batalla cultural,
que es el tema del cual vamos a hablar en
este momento.
El clicker me lo dijiste.
Ahí está.
Gracias.
El término batalla cultural está, mmm,
articulando los esfuerzos de la reacción
contra los zurdos de.
Cito, eh?
En todas partes.
No solamente aquí en México.
El tema batalla cultural es un tema, sino que
se ha expandido por por todo Occidente.
La expresión se usa en Estados Unidos se usa
muchísimo en Argentina se usa en España se
usa en las más diversas latitudes.
Hay una especie de conciencia que ha empezado
a tomar la derecha de que si primero no gana
la cultura, entonces el camino hacia las
urnas estará realmente muy complicado.
Por lo tanto, lo primero que propongo esta
mañana es reflexionar sobre el contenido del
concepto.
Qué significa batalla cultural?
A qué nos referimos cuando decimos que hay
que librar la batalla cultural?
La expresión invoca un concepto muy, muy
difícil que es el de cultura.
Cultura es tan difícil como concepto que hace
algunos años a la Universidad de Oxford se le
ocurrió publicar un libro donde compilaran
todos los sentidos, todos los significados
más disímiles que tenía la palabra cultura en
los más diversos contextos.
Y al final les quedó un libro muy voluminoso
que recogía alrededor de 800 significados
distintos, con lo cual eso ya te marca un un
problema.
Y es el problema que hablamos de batalla
cultural.
Pero la batalla cultural tiene que
especificar un concepto muy difícil que es el
de cultura.
Qué significa cultura?
Bueno, yo me tomé el trabajo de estudiarme
estos conceptos de este manual de Oxford y
tratar de agruparlo en en tres distintas
acepciones en tres grandes familias de
conceptos.
Vamos a estudiar rápidamente el concepto
cultura a través de tres grandes significados
que tiene el concepto.
La palabra cultura se empieza a utilizar muy
especialmente en la Europa del siglo 18, en
la Europa de lo que llaman el siglo de las
Luces.
Los ilustrados usaban la palabra cultura
evocando la idea de cultivo claro.
Del latín viene cultura colere, que significa
cultivar, que es el cultivo es el esfuerzo
sobre la tierra para que la tierra rinda
fruto.
Qué es la cultura?
Es el esfuerzo sobre el espíritu humano para
que el espíritu humano rinda fruto en
términos de tres cosas fundamentalmente
razón, voluntad y belleza.
La cultura se abre a la inteligencia.
La cultura encamina la voluntad y la cultura
apunta también hacia la belleza.
Los ilustrados entonces tenían esta
definición de cultura que en cierta forma la
seguimos utilizando nosotros en ciertos
contextos.
Cuando decimos, por ejemplo, Juancito es muy
culto y Pedrito es muy inculto, estamos
pensando en términos de un concepto ilustrado
de cultura.
Se puede tener más cultura o menos cultura en
términos de que en términos del desarrollo de
la inteligencia, la voluntad y del gusto,
podemos hacernos una idea de que si Juancito
es muy culto es probablemente porque tenga
una gran afición por artes finas, por
determinado tipo de literatura.
Posea cierto conocimiento histórico, cierta
amplitud de miras.
Y cuando pensamos en Pedrito, que es muy
inculto, se nos viene a la cabeza un tipo que
está jugando todo el día 1 videojuego, por
ejemplo.
Claro, estamos pensando en términos de
cultura como concepto ilustrado, pero luego,
en el siglo 19, aparecieron unos sujetos
llamados antropólogos y muy poquito después
sociólogos que plantearon otro concepto de
cultura para los antropólogos y los
sociólogos Cultura, en lugar de significar
una jerarquía que apuntara a la inteligencia,
a la voluntad y el gusto significaba
simplemente todo aquello que heredamos de un
contexto social, pensando al ser humano como
un animal cultural.
Qué significa ser un animal cultural?
Bueno, estar partido por una determinación
biológica.
El ser humano es una criatura natural en la
medida en que está determinado
biológicamente, pero tiene una amplitud que
le permite su desarrollo cultural y la
cultura.
En ese sentido evoca una serie de
componentes que van a ver y estudiar
tanto los antropólogos como los
sociólogos, tales como el lenguaje, los
signos, las historias, los mitos, los
ritos, las costumbres, los valores, toda
una serie de cuestiones intangibles que
hacen a un grupo social.
Por eso los antropólogos que descubrieron
este concepto lo hicieron cuando, cuando
desde Europa se iban a estudiar tribus y
grupos exóticos y notaban que allí el modo de
vida era muy diferente y a todo lo que era
diferente lo bautizaron con el término, con
el concepto cultura.
Qué es cultura entonces?
Es nuestra herencia social, es lo que
recibimos de nuestra vivencia social para
ordenar nuestra vida y nuestra conducta.
Y luego hay otro concepto de cultura que es
también sumamente frecuente al día de hoy,
que es la acepción estética.
La idea de cultura como un ámbito donde se
desarrollan ciertas actividades culturales.
Aquí, por ejemplo, entra desde la música
hasta el arte, pasando por la danza, la
pintura, la literatura, las expresiones que
se regulan, por ejemplo, en política, a
través de lo que llamaríamos un Ministerio de
Cultura.
Cuando pensamos en un Ministerio de Cultura
estamos pensando en el concepto estético de
cultura.
Ustedes me dirán bueno, está bien.
Tenemos tres grandes conceptos de cultura,
pero acá veníamos a hablar de batalla
cultural, no simplemente de cultura.
En efecto, cuando le agregamos el concepto
de batalla al concepto cultura se nos
desprende esto.
Y es que cada definición de cultura
implica un tipo de medio y por lo
tanto un tipo de disputa distinta.
Decíamos el concepto ilustrado de cultura.
Qué tipo de instituciones están en relación
con este concepto?
Bueno, la literatura, las escuelas, las
universidades, los grupos intelectuales.
Ahí se van a desarrollar dos tipos de
batallas culturales muy importantes que las
podemos llamar de esta forma batalla por las
ideas y batalla por la historia.
Y hay que preguntarse estamos ganando la
batalla por las ideas?
Nuestras ideas son las que dominan en el
entorno social o nuestras ideas son
absolutamente minoritarias?
La batalla por la historia.
Nosotros somos los que estamos relatando el
pasado o aquellos que tienen una visión
totalmente antagónica a la nuestra.
En política son los que están escribiendo la
historia.
Vale la pena pelear por la historia?
Un George Orwell, por ejemplo, 1984, le
hubiese dicho es absolutamente necesario,
porque quien controla el presente controla el
pasado y quien controla el pasado controla el
futuro.
Modificar los relatos históricos significa
modificar la identidad actual de un pueblo
que echa raíces en su pasado y por lo tanto,
le condiciona en el futuro.
La gran pregunta es estamos dando una batalla
por la historia o la historia que dado
también en manos de aquellos que están en
nuestras antípodas?
Decíamos que los antropólogos y los
sociólogos tenían su propio concepto de
cultura también, del cual se desprendían una
serie de elementos, símbolos, costumbres,
tradiciones, lenguaje, valores.
De allí se desprenden otros dos tipos de
batallas culturales sobre las que también
tenemos que reflexionar en qué situación nos
encontramos.
Una de ellas, que es imprescindible, es la
batalla por el lenguaje.
Me encantó cómo cerró Don Salinas cuando
dijo La palabra mala es la igualdad.
La palabra buena es la libertad.
Claro, porque no se puede tener al mismo
tiempo las dos.
Hay un trade off entre igualdad y libertad,
pero nuestra comunidad política cuál valora
más y qué entiende por libertad?
Y qué entiende por igualdad?
Es el discurso de la libertad el que impera
en el lenguaje político o es el discurso de
la igualdad?
Qué solicita la gente?
Qué entiende por cada uno de estos conceptos?
Esa batalla por el lenguaje en Argentina la
dimos, por ejemplo, frente al concepto de
justicia social.
Esa fue una batalla durísima, porque la
justicia social estaba tan metida en el ADN
del pueblo argentino a través del peronismo,
que es el partido de la justicia social que
nos costó horrores poder convertirla en una
palabra negativa y hoy ya nadie la quiere
utilizar.
Eso es una batalla por el lenguaje enmarcada
en lo que llamamos de forma genérica una
batalla cultural.
Y además hay algo que también me gusta mucho,
que es la batalla moral.
La batalla moral es una batalla por
determinar la escala de valores que predomina
en una población.
Cuáles son los valores imperantes en una
población?
Cuáles son los vicios imperantes?
También don Don Salinas hablaba del
resentimiento y de la envidia, el
resentimiento y la envidia es el vehículo más
rápido para llegar a la izquierda.
Es de hecho, la plataforma moral sobre la
cual la izquierda elabora su su su narrativa
política.
Hace poco hicimos en Argentina desde la
Fundación Faro una investigación que nos dio
unos resultados maravillosos, precisamente
pensando en términos de batalla moral,
hicimos una encuesta muy representativa, con
una muy buena muestra y le preguntábamos a la
gente le hacíamos un test de envidia sin que
se dieran cuenta, pero eran todas palabras
para irle midiendo la envidia.
Le medíamos la envidia a la gente, le
medíamos el resentimiento.
A la gente le medíamos su apego a
las normas, le medíamos su
tendencia a la meritocracia y le
medíamos su autoestima.
Y después le preguntábamos por su
posicionamiento político, ideológico y los
resultados fueron brutales.
Cuanto más a la izquierda te ibas, tenías más
envidia, tenías más resentimiento, tenías
menos respeto por la norma, tenías menos
sentido de la meritocracia y tenías más baja
la autoestima cuando te ibas más hacia la
derecha, la función era exactamente la
inversa.
Y qué hacemos en esos casos?
Salimos a la prensa y mostramos Miren, acá no
solamente se trata de política, acá se trata
de valores éticos y morales que están
involucrados en un posicionamiento político.
Eso es una forma, entre tantas otras, de
dar una batalla moral.
Y por último, decíamos también en su acepción
estética, la cultura tiene una serie de
instituciones o de espacios de expresión La
música, las artes audiovisuales, las artes
plásticas, etcétera Esto es lo que podemos
denominar la batalla por el arte.
Miren, yo creo que ese es el peor escenario
en el cual nosotros hoy estamos parados.
Creo que la batalla de ideas, la cosa no está
tan mal, La batalla por la historia más o
menos tenemos conciencia de eso.
Batalla por el lenguaje, batalla por la
moral.
Estamos ahí, pero la batalla por el arte
está muy, muy difícil.
Habitualmente los artistas tienen además
una.
Una tendencia casi estructural hacia el
socialismo, porque la inmensa mayoría de
ellos vive del Estado, no del mundo privado.
Entonces eso es un gran condicionamiento para
que a la hora de escoger un posicionamiento
político, la batalla por el arte es, yo
personalmente en la que en la que menos
éxitos he conseguido.
Uno tiene.
Para esto sirve este análisis, para empezar a
desagregar las cosas y ponerle contenido a
los conceptos y empezar a pensar cómo cada
uno está parado en cada uno de este tipo de
batallas culturales.
Y nosotros en Argentina hemos descubierto que
el poder se articula de esta manera, o por lo
menos esta es nuestra teoría del poder con el
gobierno de Javier Milei, nosotros
conseguimos tres grandes tipos de batallas la
batalla política, la batalla por la gestión y
la batalla cultural.
La realidad es que las tres tienen que estar
presentes.
Si uno hace batalla política, llega
al gobierno.
Tiene una muy buena gestión, pero abandona la
batalla cultural que tiene como resultado
Chile del 2019.
Chile del 2019 tenía un gobierno
políticamente estable, tenía un gobierno
económicamente robusto y sin embargo tuvo una
verdadera revolución que terminó en Gabriel
Boric después de dos intentos de Asamblea
Constituyente fallidos.
Gracias a Dios.
Pero lo tuvieron.
Al contrario, si uno tiene, por ejemplo,
Batalla cultural pero no tiene batalla
política, puede cambiar el entorno.
Pero al final los candidatos políticos van a
ser de los otros y eso tarde o temprano se va
a caer porque los otros ponen la maquinaria
del Estado para hacer batalla cultural y con
eso siempre nos sacan ventaja.
O uno puede hacer otra cosa, puede hacer
batalla cultural, batalla política llega al
poder, pero su gestión es un desastre.
Si su gestión es un desastre, te hundís
porque porque no tenés resultados concretos.
A la gente hay que darle resultados concretos
en dos materias que son fundamentales
siempre, en todo momento y en todo lugar.
La economía y la seguridad, la economía y
la seguridad.
Lo otro, lo invisible.
Fíjense que ambas cosas son muy tangibles.
Digo yo toco un billete y toco un arma.
Ahora yo no toco una costumbre, no toco un
valor, no toco un lenguaje.
No, no, no toco una palabra, no toco una
historia.
Esta es la maravilla de la batalla cultural
que trata de todas aquellas cosas invisibles
que, sin embargo, constituyen la estructura
sobre la cual los resultados surgen.
Pero si no me surgen resultados, entonces voy
a perder el poder.
Son las tres aristas las que tienen que
estar siempre arriba.
Yo les decía la derecha o las nuevas derechas
están empezando a ganar posición en muchos
países.
Argentina.
Tiene ha sido paradigmático en esto.
En virtud de esta estrategia, Sí, pero este
no es un descubrimiento de la derecha.
Al contrario, la batalla cultural es un
descubrimiento de la izquierda cuando cuando
descubre la izquierda, la batalla cultural
la descubre en el marco de la década del 30
del siglo pasado, década del 40 del siglo
pasado.
Pero para entender esto hay que rápidamente
entender un poquito de lo que podemos llamar
hoy ya la vieja izquierda, la izquierda del
marxismo, del marxismo clásico.
Esto que puse en pantalla es una, es un
extracto del Manifiesto Comunista escrito en
1008 48 por Karl Marx y Federico Engels.
Dice así El proletariado se servirá de su
supremacía política para arrancar poco a poco
todo el capital de la burguesía, para
centralizar todos los instrumentos de
producción en manos del Estado.
Esto, naturalmente, no podrá cumplirse al
principio, sino por una violación despótica
del derecho de propiedad y de las relaciones
burguesas de producción, es decir, mediante
la adopción de medidas que parecerán
económicamente insostenibles, pero que en el
curso del movimiento se sobrepasarán y son
indispensables como medio para transformar
por completo el modo de producción.
Acá está hablando de cultura.
Marx está diciendo tenemos que conquistar el
mundo de las ideas, del lenguaje, del arte,
de la música, de la historia.
No está hablando de algo tan tan tangible
como la propiedad y como la economía.
Para el marxismo clásico.
Y está hablando de la violencia política.
Para el marxismo clásico la cuestión era muy
sencilla hacer una revolución armada, tomar
el poder, expropiar al empresario,
centralizar los medios de producción en el
Estado y llevar al proletariado al poder.
Tanto así que esto continúa.
De este modo los comunistas rechazan ocultar
sus opiniones y sus proyectos.
Proclaman abiertamente que sus propósitos no
pueden ser alcanzados sino por el
derrumbamiento violento de todo el orden
social tradicional.
De acá surge la revolución rusa, pero
también surge la Revolución cubana.
Por ejemplo, las guerras de guerrillas en
América Latina, las revoluciones del este
europeo, la revolución china, que son
revoluciones violentas, donde se toma con las
armas el poder del Estado y se modifica el
sistema económico, el marxismo tradicional,
la vieja izquierda era una doctrina
revolucionaria sobre la economía, no sobre la
cultura.
De hecho, para esta gente la cultura era
epifenoménica.
Qué significa esto?
Que la cultura.
Era un simple fantasma que se creaba casi
que automáticamente para proteger la
realidad material que es la economía.
El contenido de la fe, por ejemplo, apuntaba
a aquietar al pobre, a darle una esperanza no
en esta tierra, sino en el más allá.
Pero por qué?
Porque en esta tierra era parte de la clase
explotada.
La cultura para el marxismo es siempre un
dato secundario, subordinado a una
realidad material llamada economía.
Pero esto que parecía tan fuerte como
doctrina política, empieza a hacer aguas
en Europa occidental y empieza a hacer
aguas.
En primer lugar en Italia.
En Italia hay un señor llamado Antonio
Gramsci.
No sé si alguien lo habrá escuchado alguna
vez.
Antonio Gramsci, líder del Partido Comunista
italiano, filósofo, estaba muy esperanzado de
que la Revolución rusa se replicara en Italia
por el determinismo histórico del marxismo.
Se suponía No voy a entrar en esto porque
sería muy largo, pero el marxismo se concebía
como una ley de la historia.
Es decir, era necesaria la revolución y tarde
o temprano, por las contradicciones del
sistema capitalista, iba a llegar a todas
partes.
Gramsci se creyó este cuento, se creyó en
este fatalismo político y él creía
verdaderamente que muy pronto Italia iba a
tener una revolución comunista.
Y lo que llegó no fue una revolución
comunista, Fue Mussolini.
Y Mussolini lo termina poniendo preso a
Gramsci.
Y Gramsci termina escribiendo en la cárcel
sus famosos cuadernos de las cárceles, donde
empieza a reflexionar y dice Cuidado, Nos
olvidamos de la cultura.
Acá apostamos por una vía violenta.
Pensábamos que esto era realmente lo que
había que hacer.
Pero hay otra vía que es la vía de la
cultura, Dice Gramsci.
Así lo cito Un grupo social puede y debe ser
dirigente, es decir, ejercer una dirección
intelectual y moral Ya antes de conquistar el
poder gubernamental.
Esta es una de las condiciones principales
para la conquista del poder.
Después, cuando ejerce el poder y aunque lo
tenga fuertemente en sus manos, se vuelve
dominante, pero debe seguir siendo dirigente.
Esto es una forma de decir lo que Ricardo
dijo recién cuando dijo Primero hay que ganar
la batalla cultural para poder ganar la
batalla electoral.
Gramsci dice exactamente lo mismo El grupo
social puede y debe ser dirigente antes de
conquistar el poder gubernamental.
Que qué significa?
Significa que imprime en el grueso de la
sociedad sus valores, sus costumbres, sus
historias, sus aspiraciones.
Gramsci termina muriendo en la cárcel, pero
su legado filosófico político lo va a tomar
algo llamado socialismo del siglo 21.
En nuestra región.
Pero no voy a entrar en eso ya sin antes
contarle otra experiencia de transformación
dentro del marxismo, que fue la de los
señores de la derecha.
Lo de los señores de la derecha se llaman
Escuela de Frankfurt.
La Escuela de Frankfurt surge en Alemania a
principios del siglo 20.
En el año, en el año 1922 y también
esperando la revolución alemana.
Después se les presenta la situación de
que quien sube al poder es Hitler y con
un Hitler en el poder.
Qué hacen estos señores?
Se escapan hacia Rusia.
>> De norteamericana.
No hablemos tanto de economía.
Empecemos a hablar de familia, de
sexualidad, de cultura, de arte, de
música.
Hay que ir metiendo una cosmovisión de
izquierdas en esos dominios.
Uno de ellos, uno de los más importantes.
Horkheimer.
Max Horkheimer, lo decía de este modo
Atención.
Dice así Toda cultura resulta incluida en la
dinámica histórica.
Sus dominios.
Es decir, los hábitos, los usos, las
costumbres, el arte, la religión, la
filosofía, constituyen en su entrelazamiento
los factores dinámicos que en cada caso
contribuyen a mantener o destruir una forma
determinada de sociedad.
Claro, yo con usos, costumbres, hábitos,
religión, filosofía, historias, puedo unir a
una sociedad o lo puedo hacer volar por los
aires.
Todas las instituciones y los procesos en
todos los dominios de la cultura, en tanto
actúan sobre el carácter y los actos de los
hombres, aparecen como momentos de
conservación o bien de disolución de la
dinámica social y, según los casos,
constituyen la argamasa de un edificio
todavía en construcción.
La masilla que reúne artificialmente partes
que tienden a separarse o una parte del
explosivo que destroza el todo con la primera
chispa.
Esto es impresionante porque tiene poco que
ver con el viejo Marx.
Marx decía algo muy simple revolución
violenta se toma el Estado, se modifica el
sistema económico.
Punto final.
Estos tipos están diciendo no, cuidado.
La violencia puede darse en el ámbito de la
cultura.
Tenemos que primero desarmar culturalmente a
la sociedad.
En Occidente, para después allanar el camino
y tomar el poder.
Hay un gran cambio estratégico en la
izquierda que se termina expresando en un
acontecimiento histórico muy significativo.
En Francia, en mayo de 1968.
En mayo de 1988, por primera vez no eran los
obreros de izquierdas los que generaban una
revuelta en las calles, sino que eran los
estudiantes universitarios.
La izquierda empezó a cambiar la fábrica
por la cátedra universitaria al obrero,
por el estudiante y el profesor cambió
el modo de hacer la revolución.
Mientras tanto, nosotros en América
Latina no estábamos en esta onda.
Si bien es cierto hubo revueltas
estudiantiles, las hubo en Argentina y demás
en esta misma época, ciertamente.
Pero el modo de acceder al poder en la década
del 60, 70 y 80 en América Latina continuó
siendo estrictamente marxista leninista, es
decir, guerras de guerrillas, revoluciones
violentas como tuvieron éxito en un único
lugar en realidad, que fue Cuba, que se
convirtió en un centro de exportación de este
modelo que fracasó en todas partes.
Pero luego llegó 1989, se cayó el Muro de
Berlín.
Hubo un gran exitismo.
Poco después, cuando en 1991, la Unión.
La Unión Soviética implosionó y quedó la
sensación en el mundo de que había un único
sistema que no solamente había triunfado en
esta disputa que llamamos Guerra Fría, sino
que iba a perdurar para siempre, que no iba a
tener nunca un desafío significativo en lo
que siguiera de la historia.
Ese sistema se llama capitalismo liberal,
articulado con democracia liberal.
El hombre que mejor encarna este exitismo en
Occidente fue un filósofo llamado Francis
Fukuyama.
Fukuyama escribe en 1989 un paper muy citado,
muy importante para su época, que lleva el
título de The End of History y dice lo
siguiente Lo que podríamos estar presenciando
no es solo el fin de la Guerra Fría o el paso
de un período particular de la historia de
posguerra, sino el fin de la historia como
tal, es decir, el punto final de la evolución
ideológica de la humanidad y la
universalización de la democracia occidental
como forma final de gobierno.
Miren ustedes la escatología que supone este
párrafo, la idea de que la historia se
desenvuelve hacia un estadio final y
definitivo, que no es el del socialismo que
acaba de derribarse, sino que es el del
capitalismo de libre empresa y el gobierno
democrático limitado.
Esto con el diario del lunes sabemos que
fue una pavada, pero esto marcó el ánimo
y reflejó el ánimo al cierre de la
Guerra Fría.
Y fue una pavada que muchos no se hubieran
dado cuenta que al mismo tiempo que
Fukuyama escribía estas cosas y era
celebrado en los Estados Unidos en 1990, se
producía esto en Brasil.
Esta es la primera reunión del Foro de Sao
Pablo, una un grupo internacional, un foro
internacional creado por Fidel Castro y un
ignoto para esa época, el señor Lula da
Silva, hoy presidente de Brasil, que tenía
por objetivo lo siguiente Habiendo visto la
crisis de la izquierda a partir de su derrota
en la Guerra Fría, había que preservar a la
izquierda latinoamericana y había que
replantear la estrategia política.
Ya se había visto que en los 60, 70 y 80 la
guerra de guerrillas, salvo en Cuba, no dio
resultado en ningún otro lugar.
No lo dio ni en Chile, ni en Argentina ni en
Perú.
No lo dio en ningún lugar, salvo Cuba.
Y encima Cuba se queda sin su espónsor
número uno, su sponsor económico.
Cuba siempre ha vivido de sponsors
internacionales.
Miren lo que le está pasando ahora, sino
desde que cayó Nicolás Maduro en ese momento
era la Unión Soviética.
Por eso, ni lerdo ni perezoso, Fidel Castro
en 1990 organiza esto.
Qué es esto?
Es un foro que reúne partidos políticos de
izquierda, sindicatos de izquierdas, grupos
guerrilleros de izquierdas, movimientos
sociales de izquierdas, grupos de derechos
humanos, izquierdas como Madres y Abuelas de
Plaza de Mayo, por ejemplo.
Grupos indigenistas mexicanos que fueron allí
tanto en esta edición como en muchas otras,
las guerrillas del ELN, las guerrillas de las
Farc.
Hay que juntar todo lo que vaya por izquierda
en un foro internacional latinoamericano para
redefinir una estrategia y estrategia.
Fue sumamente exitosa.
Del Foro de Sao Pablo van a salir muchos
presidentes.
Miren ustedes, Lula da Silva, Dilma
Rousseff en Brasil, el matrimonio
Kirchner.
O sea, por dos en Argentina.
Rafael Correa en Ecuador, Daniel Ortega en
Nicaragua, también vinculado al Foro de Sao
Pablo, Evo Morales, que ahora está queriendo
hacer un golpe de Estado en Bolivia, es el
fruto del Foro de Sao Paulo, Por supuesto.
Hugo Chávez y su sucesor, Nicolás Maduro.
Y ahora veremos qué pasa con Delcy, también
del Foro de Sao Pablo.
En Paraguay estuvo Lugo, que duró poco en el
poder, pero también provenía del Foro de Sao
Pablo.
Como ven ustedes, el Foro de Sao Pablo ha
dado muchos presidentes a la región, pero
ese mismo foro de Sao Pablo entró en una
cierta crisis allí por el año 2015.
En el año 2015 tuvimos un respiro del Foro de
Sao Pablo.
Por qué?
Bueno, porque pronto ganaría Trump en Estados
Unidos, Bolsonaro en Brasil en el 2018,
Piñera en Chile, en Colombia, Iván Duque, un
hombre de Uribe en Perú, la gente del Foro de
Sao Paulo nunca había hecho todavía pie y en
México todavía López Obrador no había ganado.
Pero todo esto empezó a cambiar cuando López
Obrador ganó.
Por qué?
Porque advirtieron rápido la crisis y crearon
algo distinto llamado Grupo de Puebla y
reorganizaron a la izquierda continental en
Puebla, a partir del año 2019 y a partir del
año 2019 empezás a tener un avance brutal de
la izquierda nuevamente en toda la región,
ganando en países donde antes nunca había
ganado el Foro de Sao Paulo, entre ellos
Perú, con Pedro Castillo.
Se acuerdan?
Chile con Gabriel Boric y
Colombia.
Gustavo Petro.
Tenemos elecciones ahora el 31 de mayo.
Por cierto.
para el año 2023.
Este es el mapa de nuestra región.
El rojo simboliza izquierda, el
azul vamos a decir derecha o
centro derecha.
No me animo ni siquiera a decirle derecha.
Pero bueno, miren lo que es la hegemonía
total y completa, incluyendo a Estados Unidos
en manos del Partido Demócrata más
radicalizado de la historia y Canadá en las
manos de un progresista globalista llamado
Trudeau.
Cuando uno miraba esto decía acá no hay
ninguna salida.
Y sin embargo, a fines del año 2023 ya hay
una primera victoria de la derecha libertaria
en Argentina en segunda vuelta, de la mano de
Javier Milei.
Luego va a venir una nueva victoria de Bukele
en El Salvador.
Luego tendremos victoria de Noboa
en Ecuador, Victoria en Honduras,
Victoria en Bolivia.
Y este es el mapa victoria de Trump.
Por cierto, en Estados Unidos.
Y este es el mapa
actual 2026.
Esto a mí me da esperanza porque significa
que hay vientos que están soplando por
derecha.
Las motivaciones son múltiples.
No puedo ahora entrar en ello, simplemente yo
quería hacer rápido una genealogía de la
izquierda rápidamente desde Marx hasta hoy,
con resultados políticos clarísimos.
Qué aplicó?
El Foro de Sao Paulo?
Aplicó las técnicas de Gramsci y las
técnicas de Frankfurt que terminaron
en algo llamado Agenda Woke.
Han escuchado esta expresión woke
wokismo, agenda, woke, cultura, Woke
es un término muy nuevo.
Nos viene desde Estados Unidos.
Está vinculado a la idea de despertarse.
Los woke serían aquellos que se han
despertado.
Despertado a qué?
A las opresiones que existen en las
estructuras más profundas de nuestra
sociedad.
El woke, que es una expresión radical de
la izquierda cultural, que tiene sus
raíces más profundas en la Escuela de
Frankfurt, supone que la vida social
distribuye a opresores y oprimidos en
todas las categorías posibles de la
existencia grupal e individual.
Para la vieja izquierda la cuestión era muy
simple era económica.
El opresor es el empresario, el oprimido es
el trabajador.
Punto final para el woke, El opresor y
el oprimido pueden tomar un montón de
rostros distintos y amplían de esta
forma su estrategia política, girando
hacia lo que ellos denominan las
minorías oprimidas.
Este cuadro sintetiza algunas de las más
exitosas dialécticas Woke.
Claro, los seres humanos tenemos sexo.
En torno al sexo surgen dos.
A uno le digo oprimido y al otro le digo
opresor.
Y ya tenemos algo llamado feminismo.
El hombre se lo pensó.
La mujer es la oprimida y el sistema de
opresión se llama patriarcado.
Incorporó la dialéctica opresor y oprimido
que antes era exclusiva del ámbito económico.
Ahora lo meto en el sistema sexual.
Pero también dicen hay algo llamado
orientación de género, según la cual se puede
ser heterosexual u homosexual.
Bueno, esto también es muy simple el
heterosexual es opresor, el homosexual es
oprimido, el sistema de opresión se llama
heteronormatividad y la militancia política
resultante de esta ideología se llama
movimiento lgbtqi+.
Pero la gente también puede tener una
identidad de género, que es la identidad
autopercibida.
Ustedes tienen, tengo entendido, algunos
jueces, incluso con identidades
autopercibidas.
Y aquí se puede ser cisgénero o
transgénero.
Ustedes miran qué cisgénero?
Bueno, el transgénero es aquel que se
autopercibe con una sexualidad que no se
corresponde con su realidad biológica.
Y qué es el cisgénero cisgénero?
Era lo que antes llamábamos una persona
normal, es decir, una persona que se
autopercibe con el cuerpo tal como es.
Y esto genera un sistema de opresión llamado
cisnormatividad y genera a su vez una
militancia política llamada militancia queer
o la militancia de la ideología de género.
La gente también tiene raza y aquí es muy
fácil también el opresor es el blanco, el
oprimido es el negro y el sistema de opresión
se llama racismo.
Y los movimientos políticos que resultan se
pueden llamar desde blacklivesmatter a lo que
ustedes quieran.
Por ejemplo, los combates contra las unidades
que en Argentina, que no hay afroamericanos
prácticamente, lo cual motivó una queja de
Washington Post en el último Mundial porque
decían por qué no hay más negros en la
Selección argentina?
Y es que el censo de Argentina.
Tenemos menos de un 1% de afroamericanos.
Pero esto le molestaba a la prensa de Estados
Unidos y entonces el gobierno kirchnerista se
inventó la idea de luchar contra las marrón
idades.
Porque bueno, si no hay negros pero sí hay
marrones, entonces a los marrones también se
los discrimina.
Tenemos, por supuesto, no sé, religión.
El cristianismo es la religión de los
opresores.
Todo el resto de religiones o no religiones,
son las posiciones de los oprimidos.
El sistema de opresión se llama
fundamentalismo religioso.
Tenemos una nacionalidad, el nacional del
Estado en el que vive el opresor.
Respecto del inmigrante que llegó al país que
uno vive y esto se llama xenofobia, Tenemos
temas étnicos.
Quien tiene ascendencia europea es opresor
respecto de aquel que tiene ascendencia
indígena.
Esto se llama neocolonialismo y la militancia
resultante se llama indigenismo.
Tenemos incluso algo que aquí en México se ha
puesto también de moda, que es la lucha
contra la gordofobia.
No sé si lo han escuchado eso.
Ahora resulta que también el mundo está
dividido en gordos y flacos y el flaco oprime
al gordo.
También tenemos temas de belleza.
Entonces aquellos que son más bellos son
opresores de aquellos que son más feos.
Y el sistema de opresión se llama belleza
hegemónica.
Y así, en general, tenemos opresores y
oprimidos por doquier.
Allí donde usted sea capaz de darle valor a
una categoría social o individual, puede
dividir al mundo entre opresores y oprimidos.
Y cuál es el chiste de todo esto?
Por qué todo esto le gusta tanto a la
izquierda?
Muy simple.
Porque allí donde haya un oprimido, el Estado
es la solución para su emancipación.
Necesitamos entonces leyes de género, leyes
de raza, leyes de etnias, ampliar los curules
en el Congreso, diversidad, discriminación
positiva, regulaciones, intromisiones,
censuras, organismos para luchar contra la
discriminación.
Necesitamos políticos.
El político está encantado con la cultura
porque es su combustible.
Es aquella ideología que le requiere para
liberar minorías de oprimidos.
Fíjense ustedes que funcional que es esto
Entonces para aquellos que tienen apetito de
no recortar el gasto público, sino al
contrario, incrementarlo cada vez más,
entonces la izquierda actual es esta
combinación de socialismo del siglo 21, de
ideología woke de algo llamado también
globalismo, que no tengo tiempo para entrar
ahora en eso, pero es básicamente el dominio
que empiezan a ejercer desde los.
Desde el ámbito de los organismos
internacionales.
Y frente a eso ya les
anticipaba hoy una hay una
nueva derecha, hay una, hay
una nueva derecha que ha
surgido como reacción y que
sin embargo tiene.
Casos de éxito, con más o con menos, como en
todo, pero casos de éxito al fin.
Hay algunos exponentes que quizás ustedes
conocen de esta nueva derecha.
He puesto algunos en pantalla.
Los vamos a analizar muy rápidamente, De
izquierda a derecha tenemos a José Antonio
Kast, que acaba de asumir como presidente en
Chile.
Y fíjense, yo quiero ver, quiero hacer foco
en una cosa muy importante, que es por qué le
llamamos Nueva derecha.
Qué tiene esto de nuevo?
En primer lugar, prácticamente todos
ellos han creado espacios políticos
nuevos.
José Antonio Kast, por ejemplo, venía de la
UDI, que era la derecha tradicional, digamos,
el pan de aquí más o menos.
Pero el tipo se hartó de la corrección
política.
Y fíjense que en todos los casos la cosa es
bastante similar.
Se hartó de la disolución de los
principios de la UDI y creó su propio
partido político.
El Partido Republicano, desde donde él
dio batalla cultural durante muchos
años empezó a crecer políticamente.
Las elecciones del 2021 las perdió
en segunda vuelta, pero las del año
pasado las ganó por mucho, casi por
diez puntos.
En segunda vuelta y hoy preside
Chile.
Por qué lo eligió la gente a José Antonio
Kast?
Fundamentalmente por temas de seguridad.
Yo les voy a ir contando todas estas cosas,
porque ahora entramos después de hablar de
izquierdas.
Ahora estoy intentando hablar de derechas
para tratar de ver qué similitudes hay con
México, que entiendo que eso es lo que
verdaderamente importa.
Aquí hoy el tema seguridad se descarrió
en Chile, principalmente por el factor
migratorio y porque empezó a haber crimen
organizado.
En Chile se multiplicaron los secuestros,
creció como nunca el índice de homicidios, la
tasa de homicidios, robos, hurtos y cuando se
medía en Chile, quién era el gran referente
para los chilenos?
No salía ningún chileno, salía Bukele.
Frente a una situación así, evidentemente lo
que hizo José Antonio Kast fue muy
inteligente.
Planteó políticas de mano dura junto con todo
el paquete de cosas que a nosotros nos
interesan particularmente, pero que están
debajo de la estructura visible, lo que
llamamos batalla cultural.
La batalla cultural es una estructura que
está por debajo de lo que vemos
inmediatamente, que es inseguridad, pobreza,
desempleo, recesión, etcétera.
En Chile el asunto fue seguridad.
En Argentina la historia es bastante
similar.
Javier Milei surge por derecha porque lo que
había funcionado como centro centro derecha
en Argentina era una porquería, que era el
macrismo, el PRO, que cuando le tocó
gobernar se bajó los pantalones y le abrió
las puertas a todos aquellos que traían una
ideología totalmente contraria a la derecha.
Y así le fue a Macri.
Tuvimos cuatro años más de kirchnerismo.
Javier Milei armó un partido político nuevo.
Es decir, se puede llegar al poder
rápidamente con partidos políticos nuevos.
Y ganó las elecciones en segunda vuelta.
En el caso de Trump, ustedes me dirán Bueno,
pero Trump no creó un partido político nuevo,
se metió en el Partido Republicano Correcto.
Sin embargo, creó un movimiento nuevo dentro
del Partido Republicano Maga Make America
Great Again.
Bukele creó un nuevo partido político en El
Salvador.
Este señor que me interesa mucho que lo
tengan en cuenta.
Abelardo de la Espriella es un outsider en
Colombia, no tiene partido político y hoy
está segundo en las encuestas.
Pasaría si todo marcha bien a segunda vuelta.
Santiago Abascal, en España, creó un partido
político nuevo, Vox.
Tenemos a López Aliaga un poquito más allá,
que es el peruano, que le hicieron fraude.
Lamentablemente ahora no pasó a segunda
vuelta por 18.000 votos y lo hizo con un
partido político nuevo.
No voy a hablar ahora de Europa porque nos
vamos a perder, sino.
Pero estos son los casos de América que me
interesan y muy probablemente el hijo de
Bolsonaro, Flavio Bolsonaro, tiene muchas
posibilidades de ganar las elecciones.
Ya le ha sacado una gran ventaja a Lula y las
elecciones son este año en Brasil.
Esto es lo que llamamos nueva derecha, porque
tiene nuevas estructuras políticas, porque
tiene una nueva estrategia basada en la
batalla cultural y porque articula tres
posiciones, tres doctrinas distintas
libertarismo, es decir, reducir el Estado
conservadurismo, es decir, levantar las los
buenos valores, las buenas costumbres, las
buenas prácticas, las buenas instituciones de
la sociedad civil y soberanismo número tres o
Nacionalismo o soberanismo.
La idea de proteger la soberanía de la nación
frente a la intromisión de organismos
internacionales.
Eso articula lo que llamamos nueva
derecha, que como les digo, tiene
varias, varios casos de éxito en
distintas partes de la región y de
Europa.
También en Europa está creciendo muchísimo.
Ahora, en Inglaterra, por ejemplo, ahora
mismo.
La pregunta entonces es me quedan 15 minutos,
vamos a dedicarlo a esto?
Y entonces en México qué pasa?
Qué hay de México?
Miren, no les voy a mentir, México para mí es
el país más complicado en este momento.
Si yo tuviese que decir cuál es el país donde
la izquierda tiene mayor hegemonía en todo el
continente, yo no dudaría en decir México.
Ustedes me podrían decir no, bueno, pero
mira, en Cuba sí, pero Cuba está a días de
caer la dictadura castrista.
No sé si vieron ayer el mensaje de Marco
Rubio de Donald Trump, de la Casa Blanca.
Cuba está a días de caer.
Ustedes me van a decir bueno, pero entonces
Ortega en Nicaragua tiene un control mucho
más férreo.
Sí, pero a Cuba le va a seguir Nicaragua, así
como Cuba le siguió.
Venezuela.
Y por qué Cuba, Venezuela, Nicaragua?
Porque son dictaduras, o bien porque hicieron
fraude o bien porque maniataron de tal manera
el sistema electoral que nadie puede decir
que allí haya democracia y eso le permite a
Estados Unidos elaborar un discurso distinto.
Pero ese no es el escenario de México.
En México, Morena ganó con votos.
Por eso me parece muy importante lo que don
Ricardo dijo recién No podemos esperar que
sea Estados Unidos el que salve a México.
Mexico Los mexicanos tienen que
salvar a México y ojalá que
ciertamente con un una ventisca.
Con un viento a favor.
México es esto.
México se convirtió en el
epicentro de la izquierda
continental.
Este es el grupo de Puebla.
Esta foto es del año 2019, cuando lo habían
elegido Alberto Fernández, presidente del
Grupo de Puebla de aquí desde México está
surgiendo todo.
Miren, en los años 60,
70, 80 fue La Habana, en
los años 90, 2000 2010.
Fue Caracas, ahora es México.
Por eso es tan importante desarmarlo desde
aquí y por eso también es importante esta
pregunta, porque hay que responder con qué lo
vamos a desarmar.
Yo estoy convencido que para desarmar a la
izquierda se necesita derecha.
El centro se ha mostrado totalmente incapaz.
De sacar de juego a la izquierda.
Al contrario, cada vez que ha ganado el
centro, todo lo que ha hecho es correr el eje
ideológico hacia la izquierda, porque el
centro quedaba redefinido como derecha y por
lo tanto la izquierda podía radicalizarse aún
más hacia la izquierda.
Esto pasó en Chile con la experiencia de
Piñera.
Pasó en Colombia con la experiencia de Santos
y de Iván Duque.
También pasó en Argentina con la experiencia
de Macri.
Y posiblemente pasó aquí también con la
experiencia del PAN.
La pregunta es hay una derecha en México?
Yo respondería a los siguientes puntos.
México tiene una derecha sociológica, pero no
tiene una derecha política.
Qué significa una derecha sociológica?
Bueno, que hay sectores,
ámbitos, círculos, zonas donde
la población tiene en México
una tendencia a ver con buenos
ojos las ideas de las derechas.
Pero no hay oferta, no hay oferta
política.
Ustedes me van a decir bueno, el pan sí, pero
el PAN renunció a ser una derecha para
volverse oposición genérica y esto se vio
perfectamente en su alianza con otros
partidos con los cuales yo no compartía
absolutamente nada más allá de oponerse a
Morena.
Por lo tanto, todo lo que terminó teniendo el
pan para ofrecer es ser una opción contra
Morena.
Pero se desgastó ideológicamente.
Perdió sobre todo su dirigencia.
Yo no digo su militancia.
A mí me ha pasado, me ha tocado mucho dar
conferencias en instituciones del PAN y he
percibido en todos lados una gran frustración
de las bases respecto de la dirigencia.
La idea de que la dirigencia, la que abandona
progresivamente los principios, la derecha
mexicana, tiene un complejo de culpa.
Probablemente el complejo de culpa más grande
que yo haya visto en toda la región.
Yo por mes les decía más o menos visitó tres
países distintos impulsando estas ideas.
Yo estoy en mi casa solo la mitad del mes, la
otra mitad del mes estoy en cualquier otro
lugar.
Eso me ha permitido conocer muy bien la
política de toda América y el complejo de
culpa que he encontrado en la derecha
mexicana.
Nunca lo he visto ni en la derecha
colombiana, ni en la derecha peruana, ni en
la derecha argentina, ni en la derecha
chilena, mucho menos aquí.
Eso lo ha sabido explotar perfectamente bien
López Obrador.
Cuál era el gran enemigo de López Obrador?
El conservadurismo, o por lo menos ese era el
término que invocaba cada vez que quería
denostar a alguien en su programa de en su en
su programa, que siempre le digo al
presidente, pero a lo presidente era el de
Chávez.
Este es el mañanero, cierto?
Son un calco, un calco.
Es lo mismo.
Ahora lo hace con mucho menor destreza.
Por cierto, su sucesora.
En México, además, noto que la derecha
económica quedó desconectada de la derecha
cultural, que sería la derecha económica la
que le preocupan las recetas económicas libre
empresa, libre mercado, libertad contractual,
Respeto de la propiedad privada, reducción de
la carga impositiva, reducción del gasto
público.
Todo eso es muy, muy importante.
Pero no solo de números vive el hombre.
Los hombres hacemos cuentas, pero vivimos de
cuentos.
Y la derecha mexicana no ha tenido cuentos.
Por eso es muy importante amigar a los
libertarios con los conservadores y con el
nacionalismo de derecha que en este país, por
cierto, casi que no existe.
Lamentablemente tampoco.
Porque el nacionalismo, la idea patria,
lamentablemente, ha sido absorbida por la
izquierda.
Ese es un diagnóstico que yo haría a vuelo de
pájaro.
Para responder a la pregunta, México tiene
una derecha?
Bueno, según a qué le llamemos derecha,
sociológicamente hay una gran potencia en
México para tener una derecha, pero no hay
una derecha política.
Esa sería la respuesta genérica, Lo cual nos
lleva a otra pregunta Qué se necesita
entonces para formar una derecha en México?
Digo, si estamos de acuerdo, quizás que no,
pero si estamos de acuerdo de que para sacar
a la izquierda se necesita no centro sino
derecha, y que en México no hay una derecha
política, pues la respuesta la tenemos en
nuestras manos.
Qué hay que hacer?
Hacer una derecha política?
Pero cómo es la pregunta?
Miren, evidentemente esto
llevaría toda una conferencia
aparte, pero voy a tratar de dar
seis puntos que pueden marcar un
camino.
En primer lugar, y surge de lo anterior para
formar una derecha política, esa derecha se
tiene que atrever a llamarse derecha.
Suena obvio, pero no lo es.
Generalmente la derecha tiene complejo de
culpa y por lo tanto empieza a ocultar su
verdadera identidad política.
Pero quién no reivindica su identidad
política queda a merced a las caricaturas que
le construye su adversario político?
Yo no digo que se llame el partido de la
derecha.
Yo digo que si a uno le preguntan sus
ideas políticas son de derechas.
Uno con la frente en alta, diga Sí, claro.
Después podemos discutir qué significa
izquierda, qué significa derecha.
Yo doy por hecho que más o menos todos
tenemos una noción, un sentido común al
respecto.
Por ejemplo, el caso de Argentina.
Y déjenme que les ejemplifique con algunos
casos de la región, particularmente
argentina, que es el que me toca vivir de
cerca por razones obvias.
En el caso de Argentina, el partido se llama
La libertad Avanza.
Y cuando a Javier Milei le quieren correr por
derecha y le dicen que es un derechista, él
dice sí, cuál es el problema?
Y usted es un zurdo de.
A mí aquí en México, que he venido mucho,
conozco más México que Argentina.
Tengo que decir de verdad.
Y he estado en muchos programas de la
televisión de distintos estados de México y
me decían.
En Wikipedia dice que usted es de ultra
derecha, porque eso es lo que dice en
Wikipedia, eso lo escribe cualquiera y queda
ahí.
Y yo le decía No, no, se equivocan, se
equivocan.
Soy de ultra mega, súper derecha.
Claro, uno le redobla porque ya todo es una
caricatura, no?
Pero cuando uno empieza a atreverse a esas
cosas, se desarma el dispositivo sensor del
enemigo.
En segundo lugar, para formar una derecha
política, esa derecha política tiene que
tener una doctrina clara.
En el caso de Argentina, el libertarismo.
Pero no es solo libertarismo, cuidado, es un
libertarismo que tiene una gran influencia
del conservadurismo cultural y una gran
influencia del nacionalismo político.
En el espacio de la libertad avanza, uno
encuentra distintas derechas que han
aprendido a convivir, pero todas tienen claro
de que hay doctrina atrás de lo que se hace.
Y cuando uno mira qué ha pasado con los
partidos de la derecha tradicional, han
tenido todo menos doctrina.
En las últimas décadas.
En tercer lugar, claro, ahí puse no basta ser
anti morena, no basta que la derecha mexicana
diga cuál es tu ideología política.
Yo soy anti morena, eso dejémoselos a los
políticos que hoy dicen ser oposición y que
lo que ofrecen es simplemente eso.
En tercer lugar, hay que nombrar al enemigo.
Esto es muy importante.
El enemigo tiene que ser real, tiene que
tener rostro, tiene que tener un lenguaje
propio, tiene que tener escenas, tiene que
explicar muchos males al mismo tiempo, tiene
que tiene que separar al pueblo de las
élites.
Y en torno a su derrota tiene que haber una
promesa de liberación.
Por ejemplo, en la libertad avanza el
enemigo se llama la casta política y
con la casta logramos englobar tanto
al kirchnerismo como al macrismo como
a la socialdemocracia y a las
distintas expresiones más o menos
lavadas que se dan en el ámbito de los
otros partidos políticos.
Si vos, nosotros venimos a destruir a la
casta política o por ejemplo, Abelardo de la
Espriella, que recién se los mencionaba, este
outsider colombiano, él lo llama los de
siempre venimos a sacar del poder a los de
siempre.
Cuando la casta política o los de siempre se
vayan del poder, tu vida va a mejorar.
Por qué?
Porque voy a meter preso a los delincuentes,
voy a acabar con el crimen organizado, voy a
mejorar la economía, pero tengo que ponerle
un nombre muy abarcante que sea capaz de
evocar imágenes, escenas, lenguajes, rostros.
En el caso de Maga, los globalistas, cuál es
el gran, el gran enemigo de Make America
Great again?
Los globalistas que han llenado Estados
Unidos de inmigración ilegal y han vuelto los
barrios inseguros.
Cuál es el gran enemigo en España de Vox?
La conjunción de los socialistas con los
globalistas, fundamentalmente en las
instituciones de la Unión Europea número
cuatro tiene que tener esta nueva derecha un
lenguaje popular claro, de fondo.
Tiene que haber una doctrina muy potente
atrás de esto.
Tiene que haber filósofos, escritores,
intelectuales, periodistas, artistas.
Pero quien lidere el espacio tiene que hacer
que su mensaje sea entendido.
por las personas de todos los niveles, porque
de eso se trata la democracia.
Al final de cuentas, de juntar todos los
votos que uno pueda.
Y muchas veces estas cosas se capturan en
expresiones muy populares.
Viva la libertad, carajo!
Ha sido el grito de guerra del mileurismo.
Make America Great again ha sido el
grito de guerra de Trump.
Viva España!
Ha sido el grito de guerra de Vox en España.
Firmes por la patria!
Ha sido el grito de guerra de Abelardo de la
Espriella en Colombia.
Y así sucesivamente.
En todos los casos tiene que haber un
lenguaje popular y tiene que haber
expresiones políticamente incorrectas que le
diferencien a uno de todo el resto de ofertas
políticas.
En 5.º lugar, tiene que haber un líder
carismático porque al final de cuentas se
votan por personas y la inmensa a ver, la
gente no va habitualmente a ver un programa
de gobierno, no lee cuáles son los puntos que
ofrece electoralmente el espacio político.
La gente se enamora de gente.
La gente se enamora de gente y el carisma ha
sido fundamental para todos los personajes
que yo les mostré recién.
Qué tiene que tener un líder carismático de
derechas?
En primer lugar, valentía.
Recién, don Ricardo, lo primero que dijo de
costos que tiene esto dijo costos personales?
Ya lo creo, pero solo un valiente puede
enfrentar esos costos personales por una
causa mayor.
Sin valentía no hay derecha.
Formación.
Un líder de una nueva derecha tiene que estar
muy empapado del contenido doctrinal de su
espacio.
Caso contrario no va a ser eficiente a la
hora de transmitir las ideas, porque quien no
conoce las ideas, mucho menos las puede
simplificar.
No hay nada más difícil que simplificar una
idea compleja, y eso solamente lo puede hacer
quien entiende la complejidad de la idea que
simplifica.
Si no está dando eslóganes y eslogans, no se
puede llegar a ningún lado.
Tiene que tener oratoria.
Todas estas personas que yo les mostraba
recién tienen buena oratoria de distintos
estilos, pero el líder de una nueva derecha
tiene que ser capaz de su oratoria,
conquistar a las masas tiene que tener
autenticidad.
La gente lo tiene que ver como alguien
transparente.
Tuvimos una experiencia.
Tomo dos dos minutos más acá ya me dice cero
dos minutos más como para poder cerrar esto,
por favor.
Cuando Milei perdió el debate con Sergio
Massa, que era su oponente kirchnerista, la
gente, sin embargo, contestó en las encuestas
que se hicieron que él había ganado el debate
porque se había mostrado auténtico la idea de
la autenticidad resulta fundamental en el
carisma de un líder de nueva derecha.
Y tiene que haber magnetismo, que es lo más
irracional y lo más difícil de conseguir,
porque o se lo tiene o no se lo tiene.
Eso sí que no se construye.
Eso es inherente.
Por último, la nueva derecha tiene que tener
una estrategia de batalla cultural, que es lo
que le ha acercado al poder en todos los
casos que yo les comenté.
Qué significa tener una estrategia de batalla
cultural?
Significa muchas cosas.
En primer lugar, hay que moverse como pez en
el agua, en las redes.
Y les voy a decir algo polémico en las redes
se tiene que contar con la espontaneidad,
pero también con la programación.
Se necesitan centros de trolls, se necesita
gente dedicada a tiempo completo, a
establecer una narrativa en las redes, a
manejar muchas cuentas al mismo tiempo.
Sé que ustedes pueden decir, pero así es.
Si esto es así en la política de redes de
hoy, en cualquier país, hacer una política de
batalla cultural fuerte en redes, se necesita
una gran organización para marcar las
tendencias, para instalar los temas, para
hacer virales los contenidos y para eso se
necesita gente organizada, Se necesitan
intelectuales.
Esta es la parte que a veces se entiende
menos, porque se piensa que los intelectuales
llegan a muy poquita gente.
Y es cierto, los intelectuales llegan a
poquita gente.
Es decir, no todo el mundo lee un libro de un
filósofo, no todo el mundo va a escuchar una
conferencia de un politólogo, pero hay que.
Hay que diferenciar cantidad y calidad.
La gente que consume este contenido es la que
después más influencia social tiene.
Está muy bien llegar a grandes masas, pero
también hay que llegar a las personas que
forman personas y esas son las personas que
consumen el contenido de los intelectuales,
profesores, periodistas, otros escritores,
artistas, gente preocupada por el mundo de la
cultura en general.
No todo se tiene que medir con términos
cuantitativos, sino cualitativos.
Y el último punto que quiero mencionar en un
minuto es el de las universidades.
Recién les decía que el campo del arte para
mí es el más complicado para las personas de
derechas, y a eso le agregaría ahora el campo
de las universidades.
Las universidades son los cuarteles generales
de las batallas culturales, porque ahí es
donde se producen y se distribuyen las ideas.
Aquellos que después las diseminan por la
sociedad.
En la universidad se forman los periodistas,
los psicólogos, los abogados, los filósofos,
los sociólogos, los historiadores, los
antropólogos, todas las personas que trabajan
en el mundo de la cultura se forman en
universidades.
Y estas personas, a diferencia de las que
trabajan sobre cosas tangibles, duras,
reales, materiales, como puede ser un
ingeniero, por ejemplo.
Esas personas no son habitualmente las que
van a tener gran impacto en el mundo de la
cultura.
Y esas personas quizás tienen más, más
incentivos para ser de derechas.
Pero las personas que trabajan en el ámbito
de la cultura tienen grandes incentivos para
ser personas de izquierdas porque su
empleador natural se llama Estado.
Y por qué su empleador natural se llama
Estado?
Porque no tienen mercado.
Son muy pocas las gentes que quieren comprar
un libro de filosofía y se los digo como
escritor de filosofía.
Son muy pocas las personas que quieren pagar
una entrada para ir a una conferencia, para
ir a una, a una, a una exposición de arte.
Son muy pocas las personas que quieren
comprar un libro de historia, pero estas son
las personas que moldean nuestra cultura los
historiadores, los filósofos, los sociólogos,
los politólogos, los psicólogos, los abogados
y se forman en lugares donde se les formatea
en un sentido político que termina teniendo
un círculo vicioso, como ustedes notarán cómo
salimos de eso.
Yo sé que ustedes tienen un gran
emprendimiento, que es una Universidad de la
Libertad.
Los felicito por ello.
Digo que dan en el clavo con ese tipo de
emprendimientos, pero también sería muy bueno
formar una nueva escuela de intelectuales en
México.
Se los dejo como una inquietud tener una
nueva escuela de pensamiento político
mexicano y ser capaces de atraer y financiar,
porque acá el asunto del financiamiento es
clave, como verán, porque todas estas gentes,
si no terminan cobrando del Estado, entonces
se dedican a otras cosas que se dediquen a lo
que se dedican por profesión, pero que lo
hagan para nosotros sería la consigna.
De eso se tratan los think tanks, por
ejemplo.
Entonces, cómo podemos hacer para traer
intelectuales?
Cómo podemos hacer para formar una escuela de
pensamiento político alternativo en México?
Es lo que yo dejaría sobre la mesa como uno
de los grandes desafíos de lo que viene.
Mi tiempo se ha acabado, De hecho, me he
excedido cinco minutos.
Espero que esta breve conferencia les les
pueda servir.
Saben que cuentan conmigo.
Saben que estamos mirando desde Argentina,
México.
Por lo que les dije recién, México es
fundamental para el ascenso de las izquierdas
en la región y tenemos que hacer algo con
ello por el bien de los mexicanos y del resto
del continente.
Muchísimas gracias.
>> Gracias, muchas gracias Maestro.
Gracias.
Muy interesante la verdad.
Mucho que pensar y para todos aquellos o
todas aquellas que necesiten asistencia con
sus computadoras, allá en la parte de atrás
están los ingenieros para la instalación de
del del ente.
Listo y nos vemos en 30 minutos de
regreso.
Para empezar.
Gracias.
>> Son tan amables de tomar sus lugares.
Vamos a dar inicio.
Ladies and gentlemen, please take your
sheets.
We are about to start.
That's life. That's
All the people say.
You're riding high in April, shot
down in May.
But I know I'm gonna
change that tune when I'm
back on top, back on top.
In June.
I said that's life, that's life,
that's life.
And I can't deny it.
Many times I thought of cutting out.
I'm gonna roll myself
up in a big ball and
die.
My, my my.
>> Estamos de regreso, por favor, please
>> We are back.
Y ahora vamos a recibir a
Yasmina Q es el c o the big
simple. I
O como dice el señor Salinas, la cosa
inteligente y lista que nos va a platicar
sobre liderazgo empresarial en la era de la
inteligencia artificial.
Vamos a recibirlo, por favor.
Gracias.
Bienvenido.
>> Encantado de estar aquí.
Y Ricardo, muchísimas gracias por la
invitación.
Estoy muy emocionado de estar con todos aquí.
Y si ponen aquí la presentación para que
empecemos, vamos a hablar de inteligencia
artificial.
Pero si ven aquí el título de Pues cómo se
llama esta conferencia?
No estoy hablando de IA, sino estoy hablando
de ideas.
Think Big bots, start simple.
Y así es que voy a empezar un poco mi
historia.
Y antes de meternos al tema Inteligencia
artificial, les quiero platicar un poquito de
mí y cómo fue que me metí al mundo de
tecnología y la historia de cómo acabé en el
mundo de tecnología.
Todo empezó con una gallina, tal cual, así
como lo ven, no?
Yo pues en el inicio de mi carrera, mi abuelo
fundó una de las empresas más grandes de
distribución de bienes de consumo en México y
yo pensaba que eventualmente iba a trabajar
en empresa de la familia.
Entonces dije oye, si eventualmente quiero
trabajar ahí, pues empecé trabajando como
consultor especializado en bienes de consumo,
porque dije eventualmente pues quiero hacer
esto con la empresa de la familia, no?
Y por casi cuatro años me tocó trabajar en
alrededor de 13 países, muchos en Sudamérica,
algunos en Europa, principalmente para
cerveceras y Coca-Cola, entendiendo cómo
vender mejor, cómo subir precios, cómo ser
más efectivo en las tienditas.
Y cuando iba todos estos países redefiniendo
las estrategias de estas empresas, me tocaba
estar subido en los camiones para entender
realmente la operación y me volví como muy
famoso en el mundo de consultoría.
Como latinoamericano que iba de país en país
y ni conocí a su novia ni a sus amigos porque
estaba trepado en un avión todo el día y de
repente la realidad es que pues yo no estudié
tecnología, yo no soy desarrollador, yo no
soy ingeniero, sino que aquí fue donde empezó
mi historia.
Y esa historia dio un cambio bastante
interesante.
En 2011, cuando estaba yo trabajando en
Paraguay en uno de estos proyectos y me habla
el director general de esta firma de
consultoría y me dice Adrián, acabamos de
recibir una llamada de otro lugar del mundo,
a ver si quieres ir para ver si hacemos lo
mismo.
Parecido de lo que ya se visto en
Latinoamérica.
Este lugar eran las oficinas centrales de
Coca-Cola para Kenia y Tanzania, África
Subsahariana.
Y me hablan y me dicen Oye Adrián, es que
quieren que vayas tú porque has visto algo
muy replicable en los demás países.
Pero esta experiencia en África tiene un
Kvyat muy diferente a lo que hemos visto.
Nos están pidiendo que entendamos cómo
podemos integrar a la cadena de suministro
Coca-Cola.
El tema de pagos móviles 2011.
En 2011 solamente había una penetración de
smartphones más o menos del 10% en África.
Si el global era 10%, en África probablemente
era 0%.
Y la realidad de África en cuanto a teléfonos
se veía como esta.
No había smartphones, eran feature phones.
Yo les decía y todo mundo les decían los
teléfonos de chicles.
Y cuando me dijeron pues pagos móviles, yo
dije me están choreando.
La verdad no creo que esto vaya a tener un
impacto, pero si me están pagando ir para
allá seguramente voy a aprender mucho.
Va a estar interesante.
Todavía no estaba casado y me fui y literal,
aterrizando en Nairobi un lunes.
El martes me subo a un camión de Coca-Cola
como normalmente lo hacía y me voy a una ruta
rural.
Este a dos horas de Nairobi, que de hecho ya
estamos planeando ir a rutas para entender
cómo se hace el proceso de cobranza.
Estamos platicando aquí con el señor Tanus en
la mañana y este y me subo a este camión dos
horas a las afueras de Nairobi para ver una
tiendita rural que era lo que más me
interesaba.
Me bajo y veo esta imagen.
Una persona con un teléfono de chicles
pagándole a otra persona con otro teléfono de
chicles, una gallina.
Y para mí ese fue un momento de realmente
realización, donde lo primero que pensé fue
qué fui yo al entender que mi preconcepción
de qué era la tecnología, porque vivía yo en
un mundo donde según esto somos avanzados,
estaba tan alejado de la realidad.
Después entendí que en 2011 y por esas
épocas, el tema de pagos móviles en África,
pues era un tema que estaba mucho más
adelante que lo demás, pero ese momento fue
totalmente coyuntural, donde dije papá, no
voy a trabajar en la empresa familiar
eventualmente, aunque ni lo tenía seguro.
Quiero entender cómo puedo estar realmente en
en el centro de cómo las tecnologías pueden
generar valor, transformación y realmente
hacer un cambio brutal y generar
oportunidades y negocio, no?
Y ahí fue un momento importantísimo de
cambio, de coyuntura.
Y le suelto una pregunta a ustedes cuándo fue
la última vez que realmente con un tema de
tecnología se quedaron completamente
sorprendidos que les hizo cambiarse las
concepciones de negocio o las concepciones
sociales que tenemos?
La realidad es que hoy, absolutamente todos
los días están pasando momentos como el que
para mí fue esa gallina, pero mil veces más
grande con lo que estamos viendo en el mundo
de la inteligencia artificial.
Y cuando hablo de mil veces más grande,
solamente vean este número, 1.000.000.000 de
personas.
Ese es el número de personas que ya utilizan
aplicaciones de inteligencia artificial de
forma semanal, no que la bajaron una vez para
preguntar algo random, no que la bajaron una
vez para hacer una estrategia de negocio una
vez semanal, cuando tú ya estás utilizando
algo semanal, quiere decir que tú ya estás
cambiando la forma de hacer las cosas, estás
cambiando patrones, estás cambiando
pensamiento y es impresionante que estamos
apenas hace cuatro años del momento que lo
empezó todo.
Este tweet, como muchas cosas en la era de
Donald Trump, que empiezan con un tweet de
OpenAI, la empresa que inventó Chatgpt y que
la historia de por qué el lanzamiento de
Chatgpt fue algo sin bombo y platillo y sin
muchos gritos ni mucho menos.
Por qué fue nada más un tweet?
Fue por dos cosas.
La primera es que era algo que todavía no
estaban seguros de cuál iba a ser el impacto
era algo experimental.
Y la segunda es que se quieran adelantar a
Cloud Anthropic, que les venía pisando los
talones y querían ser los primeros en el
mercado.
Y de ahí empezó un cambio que hoy en día
todavía estamos tratando de entender qué
significa.
Pero ese cambio a nivel personal, ya no a
nivel ecosistema.
A nivel personal a mí me llegó de alguna u
otra forma.
Era finales de 2023, principios de 2024 y la
empresa de mi familia, desgraciadamente en
algún momento pues se fue a concurso
mercantil, entraron nuevos inversionistas y
en ese proceso los nuevos inversionistas pues
desgraciadamente no nos entendimos.
Problemas legales de un lado, problemas
legales del otro lado y llevábamos en ese
momento ocho años, pues abogados y abogados,
y me acerco con mi papá y le digo Papá, yo sé
que nunca he estado involucrado en la
empresa, pero explícame dónde están las
cosas, a ver si puedo ayudar.
De alguna forma Me explicó la situación.
Dije bueno, voy a ver qué puedo hacer Y lo
primero que hice fue seguir la ruta del
dinero.
Pues si hay un fondo arriba, hay
inversionistas arriba del fondo, los famosos
LPs.
Logré hablar con uno de los LPs y era
el martes diciembre recibo otra llamada
llamada.
Son bien importantes en esta historia.
Era este fondo de inversión en Miami y me
dicen Adrián, estamos dispuestos a por lo
menos abrir negociaciones.
Queremos que vengas a Miami este viernes.
No queremos que vengas con nadie de tu
familia porque tú eres alguien externo a todo
este desmadre.
Queremos que vengas abogados, nada más.
Tú a negociar.
Y de repente me encuentro con el siguiente
reto Reto.
Uno no podía decir que no cuando la vida en
los negocios o en la vida en general te abre
una ventana de oportunidad, tú no te importa
si hay un precipicio al otro lado, Qué hay
del otro lado?
Tú tienes que meter la cabeza, los hombros,
la rodilla, lo que sea para mantener, para
mantener esa ventana abierta, porque se
cierra y muchas veces no se vuelve a abrir.
No puede decir que no.
Segundo problema no tenía, pero ni
remotamente poquito contexto de lo que había
pasado en esos ocho años.
Más que conversaciones familiares.
Y ahora tenía que llevar una negociación en
tres días y ser un experto en esa
negociación.
Tercer problema tampoco era un abogado
experto.
Llevo ya para ese entonces ya me dedicaba, ya
llevaba dedicado ocho años.
Ser emprendedor en tecnología y era algo muy
lejano a ser un abogado experto.
Y 4.º problema tampoco era un negociador
experto, pero más o menos en lo incipiente
que estaba el mundo de la inteligencia
artificial hacia finales del 2023 2024 ya
había empezado yo a desarrollar una
mentalidad de inteligencia artificial que me
forzó en ese momento a entender qué es lo que
estaba pasando, a frenar y decir cómo lo
puedo hacer con mayor rigor, cómo lo puedo
hacer con mayor velocidad, cómo lo puedo
hacer?
Con mucho mejor especialización y cómo lo
puedo hacer de una forma que realmente pueda
llegar al objetivo que humanamente hubiera
sido imposible si no existiera la
inteligencia artificial?
Y qué fue lo que hice?
Pues me armé un hito dentro de Chatgpt
todavía Cloud.
Como que no escuchamos mucho de esto, lo
alimenté, lo que había de la documentación
legal, de la bronca de la familia y le dije
entrénate con los fundamentos que existen en
este libro, que en mi opinión es una de las
Biblias de cómo hacer negociaciones efectivas
y conviértete en mi contrincante en la
negociación.
Y qué fue lo que hice en los dos días
siguientes?
Literal pegarle a la tecla, estar negociando
con una computadora que sí tenía el
conocimiento perfecto del problema legal, que
sí tenía el conocimiento perfecto de
estrategias de negociación.
Y en esas conversaciones con un agente
rudimentario, pude entender mis puntos
ciegos, pude entender cómo tirar bolas
curvas, pude entender cómo generar mayor
empatía en esa conexión de esa conversación.
Y me encantaría decir que esa negociación.
Resolví todo en una sentada.
Eso es utópico?
Es imposible, pero fue la mejor
negociación que humanamente posible pude
haber llevado.
No porque fui más inteligente, porque entendí
que el mundo ya había cambiado, las
herramientas ya habían cambiado y
fundamentalmente mi forma de abordar retos y
pensar deberían de cambiar ahí mismo.
Y regresando a mi oficina fue cuando dije sí,
pude hacer esto con una negociación.
Qué tengo que estar pensando para cambiar la
forma en que yo ejerzo Mi posición como CEO
de una empresa tecnología?
Qué tengo que hacer?
Y lo primero que hice fue sacar una libreta.
Y después de que abrí esa libreta, lo
apunté con pluma y puño.
Cuáles eran las diez cosas más importantes
que yo hacía de forma recurrente?
Preparar reportes para inversionistas, hacer
análisis financiero, hacer tener
conversaciones difíciles, construir cultura,
tareas administrativas.
Y dije no sé cómo, pero ya que tengo esas
diez cosas, me voy a forzar a tratar de
entender cómo la inteligencia artificial me
ayuda a borrarlas de mi lista, no para que no
las haga, sino para que reduzca el 80% y con
ese 20% las puedo hacer exponencialmente
mejor.
Y traté, fallé, Traté.
Fallé hasta que taché una.
Hasta que taché dos.
Hasta que taché tres.
Y me di cuenta que realmente podía
convertirme en un CEO que podía hacer tres,
cuatro, diez veces más y generar mucho más
valor de forma sistémica.
Y me llevé aquí una primera lección de
transformación de liderazgo en el tema de
inteligencia artificial.
A veces pensamos que este cambio que tenemos
que dar con el tema de inteligencia
artificial es porque vimos una cosa muy
flashy en algún lado ya se pueden hacer
videos chistosos que puedes realmente
utilizarlos para marketing o ya se puede
hacer ese dashboard que me va a permitir
tener todos los insights?
Eso es importante porque la sensibilización
es importante, pero el cambio empieza con
disciplina.
Suena mucho más aburrido, pero así lo es
porque la disciplina es lo que se requiere
para hacer un cambio de hábito tratar,
fallar, tratar, fallar, aprender.
Y desde esta perspectiva fue que empecé a dar
yo ese cambio personal en mi transformación,
pues de líder en el mundo, la artificial.
Y en ese proceso, mientras yo estaba
cambiando, que de hecho dejo la dirección
general de esa empresa que que lideré por
siete años para fundar otra empresa de
inteligencia artificial, más o menos en 2025,
fue que el fue el punto de quiebre en el
ecosistema de inteligencia artificial.
Fue donde las cosas cambiaron tanto para los
líderes, para los individuos y para las
empresas.
Fue cuando los modelos de IA desarrollaron
este concepto que se llama Deep Reasoning.
Razonamiento profundo porque antes de 2025,
mucho de lo que leíamos a nivel empresas es
no estamos generando resultados, estamos
haciendo demos bonitas, pero no funcionan
para mucho.
Pero en 2025 empezaron los modelos a tener
profundidad de razonamiento mucho más
asertiva y entonces pasó algo que les voy a
explicar qué es que estamos viendo aquí
atrás.
Es un cielo estrellado que podríamos ver
inclusive aquí en Jalmolonga, con el ojo
pelón para ver las estrellas que hay allá
afuera de noche.
No?
Esta segunda imagen también es un cielo
estrellado, probablemente en el firmamento
existen exactamente las mismas estrellas en
la slide anterior que en esta estrella.
Pero aquí estamos, cambiando de óptica.
Estamos entendiendo y viendo texturas que
antes no veíamos.
Estamos entendiendo y viendo patrones que
antes no identificábamos que estaban ahí,
aunque ya existían, pero no éramos capaces de
verlos.
Y aquí fue en una conversación que tuve con
un director general que ahorita les voy a
platicar, que llegamos a esta realización,
que antes de meternos a platicar de agentes y
de automatización en el core de ejercer o
usar inteligencia artificial como líder,
tenemos que pensar que la inteligencia
artificial es un telescopio para el
pensamiento.
Hablando de pensamiento que me encantó la
plática anterior.
Y por qué?
Porque exactamente la inteligencia artificial
nos permite encontrar los unknown Unknowns,
los famosos desconocidos desconocidos, esas
oportunidades que probablemente ya existían
en nuestros negocios, en nuestros
emprendimientos, pero no teníamos esa
capacidad de entender las texturas, los
puntos hilarlas y poder generar valor.
Y déjenme platicarles esta historia porque
ata muy bien.
Con esto también tengo tengo la fortuna de
ser consejero externo, miembro del consejo de
Administración de cuatro empresas.
Una de ellas es un conglomerado bastante
grande que tiene negocios de banca, bueno, de
Sofom tiene un negocio de plásticos, negocio
de jabones, negocio realstate, hoteles,
bastante diversificado y estaba teniendo una
conversación con el CEO de del grupo de
empresas y me dice Adrián, es que yo soy
fanático de la inteligencia artificial.
Y yo Ay, a ver, a ver qué me va a decir.
Es que hablo con Chatgpt todo el día y yo
dije no, pues seguramente está haciendo lo
mismo que hace mi mamá o algo.
Habla con todo el día y hablando con chatgpt
todo el día sin hacer algo más, sin construir
agentes.
Logramos identificar 5 millones de dólares a
Levitt en un año, sin hacer un centavo
adicional de inversión y estamos perfilando
que sean cercano a 20 millones de dólares en
el año 2 cero.
Inversión por platicar con Chatgpt.
Y ahí sí le dije tienes toda mi atención,
qué hiciste?
Y me dijo mira, pues somos un grupo bastante
diversificado en lo que hacemos, tenemos
muchas unidades de negocio, todas haciendo
cosas diferentes, pero una particular que es
de agricultura.
Generamos una cantidad toneladas
impresionantes de desperdicio de hueso, de
aguacate y de cáscara de aguacate.
Y aunque no es la unidad de negocio
principal, por muchos, por muchos años,
decíamos cómo podemos capitalizar la cáscara
de aguacate y el hueso de aguacate de forma
efectiva pero sin invertir ahí?
Porque el capital allocation lo estamos
haciendo en otras empresas y sabíamos que
eventualmente podíamos ser aceite de
aguacate, pero teníamos que hacer inversiones
fuertes y no estábamos dispuestos a hacerlas.
Y entonces durante un mes le platiqué a qué
procesos productivos teníamos, qué maquinaria
teníamos, qué procesos teníamos, qué
hacíamos, de qué forma y al final del mes le
pregunté qué fregados podemos hacer con el
hueso de aguacate y la cáscara de aguacate?
Y este CEO es un ingeniero químico
sofisticado y le arroja una receta, se la
pasa a sus ingenieros químicos, la revisan,
la prueban y después de seis años que estaban
tratando de hacer pruebas y solo sacaban
aceite de aguacate como chapopote que no se
podía vender más que en toneladas, Sacan una
primera prueba de aceite de aguacate ultra
transparente.
La segunda receta sacan un polímero de
plástico que se puede se puede hacer con
aceite con hueso de aguacate.
La tercera empiezan a construir tarimas
basadas con el desperdicio de aguacate, que
esa es la oportunidad más grande que lo está
generando.
Casi 300 millones de pesos.
Es este la exposición sin un centavo de
inversión?
Este CEO, este líder de negocio?
No necesitó ser más
inteligente.
Lo que necesitó fue ver mejor y entender que
para ver mejor.
Hay tenemos exactamente esas herramientas que
nos permiten ver mejor y que antes
probablemente no existían.
Pero hay una oportunidad brutal de entender
cómo esto fue una conversación.
No fue algo mucho más sofisticado.
Y también regresando a esta historia, porque
estamos todavía en 2025, en 2025 fue donde ya
en el ecosistema grande general de
Inteligencia Artificial, surge un caso de uso
como el inesperado ganador que hoy tiene
casi, casi que el 70% de market share en el
uso empresarial de la inteligencia
artificial, que es cómo se utiliza la
inteligencia artificial para desarrollo de
software, para generación de código.
Y ahorita les voy a explicar por qué este
caso de uso es importante como reflexión
general, pero si vemos esa gráfica, esa
gráfica básicamente habla de cuántas veces la
inteligencia artificial es mejor
desarrollando retos complejos de desarrollo
de código que los humanos.
En 2023 eran dos de cada 100 retos y
seguramente en 2023 los desarrolladores de
software decían esto de ley es algo bien
interesante que va a servir para nada.
No nos preocupemos, tampoco nos apliquemos
porque las cosas no van a cambiar.
Dos años después, 78 de cada
100.
Hoy estamos probablemente ya en 88 de cada
Quiere decir que ya en una grandísima mayoría
de ocasiones estamos llegando al punto que la
inteligencia artificial es mejor que el
humano en desarrollar.
Los desarrolladores van a seguir
necesitándose, claro, pero los roles van a
cambiar.
Pero por qué quiero utilizar este ejemplo
para algo general?
Si ustedes tienen empresas de desarrollo pero
son una empresa diversificada que no nada más
desarrollan, es por este mensaje.
No es el mensaje, es los desarrolladores se
van a acabar.
Vean el mensaje más arriba de esto que está
haciendo la inteligencia artificial está
construyendo un puente totalmente un puente
entre lo que antes creíamos que era posible
que podíamos hacer como individuos y lo que
ahora.
Somos capaces de crear y utilicemos este
concepto de la innovación.
Antes pensamos que la innovación, desde la
perspectiva de innovar en software, era para
los que llevaban toda la vida aprendiendo
software, era para los ingenieros, era para
los que realmente entendían la abstracción de
cómo se tiene que hacer eso.
Hoy la IA cree ese puente y yo que al final
soy emprendedor de tecnología, pero no soy
técnico o desarrollo de software, una parte
importante de mi equipo de desarrollo no
tienen la preparación de desarrollo y pueden
desarrollar software.
Empezamos a unir un futuro que antes
pensábamos que solo estaba reservado para
unos pocos.
Y si tenemos las capacidades y el interés de
hacerlo, podemos empezar a mover por ese
puente para cerrar esas brechas y abordarlo.
Esos límites, esas excusas, esos.
No tengo el conocimiento y las capacidades se
empiezan a borrar y en el centro de este
cambio y borrar está un cambio de paradigma.
Porque pensemos exactamente con este ejemplo
qué significa ese cambio de paradigma?
Desarrollo de software Paradigma anterior Qué
pasaba antes?
Tú tenías una idea que querías desarrollar
software.
Para innovar algo tenías que contratar un
ejército de desarrolladores, tenías que
construir porque era extremadamente complejo,
tenías que lanzar y el cuello de botella era
el acceso a capital, el talento técnico, el
tiempo, porque costaba mucho tiempo.
Paradigma de ahora tú tienes una muy buena
idea.
Tus agentes de inteligencia artificial te
pueden desarrollar un MVP, un mínimo viable,
Product probablemente no algo terminado.
Ahí sí necesitas el apoyo de la gente
técnica, pero un MVP que te permita acortar
los tiempos sustantivamente, que te permite
validar, que te permite escalar y cuál es el
nuevo bottleneck?
La calidad de las ideas.
Porque en el centro de cómo podemos como
usuarios generar valor en el uso de la
inteligencia artificial están las ideas, Está
el entender un problema, está el poder
entender una solución, el poder argumentarlo,
romperlo en cachos y crear valor.
Y a mí me encanta decir que por primera vez
estamos en un momento de la historia, que la
tecnología está realmente generando un acceso
democrático a poder construir el futuro,
porque todos, o al menos muchos o la mayoría
o espero que el 100% de los que estamos aquí
tenemos capacidad de pensar de forma crítica
y si tenemos capacidad de pensar de forma
crítica, podemos realmente construir un
futuro.
Valor, negocio, crecimiento alrededor de la
inteligencia artificial.
Eso es lo que estamos viendo hoy en día.
Y si 2025 fue el año del razonamiento, este
barco no va a parar y el tren sigue avanzando
rapidísimo.
2026 se está perfilando para ser el año de la
ejecución, ya no la inteligencia artificial,
que está pensando que está definiendo el cómo
podemos innovar, sino que lo está haciendo
por nosotros.
El año de los agentes y otro punto de
quiebre, que es el último que voy a mencionar
hoy, se dio en febrero de 2026 con el
lanzamiento de este agente que ven allá abajo
esta langosta que se llama Open Cloud, que
fue el primer agente ya real lanzado al
mercado y que aparte fue open source
disponible para todos, que literal ya
funciona como alguien que puedes contratar en
tu empresa como si fuera tu Chief of Staff,
tu asistente personal que lo conectas a las
herramientas que tú usas todos los días, a tu
calendario, a tu whatsapp, a tus reportes, a
tus datos, le escribes como si fuera una
persona.
Trabaja por ti, desarrolla por ti.
Y aquí empezó a cambiar de nuevo otro
paradigma el tema de cómo las organizaciones,
personas, agentes e IA van a convivir hacia
adelante.
Pero si esto fuera solamente miel sobre
hojuelas y fuera únicamente valor incremental
de lo que podemos crear, pues todas las
empresas deberíamos estar boyantes.
Todas las empresas deberían de estar
creciendo a órdenes de magnitud.
Por qué?
Porque están las herramientas, porque el hay
resuelve, porque entonces sí, Si todo mundo
podemos hacer esto, dónde está el valor?
Deberíamos de estar arriba.
La realidad es completamente diferente.
Y esto fue de un estudio de McKinsey de este
año de abril de 2026, donde decían un estudio
de un grupo particular de Estados Unidos que
decían El 75% de las empresas ya están
utilizando AI y ya lo están utilizando de
forma sistémica.
Muchas de ellas, Sin embargo,
solamente el 20% está teniendo un
impacto real medible en más de un
de 5 a 10% de vida, solamente el
20%.
Y después la Universidad de Stanford hizo
otro estudio que trataba de entender
exactamente cuáles eran las razones y
consistentemente empezaba a surgir esta
razón.
El problema no es la tecnología.
Desde mediados de 2025, finales de 2025, la
tecnología ya está en un estado que ya
permite, sí, generar el brinco de resultados
que podemos estar generando antes.
Todavía no estamos llegando ahí, pero empieza
a verse que el principal cuello de botella
para generar estos resultados es un tema de
liderazgo, es un tema de cultura, es un tema
que puede empezar con nosotros cuando cuatro
de cada cinco problemas de falta de creación
de valor tienen que ver con gente, tienen que
ver con personas, Resistencia al cambio.
No tengo los skills adecuados, tengo miedo,
tengo sesgos porque la realidad, como vimos,
este tema de historia, de cómo se fue
moviendo la evolución de la inteligencia
artificial es que han sido cambios
brutalmente grandes a lo largo de los últimos
cuatro años.
Pero regresemos a esto.
Si la tecnología ha tenido estos cambios tan
brutales en los últimos cuatro años, tú te
has hecho estas preguntas.
Tú has cambiado, Has cambiado tú la forma en
la que piensas?
Has cambiado la forma en la que lideras, Has
cambiado la forma en la que decides porque
existe la inteligencia artificial o existe,
la hay, pero tú sigues haciendo lo mismo.
Porque si esa es la situación, entonces no
esperes que se pueda generar un impacto y una
realidad diferente a la que estás viviendo
hoy en día.
Porque la realidad es que hay cosas que no
van a cambiar.
Como líderes de negocios, ustedes tienen que
tener visión estratégica.
Eso va a seguir siendo consistente, van a
seguir, van a seguir tomando decisiones
críticas y profundas todo el tiempo.
Vamos a tener que construir cultura, eso es
un hecho también y al final vamos a seguir
teniendo la responsabilidad final de lo que
hagamos.
El día no va a ser responsable de los
resultados.
Tú BAZ a seguir siendo responsable de esos
resultados, pero si bien hay cosas que no
cambian, hay cosas que sí cambian y cosas que
sí están cambiando.
Ya antes, en 2020, los equipos estaban
tomando decisiones basadas en reportes
mensuales.
El reporte mensual es algo que ya pasó, ya no
puedes hacer nada de lo que pasó.
Los equipos que están construyendo sobre
inteligencia artificial están empezando a
tomar decisiones informadas en tiempo real.
Antes la innovación pasaba en ciclos de 12 a
18 meses.
Por qué?
Porque era costoso.
Porque era difícil, porque tomaba tiempo
innovar.
Hoy los equipos están innovando en ciclos de
semanas, constante.
Antes las empresas tomaban y definían su
estrategia en Offsite.
Hoy las estrategias deben de ser dinámicas
porque tienes el telescopio que te permite
entender y ver y en el centro de esto está el
entendimiento que tenemos que convertirnos.
Cada uno de ustedes y Grupo Salinas quiere
realmente avanzar en First Leaders.
Y qué es convertirte en un líder?
Es entender que en el centro de la creación
de valor, la inteligencia artificial, primero
tienes que empezar por ti.
Tú, como usuario de ti.
No esperes que tu área, que tu departamento,
que la empresa que lideras en Grupo Salinas
se.
Forme Si tú al inicio no eres alguien que
estás utilizando la.
De forma intensiva para entender.
Por eso en el centro tú sí, entonces el líder
tiene esa capacidad de aprender y cambiar.
Puedes ya cambiar la parte de la empresa y
por qué no, tu mundo?
Y no estoy hablando del mundo como este globo
efímero, tu mundo, algo personal.
Y quiero entonces platicarles el cómo se ve
esto de forma específica.
Primero, cómo pueden ustedes construir este
liderazgo de personal como usuarios?
Y fue que realmente lo puse esto en cinco
escalones del nivel de sofisticación que
vamos avanzando en el uso de la inteligencia
artificial y quiero que cada quien piense
cuando los describa, dónde sienten ustedes
que se acomodan y no se desanimen si están en
los primeros?
Más bien, quiero que se emocionen para
entender que hay más escalones hacia adelante
y empecemos con esto.
El primer escalón es al que yo le llamo el
consumidor accidental.
Es el que abre su aplicación de IA porque le
abre normalmente en el teléfono le pregunta a
Chatgpt porque normalmente tienen chatgpt y
le dicen cuáles son las tendencias de
marketing digital para 2025?
Chatgpt te responde una respuesta
shakesperiana y básicamente la lees y dices
Ya sé perfectamente qué hacer con marketing.
Cierra la conversación de y no haces nada
diferente.
Lo estás utilizando como un Google
glorificado?
No, no está cambiando tu capacidad cognitiva,
no está cambiando tu capacidad de pensar y
descomponer un problema.
Estás googleando respuestas más profundas que
antes.
Todos empezamos ahí.
Quién es el paso dos?
El paso dos es lo que yo le llamo el pensador
estructurado.
Y durante 2024 y 2025.
Todo mundo era lo único que hablábamos es que
tienes que estructurar buenos prompts, es que
tienes que saber el rol, el objetivo, el
contexto, la tarea y si ya sabes escribir
buenos prompts, ya sabes usar AI, no te
tienes que preocupar nada.
Prompts, prompts, prompts no?
Y la verdad que esa era la realidad.
2024 Estábamos en esta fase donde estábamos
entendiendo que deconstruyendo un reto, una
oportunidad en qué es lo que quiero resolver,
cómo lo quiero resolver, qué rol quiero que
tome la inteligencia artificial?
La inteligencia artificial empezaba a dar
mejores resultados porque le estaba dando el
contexto correcto, le estaba dando las tareas
correctas, le estaba asignando el rol
correcto.
Aquí empieza a haber un cambio cognitivo y
empieza a haber un cambio de cómo pensamos,
porque ya nada más no está tratando de
resolver algo con una pregunta.
Estás descomponiendo la forma en la que
piensas para tratar de llegar a una solución.
Pero en 2025 cambiaron las cosas y aquí ya no
es donde tenemos que quedarnos y tenemos que
pensar qué es lo que sigue hacia adelante.
Y por eso me voy al tercer eslabón.
Que es el arquitecto de contenido.
>> Listo.
>> Cuál es el líder que llega al tercer eslabón,
que es el arquitecto de contexto?
El arquitecto de contexto es el cuate que ve
un reto, ve una oportunidad, ve algo y no lo
quiere resolver rápido con ella.
Ahí dice me voy a frenar para entender
cómo más bien sistematizo la forma de
resolver esto.
Una vez, para resolverlo de
raíz.
No tener que utilizar cada vez que lo quiero
resolver.
Entender que es algo que va a tener
recurrencia, que puedo sistematizar, Por
ejemplo oye, tengo que recopilar datos,
analizar oportunidades, identificar riesgos.
Por qué resolverlo una vez, si puedo
sistematizarlo, resolverlo para siempre y
para adelante, liberar tiempo que me permita
pensar mejor, vender más, agregar más valor,
pensamiento estratégico.
Y te BAZ quitando tareas.
Yo siempre digo que si recuerdan la película
de Matrix en la imagen donde a Neo está
tratando de aprender artes marciales y que le
meten un chip en la cabeza para que aprenda
artes marciales porque antes no sabía nada.
Este es es esa similitud cuando la
inteligencia artificial le enseñas y van a
tener un taller de clown y esto es un tema
que van a ver hoy o mañana.
Dentro de clown le enseñas con skills cómo
sistematizar algo que tú haces y siempre
hacer esto y estás generando leverage,
apalancamiento.
Y ustedes saben que el apalancamiento crea
valor y aquí estás generando apalancamiento
sobre tu tiempo porque estás liberándolo para
enfocarte en lo que importa.
El 4.º punto es el líder conectado.
Es el que empieza realmente a operar con
inteligencia artificial, ya no como
asistente, sino como modelo operativo.
Conectas a tu sesión de cloud, por ejemplo,
tu mail, Slack o tus herramientas internas,
tu calendario, lo que puedas tú conectar y
empiezas a operar la forma en la que haces
las cosas en el día a día.
Desde la inteligencia artificial Cloud
Revísame los últimos 60 correos que tengo en
mi bandeja, quiero que analices todos los
correos que tengo de Ricardo.
Quiero entender cuáles son todas las
prioridades que Ricardo está comunicando para
estar seguros que tenemos realmente todas las
tareas bien hechas.
Quiero que identifique si hay brechas.
Esas brechas me las mandes al CRM.
Después de que lo mandaste al CRM, quiero que
detones correos a todos los involucrados para
que realmente estemos arriba de las cosas que
tenemos que hacer.
Estás escribiéndole directamente ahí a Cloud?
No tienes que estar haciendo cosas en los
diferentes sistemas y Cloud se vuelve ese
sistema operativo personal que te permite
generar valor, cambiar resultados.
Y esto es algo que hay literal.
Otra vez, de nuevo con Cloud lo podemos hacer
mañana y si llegamos ahí, el último eslabón
que queda es este, que por mucho es el más
importante y es algo que de hecho mencionaba
Ricardo al inicio de la sesión, no?
El líder que logra llegar al punto cinco
es el Native Builder.
Y siempre digo que si una empresa tiene a una
persona, una que logra llegar a este nivel,
es una empresa que tiene la posibilidad de
generar un valor exponencial brutal y esta
persona ya no es la persona que utiliza ya
ahí, sino que realmente está pensando en
organizaciones, está entendiendo cómo se
tiene que reconfigurar la organización del
futuro, donde tenemos entendido que hacia
adelante las organizaciones van a cambiar
roles, los van a tomar la inteligencia
artificial, roles los vamos a tener las
personas y vamos a entender.
O ese builder va a estar Arquitectura como
las organizaciones del futuro, donde
personas, agentes van a convivir.
Y aquí es donde regresamos a lo que dice Sam
Altman o Dario Amodei.
Va a haber organizaciones que con personas
más limitadas o con las mismas van a
potencializar resultados multimillonarios.
Inclusive vamos a ver empresas de dos o tres
personas que valgan 1 billón de dólares.
Esos son arquitectos de organizaciones, son
los que realmente entienden que la
inteligencia artificial, ya en el nivel que
tenemos que verla hacia el futuro, sí va a
transformar cómo trabajamos.
Sí va a transformar los procesos.
Si los agentes, pero al final va a
transformar las organizaciones.
Desde esta perspectiva.
Y esto es la parte individual, Ese fue el
centro que decía del yo, pero realmente para
que ustedes puedan realmente ir avanzando del
escalón uno al dos, al tres, al cuatro,
eventualmente al cinco, les voy a pedir algo
incómodo que no les va a gustar y que van a
sacar a salir de aquí diciendo Pinche Adrián,
por qué no está diciendo esto?
Van a tener que desaprender lo que saben y
más importante, en lo que ustedes creen que
son buenos, porque ahí es donde nos cuesta
más trabajo.
Vamos a tener que desaprender la forma en la
que hacemos finanzas para hacer finanzas con
ella.
Ahí vamos a tener que desaprender la forma en
la que hacemos cobranza para hacer cobranza
con ella.
Vamos a desaprender la forma en la que
hacemos cultura para también ver cómo la IA
nos potencializa y ese tema de desaprender
para aprender es el reto más grande que
tenemos.
Cuando ya llegamos a ser líderes, Porque tú
si ya llegaste a ser líder, dices llegué aquí
porque tengo lo que se necesita.
El futuro cambió las reglas del juego, lo que
se necesita cambió.
Para llegar ahí tienes que incomodarte y
hacer esta tarea porque la IA no cambia lo
que hacemos, pero sí cambia cómo lo hacemos.
Cómo analizamos, cómo decidimos,
cómo al final construimos.
Pero este fue el yo.
Ya cambiaste tú.
Imaginemos que ya lo logramos hacer aquí.
Estamos en un grupo de empresas increíble que
tiene un impacto y que realmente tiene una
influencia importantísima en el país.
Cómo cambias el sistema donde trabajas?
Y aquí es donde ya no podemos hablar nada más
de lo que yo puedo hacer con la inteligencia
artificial.
Aquí sí tenemos que empezar a pensar en cosas
un poco más complejas, que son los sistemas y
los habilitadores, porque todas las empresas
quieren hacer lo que está del lado izquierdo.
Creemos que tenemos todo listo para tener una
gente que revisa las finanzas, identifica las
brechas, hace cobranza solita y atiende a
todos y todos.
Y decimos es que hay que hacer agentes por
todos lados.
Si todo mundo queremos estar ahí.
Pero también la realidad de muchas empresas.
Desgraciadamente la mayoría estamos del lado
derecho.
Datos desconectados, herramientas aisladas,
contexto incompleto.
Y si tenemos contexto incompleto y data
incompleta, ese es el alimento realmente ya
para que la implementación es a nivel escala
de IA en las empresas se puedan hacer, pero
inclusive aquí también hay una metodología y
una forma y yo si hay una empresa que
realmente me emociona ver cómo ha sido el
efecto transformacional que ha tenido, de
cómo han implementado IA Si hay una que
escogieron el mundo se llama Ramp, es una
fintech de Estados Unidos que todo el
programa que implementaron se llama Glass y
entendieron que la inteligencia artificial a
escala a nivel organizacional requiere uno.
Si de tener una base de datos limpios,
conectados, accesibles, confiables, que si lo
tienes después arriba de esta puedas conectar
tus herramientas, tu CRM, mail, documentos,
todas las herramientas que necesitas tener.
Y en el nivel de arriba es donde empiezas a
pensar cómo entra la IA, cómo entra el agente
que se llama todo lo que vive alrededor de
los modelos de IA.
Porque si tienes la parte tres pero no tienes
la uno y la dos, no sirve de mucho, y esta
parte sí le toca a los departamentos de TI.
Si es un habilitador.
Pero después regresamos otra vez a lo que
requiere, a lo que se requiere de los líderes
de las áreas de negocio, que es el
entendimiento de lo que realmente hacemos, de
cómo trabajamos, de cómo son nuestros
procesos, de cómo realmente tenemos
resultados, de cómo agregamos valor.
Y aquí los responsables realmente de generar
el valor real de la IA.
No estoy de ti, es un habilitador del
proceso, es el que realmente es, el dueño del
resultado del proceso, porque teniendo esos
tres habilitadores, lo que queda para
construir los agentes es entender cómo crear
valor desde el proceso que tú lideras.
Con esas tres capas listas, tú podrías casi
casi que describir tu trabajo, describir tu
proceso y la IA lo convierte en agentes
ejecutables.
Y Ricardo mencionó que era un agente para los
que no entienden muy bien esto, pues un
agente es algo que se ve como esto.
Tienes entradas que son data a lo que estás
conectado.
Oye, el cliente historial, interacciones, el
pipeline de ventas, productos, precios,
comunicaciones.
Tienes a la gente que la gente tiene un set
de instrucciones y reglas que no le ponen
tantos límites, pero al menos le delimitan
cuál es la ruta a seguir.
Y el agente después decide, prioriza,
recomienda, genera, comunica y a través de
estar conectado a los sistemas, impacta.
No implementen agentes de IA que no toquen la
parte de abajo.
KPIs claves.
El agente va a generar mayor conversión sí o
no?
Ciclos más cortos de ventas, Mayor
ingreso si no toca ingreso o costo, no
va.
Y la realidad es que el cambio
organizacional, cuando un agente tiene un
impacto y una persona lo usa, se crea un
agente y tiene valor.
La.
El ejemplo de RAMP, que realmente es el mejor
ejemplo que existe, les invito a que lo lean,
de ahí diez lo usan y personas empiezan a
crear sus propios agentes porque los
habilitadores ya existen, de ahí 100 lo
mejoran y de ahí entonces explota el que
realmente es.
A productividad efímera que se menciona
realmente se haga y sea una realidad en el
mundo.
La inteligencia artificial así se transforma
en las organizaciones, Así realmente,
regresando al estudio de McKinsey y decía ese
20% que sí genera resultados, estos se ven
los números 20% son evitas dos x en
recuperación de inversión, 3 $ por cada dólar
invertido.
Pero el camino no es fácil.
El camino requiere de personas, requiere de
habilitadores para llegar ahí y requiere de
liderazgo.
Y finalmente, hablemos un poco más del mundo,
porque al final vivimos en un mundo porque
sí, este es el presente.
Les digo que lo que se viene hacia el
futuro no es incremental, es exponencial.
Computación cuántica.
Hoy estamos al inicio de la.
Realmente el nivel de madurez de hoy.
Cómo se ve el futuro y todas las
conversaciones que hay hoy en el mundo de
inteligencia artificial?
Dicen que hay una bifurcación potencial hacia
adelante.
Un futuro donde realmente la productividad
que podamos crear cree realmente estructuras
que nos permitan tener un futuro increíble y
algunas otras posturas que dicen que esa
productividad puede llevar un mundo?
Pues que los empleos, la desigualdad.
Hay un hecho que es cierto la
inteligencia va a ser abundante.
Lo que estamos viendo hoy del estatus de
dónde está el nivel de madurez de hoy es un
espejo chiquitito de lo que va a ser en diez
años el que la inteligencia sea abundante.
No está el debate, eso no está en debate.
Lo que está en debate es entender que el
impacto real de generación de valor, de
negocios, de crecimiento económico, no lo va
a definir tanto la tecnología de sociedad, de
política, que también hablamos, no va a
definir tanto la tecnología.
La tecnología es un hecho que va a estar ahí,
lo va a definir.
Las decisiones que tomemos con la misma y si
ven estamos regresando a un ciclo completo,
regresando otra vez al rol de líder.
La tecnología, si bien va a ser fundamental,
va a ser abundante y va a ser gigante, va a
seguir siendo una habilitador de nuestras
decisiones y cómo queremos realmente generar
ese futuro que queremos ver.
Y aquí quiero empezar a terminar con un par
de reflexiones.
Primero, con esta frase de Darío.
Day es el fundador de Anthropic y yo
personalmente la persona que más admiro en el
mundo de inteligencia artificial Es el
fundador de Crowd y Dario dice El miedo es un
motivador y hoy en día todos hablamos del
miedo, de ay, es que tengo que aprender hoy
porque voy a perder mi chamba, tengo que
aprender hoy porque me voy a quedar atrás,
tengo que aprender hoy porque si no voy a
perder competitividad.
Y Darío dice El miedo es un motivador, pero
no es suficiente.
Necesitamos esperanza.
Esperanza que podemos crear mejores negocios,
esperanza que podemos crear, mejor valor
económico, esperanza que podemos generar
mejores líderes hacia adelante que puedan
construir esto.
Esperanza de también, por qué no impactar
aunque sea algo chiquito nuestro mundo?
Y voy a terminar con una última historia de
cómo.
Y esta para mí es la historia más importante
que tengo yo en mi experiencia de del uso de
la inteligencia artificial.
Cómo yo pude cambiar un cachito chiquito de
mi mundo?
Uno de mis amigos más queridos y más
entrañables que conocí en la maestría en
Harvard, desgraciadamente tuvo un tema
brutalmente complicado médico en los últimos
meses, algo complicadísimo.
Y él es un emprendedor también.
Él es un CEO de una startup también increíble
y desgraciadamente por este tema médico no va
a poder él operar su negocio ni con las manos
ni con los pies hacia el futuro.
Y hace más o menos dos meses que salió de
terapia intensiva.
Voy y lo visito al hospital y platicando con
él no fuimos a platicar de oye, qué difícil
es el mundo hacia adelante, platicamos como
amigos y en esa conversación casual me salió
decirle literal del corazón y de lo más
profundo de mi ser.
No lo tengo completamente claro cómo, pero en
el momento que tú quieras regresar a ser el
CEO de tu empresa a ejercer y a generar
valor, como lo estás haciendo con
inteligencia Artificial, voy a habilitar y te
voy a ayudar que lo puedas hacer.
Y quiero decirles que eso lo dije con una
completa responsabilidad porque hubiera sido
extremadamente irresponsable de mi parte
hacer esa promesa en alguien que está en una
situación extremadamente frágil.
Y lo hice con esa responsabilidad porque hoy
entendí y tenía ya el conocimiento que para
cosas que antes pensábamos que eran
fantasías, podemos empezar a hacer promesas
accionables, promesas de algo que realmente
sí puede ser.
Y hoy pues ya le instalé su Open Cloud, ya lo
conecté a todas sus herramientas, no está al
100%, pero sí está a un 70%.
Y esto.
Y con esto voy a empezar a concluir, es
realmente por qué hago lo que hago y
realmente todo lo que hago?
Y las empresas que lidero están fundamentadas
en este pensamiento.
Think Big Start simple, Think Big en el mundo
de la inteligencia artificial es entender que
estamos al inicio de una década de una
coyuntura que muchos de los retos más
difíciles y más importantes como sociedad
cambio climático, el encontrar solución para
ciertas enfermedades, no dicho por mí, sino
por dicho por los grandes exponentes de la
tecnología de hoy, vamos a poder resolver
muchas de estas, pero es más importante la
frase de abajo, Think simple start simple
perdón.
Entender que aunque sean cosas muy grandes,
luego la mente humana es tan chiquita que no
entendemos y nos sentimos ajenos y nos
sentimos espectadores de algo tan grande que
está pasando.
Pero regresemos al tema de que la IA es tan
democrática que requiere de pensamiento
crítico y todos podemos pensar bien para
cambiar nuestros negocios.
La forma en que lideramos nuestro impacto,
que si empezamos de forma sencilla.
Podemos ser parte de un cambio mucho más
grande que se ve allá arriba.
En 2011.
Un chavo que soy yo sin idea de tecnología,
veía una transacción con un pollo en Kenia.
Esa transacción, lo que realmente despertó en
mí fue una curiosidad profunda de realmente
entender cómo la tecnología podía impactar,
crear valor económico, cambiar negocios.
Ese momento que yo viví hoy lo están
viviendo cada uno de ustedes, porque
estamos en ese momento donde la IA está
presentando esas oportunidades todos los
días El telescopio que existe ya existe,
la IA ya está en ese momento, ya tenemos
las herramientas, el telescopio ya está
ahí, las estrellas también están ahí.
Esas oportunidades de negocio, esos patrones
que antes no veíamos, esas formas de hacer
cosas diferentes, hoy las podemos abordar.
La decisión de mirar a través del
telescopio esa decisión sí es nada más de
ustedes y de nadie más.
Es el lunes, son las 09:00.
Qué fregados BAZ a hacer?
Muchas gracias.
>> Muchas gracias a Adrián Villaseñor.
Muy claro, contundente.
Y preguntaban por ahí que si además de
escribir también se le puede hablar.
>> Sí, 100%.
Y la recomendación más grande de si hablamos
de productividad, la mejor herramienta de
productividad para utilizar hoy se llama
Whisper Flow.
Yo la uso para todo y aparte no es nada más
para hablarle a la IA, sino ya le puedes
hablar a todos los lugares donde escribes
Whisper Flow, háblenle con eso y se van.
Se van a hacer todavía mucho más productivos.
>> Gracias, gracias.
Pues qué interesante, la verdad.
Y ahora, eh, vamos a recibir a Luis
Caro y a Manu Quijano para comenzar
con el primer módulo del taller de
Cloth.
Bienvenidos.
Por favor.
Hola!
>> Gracias.
Y la silla con la mesa.
Ahora sí.
Listo?
Bueno, Muy buenas tardes
>> Queremos que ustedes tengan una experiencia
real.
Nos vamos a ensuciar la mano.
Veo que todos tienen sus computadores, vamos
a probar interactuar con esta tecnología.
Creo que es muy importante que todos
empecemos, no?
Creo que todos hemos tenido nuestro momento.
Wow, Nuestro momento.
Yo a veces lo llamo momento Terminator con la
inteligencia artificial.
Hoy en día, ese momento que te asusta, que te
hace algo que te sorprende.
Mi primera reacción cuando yo tuve ese
momento fue miedo, no?
Hasta aquí llegó mi trabajo.
Me van a reemplazar, pero mi segunda reacción
fue la inteligencia artificial.
Yo creo que de verdad es la verdadera
bicicleta de la mente, no?
No sé cuántos de ustedes han escuchado.
Hay un discurso de Steve Jobs muy famoso
donde él definía que la visión de la
computadora personal era una bicicleta para
la mente, y él decía que cuando él tenía 13
años, él lo impactó mucho.
Un estudio de una investigación científica
que él leyó comparando la eficiencia
locomotora de todas las especies del planeta
Tierra.
Cuántas calorías consumía cada especie de ir
al punto A al punto B, qué tan rápido se
movían consumiendo, qué número de calorías y
cuáles eran las especies más eficientes?
Y él decía que bueno, de primer lugar quedó
el cóndor.
El cóndor era la raza que consumiendo menos
calorías se movía más rápido y podía recorrer
más distancias.
Y él decía que los seres humanos, siendo la
joya de la creación e teniendo el cerebro más
avanzado, teniendo conocimiento avanzado,
quedaron de últimos en la lista casi que en
1/3 de la lista, pero que alguien en el
estudio se le ocurrió hacer el análisis.
Pero el ser humano montado en una bicicleta y
el ser humano montado en la bicicleta dejó al
cóndor en el polvo y se convirtió en la raza
más eficiente en esquemas locomotivos de ir
del punto A al punto B.
Y él decía que la computadora personal, su
visión era que fuera eso, una bicicleta para
nuestra mente, porque los seres humanos
construimos herramientas no que nos
reemplacen, sino que aumenten nuestras
capacidades.
Y yo creo que eso fue muy cierto, pero su
visión no fue completa hasta hoy en día, con
los avances que nosotros hemos visto en
inteligencia artificial y en agentes.
Muchísimo gusto.
Mi nombre es Yo soy el doctor Luis Caro.
Actualmente lidero el área de Inteligencia
Artificial e Innovación para Amazon Web
Services en toda Latinoamérica.
Soy responsable por la implementación de la
estrategia, no solo con nuestros clientes,
sino también dentro del grupo Amazon, no?
Entonces vamos a hablar hoy un poco.
Voy a pasar ese video de Clot.
Qué es?
De las herramientas que vamos a ver hoy en
día, vamos a aclarar primero una serie de
conocimientos, estandarizar que todos estemos
hablando de lo mismo.
Sé que todos han leído, sé que todos
conocemos, hemos escuchado cosas, vamos a
cubrir algunas bases, vamos a ver algunos
ejemplos, porque esto está para quedarse.
Por qué las empresas en Latinoamérica y en
todo el mundo están usando esta tecnología y
después va a pasar a Manuel Quijano para
darnos una, ehh un taller Hanson para que
ustedes puedan interactuar con esto de
primera mano y puedan medir el impacto real.
Estamos bien con eso.
Me escuchan bien?
Estoy hablando muy rápido, muy lento.
Todo bien.
Listo?
Perfecto.
Entonces.
Anthropic es una startup que fue fundada en
el 2021.
Como mencionó el speaker anterior, fue
fundada por Dario Amodei.
De hecho, él fundó la empresa junto con su
hermana Daniela.
No es.
Ambos son fundadores de Anthropic.
Ellos trabajaron juntos.
Ambos trabajaron en OpenAI.
Dario era de investigación para OpenAI y él
sale de OpenAI y y funda Anthropic.
Él fundó Anthropic con el objetivo de, EH,
atacar una preocupación que él tenía de que
esta tecnología se usara de una manera
segura, de una manera responsable.
Estamos hablando de una época donde ella, eh,
era era sujeto a muchas fallas.
Tu podías a las primeras versiones de GPT
pedirles que te ayudaran a crear una bomba y
te daban el manual detalladito y podías hacer
cosas bien maliciosas con él.
Entonces ellos arrancaron y decir cómo
creamos inteligencia artificial de cero,
pero incorporando responsabilidad y
seguridad desde el día 1, OpenAI tuvo un
approach un poco diferente.
Creo que lanzaron al mercado rápido y después
se dieron cuenta.
A esto hay que meterle seguridad y controles.
Darío tuvo la visión de arrancar día uno con
esas funcionalidades.
Todo el mundo habla de Clod, pero es
importante aclarar qué es Clod.
Clod es una familia.
Arrancó como una familia de modelos de
inteligencia artificial generativa ya.
El modelo de inteligencia artificial
generativa es como si fuera el cerebro de
una gente.
Ya un modelo lo que hace es recibir
información, ya sea en texto, imágenes o
vídeo.
Dependiendo de su tipo, puede regresar
texto, imágenes o vídeo.
Es capaz de razonar, pero el modelo es eso es
algo que se entrenó con billones de datos en
Internet y su función es eso.
Recibe una entrada, la procesa y devuelve
una salida.
Ya entonces, cuando Anthropic
lanzó su primer modelo, lo llamó
Clod en honor AA1 matemático.
Eh, Claude Shannon, que era muy.
Fue uno de los pioneros en el área de
inteligencia artificial, y Shannon era muy
famoso porque era matemático e ingeniero
eléctrico.
Entonces era una persona que tenía un perfil
intelectual muy políglota.
O sea, conocía de inteligencia artificial,
conocía de computadoras, pero también conocía
de hardware, de electrónica.
Era entonces se inspiraron en honor a él.
Llamaron al primer modelo Clod, lanzó una
versión, salió una versión del modelo
versión uno que se llamaba Solo Clod y ya el
modelo va por su 4.ª versión.
Su 4.ª iteración, no?
Entonces estos modelos, pues tienen son
entrenados con grandes volúmenes de
información.
Algunos modelos se entrenan con información
más pequeña, más especializada, Eso los hace
más rápido, pueden responder más rápido,
otros con información más abierta, más
cantidad de información.
Eso a veces los hace más capacidades de
razonamiento, de poder pensar bien, de poder
estructurar cómo van a ser las cosas.
Eso los hacen más pesados, a veces un poco
más lentos, a veces inclusive más costosos de
interactuar con ellos.
Entonces, lo que maneja Cloud es que siempre
a partir de la versión tres en adelante, para
darle a ustedes los usuarios flexibilidad de
que ustedes puedan escoger si quieren ese
modelo grueso, grande, entrenado, con gran
volumen de información o ese modelo ligero
que sea más rápido, responda más rápido.
Yo siempre han mantenido versiones actuales
de tres modelos diferentes uno ligero, uno
intermedio y el más avanzado que sea el que
mejor le va en los rankings.
Estos modelos, cada vez que sale una nueva
versión se les hacen exámenes, se les ponen
pruebas, desafíos y así los rankeamos de
cuáles son los que mejor se desempeñan o peor
se desempeñan.
Entonces en ese momento antrópico, la
versión 4.0 nos ofrece tres modelos
diferentes HIGH, que es el más rápido
Sonet, que es el intermedio y Opus
que es la versión 4.7, que es el
modelo más avanzado.
Obviamente es el que más tiempo va a
demorarse en responder de los tres, pero es
el que más complejas tareas pueda asumir, no?
Entonces, durante el ejercicio ustedes van a
ver que van a tener la opción de escoger el
modelo.
Es importante diferenciar entre un
modelo y un agente.
Un agente es un proceso de software.
Es un software que es capaz de hacer tareas,
que es capaz de actuar de manera
independiente, tomar decisiones y es una
combinación de un modelo que es como si fuera
su cerebro.
Él va a tomar esas acciones basado en el
modelo, pero también tiene un conjunto que
son herramientas y datos base, no?
Entonces él va a combinar ese modelo con las
herramientas y con los datos que tiene.
Entonces el modelo yo le digo que yo le puedo
decir necesito hacer un análisis financiero y
quiero saber cuánto me va a dar el ITF de
aquí a diez años.
El modelo va a saber.
Tengo que hacer un cálculo del interés
compuesto, pero esos modelos son muy buenos
generando texto y cuando hacen fórmulas
matemáticas pueden cometer errores.
Entonces, usar el modelo dentro de un agente
va a permitir que el modelo sea lo
suficientemente inteligente para saber.
Ah, pero para calcular el interés compuesto
yo voy a usar esta herramienta que es una
calculadora y yo voy a multiplicar el
rendimiento del ETF por el AL al exponencial
del número de años para calcular los
rendimientos.
Entonces el agente combina el modelo con
diferentes cosas.
Nosotros desde el lado de Amazon tenemos una
alianza fuerte con Anthropic.
Estamos trabajando en una colaboración muy
fuerte para traerles esta tecnología con
seguridad, con escalabilidad.
Ustedes no tengan problemas de capacidad, que
ustedes no tengan problemas de seguridad,
pero hay muchos miedos de clientes.
Cuando yo hablo con diferentes ejecutivos en
los clientes que tenemos de Latinoamérica, de
que si yo uso estos modelos o use esta
tecnología, mi data va a estar expuesta.
Nosotros tenemos una alianza fuerte con
Anthropic Antrópico, todos esos modelos que
ustedes vieron ahí de Cloud han sido
entrenados y desarrollados en los data
centers de Amazon Web Services.
Entonces tenemos los servicios para
ofrecerlos de manera segura e inclusive de
tal forma de que son con regulaciones como
GDPR en Europa, que son una de las
regulaciones más estrictas que tenemos a
nivel mundial, no?
Entonces, esto es lo que ha traído.
Es que hoy tenemos más de 100.000 empresas en
todo el mundo que están utilizando cloud bajo
nuestra infraestructura, eh, de manera
exitosa.
Ahora, cuando hablamos de ahí, a qué nos
estamos hablando?
Hablamos de que hay empresas que usan esos
modelos directamente desde su software, pero
también antrópica lanzó sus propias
aplicaciones, su propia suite, que lo llaman
la suite empresarial, que son aplicaciones
para que las empresas no tengan que manipular
el modelo directamente, sino que puedan
interactuar con esta tecnología de manera
transparente, sencilla y asequible.
Entonces, el primer producto, que es el que
históricamente lanzaron y lo hizo muy famoso,
fue Cloud Chat, que es un producto que es una
interfaz web, tiene un cliente desktop
también y es el Clot, que yo creo que la
mayoría de personas conocemos.
Entramos en cloud.
Ella, abrimos una sesión de chat y
podemos hacer preguntas.
Podemos seleccionar qué versión del modelo
queremos trabajar y podemos hacer preguntas.
Lo vamos a ver ahora en el taller más
adelante en en detalle.
La otra solución es Cloud Cowork.
Es una solución Desktop es un programa que yo
instalo en mi computador y me permite.
Es una solución que adopta más los
principios de agentes, me permite crear y
tener agentes dentro de mi máquina local.
Ya entonces yo descargo la aplicación y esa
aplicación yo la puedo conectar con mis
carpetas en mi computadora con herramientas.
Mi correo electrónico, mis esquemas de
comunicación, sean Slack, sean Teams, mis
herramientas de ofimáticas, sean hojas de
cálculo o sean GSuite y él es capaz de hacer
tareas complejas en mi máquina por mí, donde
yo necesariamente tengo que estar todo el
tiempo supervisando su trabajo.
Yo le doy una tarea y él se va a encargar de
hacerlo.
Vamos a ver algunos ejemplos.
Como digo, de ambos chat es más para
preguntas y respuestas cowork es para que
nuestro computador sea ese agente personal y
pueda hacer tareas de manera independiente.
Yo puedo programar tareas si necesito hacer
algo todos los días a las 08:00 y mi
computador está prendido, el lo va a hacer.
Y finalmente tenemos otra herramienta que
también ha tenido mucho acoge en el mercado
que es Cloud Code.
Esa no la vamos a ver el día de hoy.
En mi experiencia con todos los clientes que
he trabajado en Latinoamérica, yo veo dos
usuarios fuertes de la inteligencia
artificial.
Vemos los usuarios finales que somos todos
nosotros y vemos los desarrolladores de
software.
Los desarrolladores de software están en otra
liga, eh?
Y los agentes?
Yo puedo usar agentes ya hechos como cowork o
puedo desarrollar mis propios agentes
desarrollando mi propio software. Es un.
Es un área de mucha innovación.
Es una discusión para otro foro, no la vamos
a ver.
Hoy nos vamos a enfocar en chat y en cowork,
pero Cloudkit es una herramienta para yo
hacer desarrollo de software con un agente.
De ahí a mi lado y poder pedirle a la gente
que me haga cosas.
Y esto vemos un área de muchos productos, es
todo un área de mercado diferente de cómo
desarrollo yo software utilizando el hoy y
cómo incorporo AI dentro de mi software.
No es el foco de nosotros.
Hoy nos vamos a enfocar en las dos primeras
herramientas.
Ahora, cuando nosotros hablamos de estos
modelos y de estas herramientas, mucha gente
habla de los famosos tokens, no?
Y Jensen Huang, CEO de Nvidia, dice que ahora
a los desarrolladores de software hay que
pagarles la mitad del salario en tokens, no?
Qué es un token?
Yo veo mucho hablar de eso.
Cómo funciona estos modelos?
El token es simplemente una unidad de
medida que mide la información que el
modelo ingesta y la información que el
modelo nos regresa.
Cómo funciona el modelo?
El modelo no procesa texto per se.
El modelo lo que hace Cuando yo le envío una
instrucción, el convierte ese texto en esos
tokens.
Tiene un proceso que se llama
tokenización, que convierte de.
Imagínense que el texto está hecho en español
tóquense como si fuera otro idioma, que ese
es el idioma que el modelo sí puede procesar.
Entonces, por qué es tan importante?
Y todo el mundo habla de tokens?
Por qué los tokens son la medida de costo de
saber cuánto me cuesta, cuánto le cuesta al
modelo procesar esa información.
Y estos modelos cuestan dependiendo de
cuántos token ingestan, cuántos token reciben
y también cuántos token devuelven ya.
Entonces, eso es lo que son los tokens.
Qué es importante que ustedes entiendan en
este punto?
Una concepción muy errada también es que la
gente cree que los token son estándar.
Los token no son estándar.
Cada modelo puede tokenizar de manera
ligeramente diferente.
Entonces la misma cantidad de texto me puede
generar n número de tokens con un modelo N
más una variación con otro.
Eso nos puede impactar el costo, pero lo
único que es importante es se refiere a lo
que estamos y a lo que el modelo devuelva.
Ahora algunos ejemplos.
Nosotros vemos que en todo el mundo,
clientes de Amazon y de Cloud están
usando estas tecnologías dentro de su
negocio.
Por ejemplo, aquí tenemos el caso de
Made.com, que es una empresa que hoy en día
gracias a estas tecnologías ha logrado
ahorrar diez horas semanales automatizando
descripción de productos en su e-commerce,
no?
También tenemos el caso de Intuit.
Intuit es una empresa de software orientada
al consumidor final en Estados Unidos para
ayudarles a los consumidores a hacer sus
impuestos.
E Intuit utiliza EH esas
tecnologías para.
Primero la utilizó para ayudar a los clientes
a entender los formularios de impuestos en
Estados Unidos.
Dentro de sus soluciones existentes, pero hoy
en día también tiene conectores de tal forma
de que si los clientes quieren.
Desde Cloud conectarse a las soluciones de
Intuit para hacer su declaración de
impuestos, también es posible.
Es algo que también vemos en los casos de
éxito de los clientes.
A veces nosotros queremos.
Al adoptar esta tecnología, buscar
impactos significativos desde el día 1, y
eso está bien.
Pero hay un efecto que estamos viendo
también.
No sé cuántos de ustedes, eh,
manejen el tema de el.
Yo creo que todos debemos manejarlo.
El concepto del interés compuesto, eh?
Nosotros en ella también hablamos de.
El el interés compuesto de la inteligencia
artificial.
Entonces hay muchos clientes que cuando
tienen sus primeras victorias tempranas con
la inteligencia artificial, tienen mejoras
del cinco o del 6% y consideran que esas
mejoras son pequeñas.
Pero algo estamos viendo también que entre
más implementamos ese cinco o 6% se va
creciendo de manera exponencial, porque si
genera ese efecto compuesto tal cual como a
veces yo veo un ETF que da cinco o 6% en
dólares y me desanimo, pero a diez años y la
ventaja del ella es que se mueve tan rápido
que no es a diez años, sino en muy pocos
meses.
Eso se vuelve ese compounding empieza a
disparar.
Entonces hoy mejoramos cómo hacemos la
reunión del equipo o la reunión X de la
organización?
Si yo eso lo hago por diez reuniones más, ese
beneficio que hice en esa reunión lo voy a
multiplicar por diez.
Si hago un agente que simplifica 5% de mi
tiempo, hago diez agentes más y eso me va a
multiplicar por 50%.
El beneficio.
Entonces es muy importante que no se
desesperen y tengan en cuenta ese inter.
Y finalmente otro cliente que
está usando esta tecnología
muy de moda recientemente eh?
Pues es la Fórmula uno, no?
Eh, Hoy en día.
>> Let's go Racing, Welcome to the
real time
Hoy en dia a
>> El aliado oficial de la Fórmula uno en
la Fórmula uno, un carro de Fórmula uno
genera más de 1 millón de datos cada
minuto y es un deporte donde tomar
decisiones rápido.
Inspeccionar esos datos, retroalimentar a los
televidentes con los insights de la carrera y
cómo van.
Eso es esencial.
Y ahí nosotros, en colaboración con
Anthropic, también hemos hecho un trabajo muy
increíble de cómo utilizamos agentes de
inteligencia artificial para acelerar y
mejorar las experiencias de los fanáticos, de
tal forma de que la resolución de incidentes
y cualquier novedad del deporte se pueda
llevar en tiempo real a los clientes.
Eso era un poco el contenido que tenía para
ustedes el día de hoy.
Para el resto de la sesión.
Me gustaría invitar a Manuel Quijano a
que les haga 1/2 de El Laboratorio.
Quiero recomendarles que quiero también
compartirles.
Manuel es uno de los especialistas y
arquitectos que no solo ha trabajado con
ustedes ya por bastante tiempo, sino que
ha sido uno de los campeones de promover
la cultura de ella y First dentro de
Amazon en México.
Entonces, mucha de la estrategia que nosotros
hemos definido a nivel Latinoamérica de cómo
los amazonians en Amazon Web Services deben
usar la inteligencia artificial en su día a
día en Latinoamérica.
Manu ha sido parte del equipo que ha hecho
Step up y que nos ha ayudado mucho a promover
el uso de esta tecnología dentro de la
empresa, de tal forma de que nosotros también
hagamos walk the walk the talk y nosotros
usemos eso también a la interna.
Entonces un privilegio tenerlo acá, un
privilegio que también esté trabajando con
ustedes.
Y bueno, lo dejo para que les muestre un poco
estos ejercicios.
Muchísimas gracias por su tiempo y un placer
conocerlos.
>> El iban al revés.
Gracias.
Por la.
Historia.
Sí, Hola!
Cómo estamos todos?
Estamos listos para ver algunas.
Demos algunos ejercicios en vivos.
Ok.
Clot Eh.
Por qué no me muestras mi agenda para el día
de hoy?
Ok, Esto es lo primero que yo hago cuando uso
Cloud.
Cuando me despierto, yo tengo cloud conectado
a mi mi calendario de Gmail y lo que está
haciendo a continuación.
Lo que están viendo es una integración de
cloud con mi Gmail y lo que me va a mostrar
es mi calendario.
Entonces esto es lo primero que yo hago al
momento de despertarme.
Parece que tengo una charla de introducción
de Cloud.
Tengo que entrar a un comité ejecutivo y
tengo que preparar un reporte para
indicadores financieros.
Pero esperen, antes de meterme realmente a
trabajar, a mí siempre me gusta revisar mis
inversiones.
Cloud.
Tú crees que me puedas ayudar a revisar mi
portafolio de inversiones?
Yo tengo en mi portafolio de inversiones
acciones de Amazon, acciones de Nvidia y
también me encanta Bitcoin.
Yo he sido un láser desde el 2018.
Siempre he confiado en Bitcoin y también
tengo Bitcoin en mi portafolio.
Entonces, a mí lo que siempre me encanta
hacer es usar Klout para que vaya y revise lo
que es mi portafolio de inversiones.
De hecho, veo ahí un movimiento de que
Bitcoin se ha mantenido bastante estable,
pero me interesa también muchísimo entender
por qué Bitcoin está teniendo ese movimiento.
Entonces Cloud, por qué no me das las
noticias más relevantes que han salido de
Bitcoin el día de hoy?
Me gusta entender, obviamente, por qué se han
movido lo que yo tengo en mi portafolio y
también me va a ayudar con esto.
Entonces esto es lo que hago después en mi
día y me hace un análisis y también es
posible que me busque como las noticias más
relevantes de por qué el precio de Bitcoin se
ha movido.
Listo, ya acabé con las actividades más
personales.
Finalmente le pregunto Dime qué pendientes
tengo yo el día de hoy?
Entonces yo continúo obviamente usando Klout
y le pregunto si tengo algún pendiente.
Vale, aquí lo estoy conectando con una
herramienta que yo uso.
Esas son todas las integraciones que ya han
visto, como las presentaciones lo conecta con
mi asana.
Que yo lo uso para gestionar mi día a día y
me dice que tengo varias, varias prioridades
para el día de hoy.
Tengo prioridades laborales número uno, tengo
que ir al Comité Ejecutivo número dos.
También tengo que ir al Comité de Marketing.
Y número tres también tengo que ir al
Comité de Finanzas, pero también me gusta
revisar mis pendientes más de mi vida
personal.
Mucho gusto.
Yo soy Manuel Quijano y yo soy arquitecto de
soluciones para el equipo de AWS.
Bien, como mencionaba Luis, yo llevo ya más
de tres años especializado en todo el tema de
usar la inteligencia artificial generativa
para impulsar el desarrollo.
Yo he trabajado mucho con equipos de
desarrollo, llevo más de diez años de
experiencia en la industria y también he sido
antes de estar en AWS y de que fuera
arquitecto.
Era desarrollador.
Entonces tengo mucha experiencia en
desarrollo.
Me encanta mi la NFL.
Si hay alguien aquí que sea fan de la NFL, me
encantaría hablar un poco.
Soy un poco triste porque mis patriotas los
destruyeron en el Superbowl pasado, pero
bueno, eso es un poco de mi.
>> René, por favor.
Yo soy René Roldán.
Soy arquitecto de soluciones también en AWS.
Yo soy especialista en la parte de datos.
Tengo más de seis años trabajando con AWS y
generalmente trabajo con proyectos de una
cantidad o volumen de datos grande.
Ahora he estado especializándome en temas de
inteligencia artificial generativa, justo
para poder ayudar a los clientes a que puedan
trabajar y desarrollar sus nuevas
iniciativas.
Yo voy a estar operando laboratorio hoy por
ustedes y voy a estar acompañando a Manuel en
esta presentación y les vamos a enseñar en
una demo en vivo cómo estamos trabajando
directamente con inteligencia artificial
generativa para ir cambiando nuestra vida y
cómo nos va a asistir en resolver todas las
tareas que tenemos en nuestras actividades.
>> Obviamente yo les voy a mostrar muchas
funcionalidades, no se agobien, quiero que
tomen un poco de todo lo que les voy a
mostrar y vamos a cerrar con un taller
práctico para que ustedes pierdan un poco el
miedo, se ensucian las manos y empezamos a
usar cloud para casos de uso reales dentro de
la organización.
Vale, pero antes de arrancar me gustaría
tener estos temas personales.
Si ustedes se dan cuenta, tengo un mensaje en
mi aniversario de boda.
A mí de hecho se me acabó de olvidar que la
próxima semana cumplo diez años de casado y
mi esposa creo que me va a matar.
Entonces me ayudarías a encontrar vuelos y
algún hotel en Cancún para la primera semana
de junio para que yo me pueda ir a celebrar
mi aniversario con mi esposa?
Lo que estamos viendo ahí es una integración
de cloud directamente con Expedia.
Cloud va a usar un agente por debajo que va a
salir, se va a conectar con Expedia y me va a
encontrar.
Primero que nada, hoteles disponibles para la
primera semana de junio en Cancún.
Además de hacer esto también no solo me va a
encontrar hoteles, sino que también me va a
buscar vuelos para esa primera semana de de
junio, no?
Esto es súper poderoso y creo que lo ha
mencionado en varias charlas que tenemos hoy.
Ustedes pueden hacer estas integraciones
dentro de Cloud para que conectarlo con
Expedia, conectarlo con TripAdvisor y también
agilizarlo más como en tareas mundanas que
ustedes hacen en su día a día, como por
ejemplo hacer planear el viaje de aniversario
con mi esposa.
Vale, me quedan ahí unos pendientes todavía
antes de entrar más al tema laboral.
Y es que yo tenía pendiente comprar una moto.
Ok, también me estoy mudando recientemente,
entonces quería validar si hay cobertura de
totalplay de paquetes de 500 megabytes donde
yo vivo.
Y tercero, también quiero enterarme de las
últimas noticias del Mundial.
También soy un apasionado del fútbol.
Estoy siguiendo muy de cerca todas las
noticias que están llevando hacia la Copa del
Mundo.
Entonces lo que están viendo aquí es una
integración de cloud en directamente en el
navegador.
Ya sabían que hay una integración directa de
cloud para usar en el navegador.
Una pregunta, pero lo pueden usar
directamente en Chrome y pueden usarlo
también para automatizar acciones en el
browser.
Y yo le voy a decir quiero que navegues a la
página de Elektra y me encuentres una moto.
No le di muchas especificaciones, obviamente
es una demostración y me la agregues al
carrito.
Todo lo que están viendo ustedes, la
integración que yo tengo aquí de cloud en el
navegador, es capaz de tomar control del
navegador de manera automática.
Como les digo, navega a la página de Elektra.
Si ven.
René no está usando las manos, nada más
muestra que no, no hay nada ahí de trampas.
Va a encontrar la moto en la página de
Elektra y finalmente me la va a agregar al
carrito.
Ok, entonces de una manera muy poderosa que
ustedes pueden usar la extensión de Cloud
dentro del navegador para automatizar esta
navegación.
>> Cloud es una herramienta.
Muy poderosa que nos permite habilitar
herramientas como por ejemplo el Agent e-
commerce.
Qué quiere decir esto?
Que nosotros podamos darle herramientas
directamente a nuestros usuarios que tal vez
no tienen las capacidades técnicas o el
tiempo para realizar una compra directa que
nos van a permitir que nosotros también
podamos ir a la competencia y analizar cuáles
son los precios para mantenernos competitivos
y nos van a permitir también generar
herramientas para conectarnos ahora a todo
este mundo auténtico.
>> Sí, algo muy importante, algo que ustedes
tienen que considerar es preparar sus sitios
web para que los agentes los puedan, puedan
navegar.
En el pasado hablábamos mucho de aplicaciones
responsivas que se vean bien desde el
browser, desde el celular.
Ahorita lo que ustedes tienen que hacer es.
Preparar sus aplicaciones.
>> Va a navegar a la página de Totalplay.
Está evaluando todos los paquetes disponibles
ahí que me está mostrando la página de
Totalplay.
Yo como le especifiqué en el prompt, quiero
que evalúe si el de 500 megabytes está
disponible en mi casa.
BAZ va a tratar, va a ser me va a llevar aquí
a la parte de check out.
Y finalmente, antes de que él haga el check,
va a validar si este paquete está realmente
disponible en mi casa.
Entonces él sigue trabajando aquí como lo
vemos, y esto es lo que se llama en el
browser.
>> Para nosotros es muy importante que tengan un
concepto que es multimodal.
Cloud tiene modelos que son multimodales y
eso quiere decir que básicamente nosotros
podemos insertar texto y el modelo lo va a
reconocer y también lo va a hacer a través de
imágenes.
Cómo funciona Cloud cuando toma control de mi
computadora es que empieza a tomar
screenshots.
Estos screenshots se los va a pasar al
modelo, los va a analizar y posteriormente va
a tratar de resolver la tarea que le estoy
dando a través de estas imágenes.
Si se fijan, nosotros simplemente le mandamos
una dirección.
No le estamos diciendo en qué lugar tienes
que ponerla.
Él está infiriendo por el nombre de los
campos.
Después de eso, analiza la página web por
detrás, extrae el contenido y va a inserta
directamente toda esta información
directamente en la página.
Eso es lo que lo vuelve a génico y es lo que
hace que nos permita que podamos operar
directamente con cualquier tipo de sitio y
automatizar diferente tipo de tareas.
>> Vale, entonces aquí ya va a terminar de
validar.
Alguien sabe si hay cobertura así nada más?
Esperemos que sí.
>> Porque está en vivo esto Entonces esperemos
que no salga mal.
>> Entonces Cloud va a terminar de escribirme.
Me va a llenar el formulario y lo que
finalmente va a hacer la página de Totalplay
me va a responder diciendo si hay cobertura
en mi casa, entonces vamos a darle.
Parece que no cuento con cobertura,
desafortunadamente, pero bueno, no pasa nada,
podemos intentar con otro paquete.
Pero bueno, este es un ejemplo de cómo
podemos usar cloud para básicamente
automatizar todas estas tareas dentro del
navegador.
Ok, última tarea Se acuerdan cuál era?
Soy súper fan del Mundial, entonces quiero
que navegue a la página de TV Azteca, busque
las noticias más recientes del Mundial y nada
más me haga como un resumen, no?
A mí me gusta estar muy enterado de qué
jugador se ha lesionado, a quién han
convocado y no sé, a ver qué, qué es lo que
va a pasar, porque ya estamos a nada de que
empiece el Mundial.
Entonces, muy similar a las otras dos
demostraciones anteriores, navega a la página
de TV Azteca, va a buscar la sección del
Mundial como ustedes están viendo ahorita van
a navegarla y lo que va a terminar haciendo
aquí es dándome un resumen de todas las
noticias más recientes del Mundial.
Entonces perfecto.
Aquí con estas tres demostraciones lo que
hicimos fue número uno navegar a Elektra,
dejar que me seleccionara una moto, me la
agregará al carrito número dos.
Se fue al sitio de Totalplay, buscó el
paquete de 500 megas, puso la dirección y
validó si había cobertura.
Y número tres se fue a navegar a la página de
TV Azteca para sacarme las noticias más
recientes del Mundial.
Y esto es lo que se llama en el browser.
>> Aquí solamente quiero dejar algo sobre la
mesa que es muy importante.
Nosotros cuando hemos desarrollado tal vez
todas estas plataformas o estas páginas las
hemos pensado directamente para que sea un
humano el que está transitando o el que está
dando clics.
Esto que nos que nos hace pensar que tenemos,
que tal vez reinventar todas estas, estas
aplicaciones y estas páginas con la intención
de que sea un agente el que está viajando en
ellas.
Entonces, cómo hacemos que este nuevo flujo
para que la gente que está navegando dentro
de nuestra página pueda encontrar la
información, pueda responder o también
podamos prevenirnos de cómo otros agentes
están entrando en nuestra página y cómo
podemos.
Protegerlas.
Vale, es un.
Es un nuevo paradigma y es una nueva forma en
la cual nosotros tenemos que empezar a
diseñar todos estos servicios que estamos
desarrollando.
>> Excelente.
Bueno, con esto yo cubro todas esas
pendientes que tenía más del lado personal.
Ahora es hora de atacar mis pendientes más
laborales.
No sé si ustedes se acuerdan, pero cuando yo
le pregunté a Cloud que me diera mi agenda,
yo tenía el comité ejecutivo ok.
Y ese es el escenario.
Básicamente, yo tengo que ir hoy al Comité
Ejecutivo, me dieron cuatro diferentes
documentos, un documento que.
Que explica el IPS, el IPN, perdón, más
reciente, un documento que también me va
a hablar del roadmap, las notas de la
reunión anterior o el último comité y
también el.
Como les decía anteriormente, el IPN o el NET
Promoter Score en inglés.
Entonces, qué es lo que voy a hacer a
continuación?
Voy a crear un proyecto dentro de Cloud, en
este caso es Cloud Cowork, en el cual yo ya
le subí los cuatro documentos.
Yo tengo que preparar un brief ejecutivo para
este comité, pero no, realmente no tengo
tiempo para leerme los cuatro documentos y
llegar con un resumen a ese comité.
Entonces, qué es lo que voy a hacer?
Creé un proyecto en Cloud Cowork y le pasé
unas reglas.
Esta parte de las reglas es súper importante.
De hecho, cuando nosotros trabajamos con
herramientas como Cloud, estas reglas me van
a permitir que se comporta de una manera
mucho más determinista.
Ok.
Qué es lo que pasa?
Que a veces los modelos sí pueden llegar a
alucinar, pero si nosotros les pasamos reglas
antes, esto puede puede hacer que el
comportamiento sea como más determinista.
Y las reglas que les estoy diciendo es que
para cualquier reporte que me genere dentro
de este proyecto, me dé información, no
opinión, me lo haga en formato bluf, o sea,
que ponga la conclusión primero y luego me
ponga los datos.
Cifras concretas.
Y esto son buenas prácticas que ustedes
pueden empezar a adoptar, no cifras
concretas, nunca.
Adjetivos vacíos.
Si llegara a detectar una contradicción entre
los documentos, quisiera que me lo dijera.
Y finalmente, si encuentra, si no encuentra,
o sea, que no me de información, que no están
contenidos en esos documentos.
Súper importante y obviamente para que no
usen anglicismos usa español de negocios y no
uses anglicismos.
Entonces listo, he creado el proyecto,
entonces ya tengo como mi proyecto dentro de
cloud, ya les subí los cuatro documentos, ya
puedo empezar a trabajar y el primer prompt
que le voy a decir le voy a decir Oye, por
qué no me cruzas los cuatro documentos que te
acabé de subir y me generas un brief
ejecutivo?
Yo necesito este brief para prepararme en el
Comité Ejecutivo.
Entonces yo lo que hago es que le mando ese
prompt de seguimiento y esto es súper
poderoso.
Probablemente.
No sé ustedes díganme si yo hubiera hecho
esto a mano, hubiera tenido que revisar todos
los documentos que me pasaron para prepararme
al comité.
Yo creo que me hubiera podido tardar más de
cuatro horas.
Lo que estamos haciendo aquí es haciéndolo
con Cloud en menos de cinco minutos o puede
ser diez minutos, dependiendo de la cantidad
de documentos que estoy usando.
Entonces le mando el prompt.
Quiero que me hagas este briefing ejecutivo
para que yo me pueda preparar para mi comité
y listo.
Me da como un resumen de las tres decisiones
tomadas en el comité anterior.
Entonces lee la minuta del comité anterior y
me da como un resumen también.
Después de eso me da como los puntos más
importantes, no los tres riesgos que nadie
está diciendo en voz alta.
Y esto lo detectó justamente este documento
del IPN.
También aquí el riesgo número dos crédito
nómina de 12% de participación.
Identifica los riesgos que encontró en estos
documentos.
Ojo, estos documentos son ficticios, no son
para nada reales, son.
Yo los creé ahorita nada más para hacer esta
demostración.
Nada más quería aclarar esa parte.
Entonces, si seguimos un poco aquí, lo que me
responde Cloud.
También me da recomendaciones de lo que yo
pueda llevar al comité.
Entonces, si se dan cuenta es súper poderoso
porque me está dando una preparación, un
desglose de todos los puntos más importantes
que yo pueda llevar a ese comité.
Listo, Pero no nos vamos a quedar hasta acá.
Ustedes sabían que Cloud Cowork al día de hoy
puede generar documentos y entregables?
Le voy a pedir que me todo este desglose o
este resumen que me hizo que me genere un
documento de Word.
Ok?
O puede ser un brief que yo voy a llevar al
comité con todo este resumen que me hizo, le
voy a decir por favor de este resumen que
acabaste de hacer generarme un brief
ejecutivo en formato Word que yo pueda llevar
al comité y esto es como ya donde vemos ya
estas funcionalidades auténticas, no?
Anteriormente cuando arrancaron esas
herramientas eran más como yo le hago una
pregunta, me contesta, pregunta, respuesta Ya
aquí con estas funcionalidades auténticas es
capaz de generar un entregable y lo que vemos
aquí es que me está generando un documento
que yo puedo llevar y listo para este comité
ejecutivo.
Entonces él es capaz de hacerme como estos
entregables, documentos de Word,
presentaciones de PowerPoint, excels o
Spreadsheets.
Y lo poderoso aquí es que yo lo puedo
descargar y también se lo puedo mandar a mi
equipo, no?
Entonces un caso de uso súper poderoso el
cual ustedes pueden adoptar para prepararse
para comités, cruzar mucha información entre
múltiples documentos, etcétera, etcétera Eso
está súper bien.
A mí me gusta, pero para mí no es suficiente.
Qué es lo que pasa?
Que yo tengo que repetir esa tarea todos los
lunes.
Es una tarea esa tarea de yo prepararme ante
el comité es algo que todos los lunes me toca
hacer.
Qué tal si la pudiera, como programar o
calendarizar de cierta manera?
Y es aquí donde entra la siguiente
funcionalidad que les voy a mostrar.
Ustedes pueden crear tareas agendadas en
cloud para que, por ejemplo, todos los lunes
a las siete am Cloud me repita esta tarea.
Entonces, yo ya la estoy automatizando.
Y si yo tengo mi computadora prendida, ojo,
esto para que esto funcione tienen que tener
su computadora prendida, pero si ustedes
tienen su computadora prendida, lo que
estamos haciendo aquí es creando una tarea
programada que se va a ejecutar todos los
lunes a las siete am.
Superpoderosa.
Una Un consejo que les daría.
Obviamente hay que mantener actualizado pues
todos los documentos que me los suban a mi
proyecto, pero si yo creo esta tarea
programada, esto se va a ejecutar de manera
automática todos los lunes a las siete am y
listo, quedó mi tarea programada.
Me va a hacer unas preguntas y este es un
caso de uso bastante poderoso que ustedes
pueden adoptar en el día a día.
Vale?
Entonces, nada más para recapitular, vimos
que creamos un proyecto, le subimos múltiples
documentos, le mandamos un prompt para que
cruzara la información entre los documentos.
Me generó un brief ejecutivo y un Word listo
para presentar ante el comité y finalmente
hicimos una tarea programada para que esto se
se ejecute todos los lunes.
Y ahí está la tarea programada.
También esto lo pueden aprender a hacer
ustedes dentro de Cloud Desktop.
Vale?
Listo.
Parece que hemos completado el primer comité,
pero se acuerdan que mis pendientes.
Mi segunda reunión del día era el Comité de
finanzas?
Ok.
Y tenemos un caso similar.
Me entregaron un Spreadsheet, un Excel, una
hoja de Excel muy grande, como con 16
diferentes hojas, muchos reportes y me
pidieron que llegara con un consolidado para
el comité de Finanzas.
Uf, Ok.
Cómo podemos usar Cloud para resolver esto?
Entonces a mí lo que me hicieron aquí es que
me entregaron una hoja, un spreadsheet
bastante complicado.
Ok?
Y vamos a usar una funcionalidad aquí que se
llama Cloud dentro de Excel.
No sé si ustedes sabían, pero ustedes ya
pueden usar directamente en Excel.
Es muy.
Yo sé que probablemente ustedes no usan Excel
en su día a día, pero muy posiblemente las
personas que les reportan ustedes es una de
las herramientas más utilizadas.
Entonces aquí hacemos un poquito viendo como
la hoja que me dieron perdón tiene más de 16
hojas, es bastante compleja, pero lo que
vamos a hacer a continuación es vamos a
activar Cloud dentro de dentro de Excel y eso
lo hacemos con esta pequeña funcionalidad que
se llama Addins.
Instalamos el plugin o la extensión de cloud
y eso me va a permitir usar Cloud dentro de
Excel.
Qué tipo de actividades puede hacer Cloud
dentro de Excel?
Bueno, vamos a intentar.
Vamos a mandarle un prompt cloud.
Quiero que me hagas un consolidado o un
reporte ejecutivo de todas estas hojas que yo
tengo en mi spreadsheet.
Quiero que me crees una nueva hoja que se
llame el reporte ejecutivo y me hagas como un
consolidado con KPIs, con gráficos de todas
las hojas que a mí me entregaron.
Esto es todo para yo prepararme ante el
Comité de Finanzas.
Entonces, esto en acción es en Excel y
Cloud empieza hace como el empieza a
analizar como todas mis hojas que tengo de
mi spreadsheet y esto es muy, muy
poderoso.
Qué puede hacer Cloud dentro de Excel?
Puede corregir datos, puede revisar números,
puede darme análisis?
En este caso es un poco ambicioso, pero sí es
capaz.
Le voy a decir que me haga un reporte
ejecutivo.
Cloud empieza a pensar aquí a la derecha y
aquí le puedo dejar un poquito la palabra a
René, que nos explique cómo él empieza a
construir ese dashboard ejecutivo.
>> Hoy en día, uno de los casos más poderosos de
Cloud es como un asistente para el análisis
de datos.
Regularmente, cuando nosotros tenemos que
empezar a hacer un análisis, tenemos que
iniciar con los exploratorios.
Tenemos que saber qué data tenemos, qué
información está contenida en los archivos.
Muchas veces qué tipo de archivos estamos
teniendo, porque ahora se complica mucho más
el proceso.
Con esto de big data y nuevas formas de
analizar los datos.
Entonces, qué es lo que está haciendo Cloud
acá?
Nos está funcionando como si fuera un
analista de datos, un analista de datos que
no sabe hacer zoom, como se darán cuenta.
Pero ese es el.
Ese es el humano y eso es lo importante.
Entonces, básicamente lo que hace
Cloud es ayudarnos o asistirnos
principalmente a ir construyendo la
información a ya sé, ir construyendo
la información para que nosotros
podamos empezar a analizarla poco a
poco.
>> Sí.
>> Voy a cambiar resolución de pantalla.
>> Igual aquí a la derecha.
Esto es una demo en vivo, obviamente, y el
spreadsheet es bastante complejo, pero les
podemos mostrar el resultado final de cómo
quedó ese esa hoja.
No?
Yo cuando obviamente cuando la probé
previamente, este fue el dashboard que él me
sacó, hizo como el cruce, analizó todas esas
16 hojas de cálculo, me sacó unos KPIs hasta
arriba, luego me sacó unas gráficas hasta
abajo y me las puso ahí de nuevo.
Esto es súper poderoso, sobre todo no tanto
para ustedes, porque probablemente en el día
a día no estamos usando Excel, pero para las
personas que les reportan a ustedes integrar
Cloud en Excel, definitivamente que puede
ahorrar muchísimo tiempo.
Esto era podido tomar más de un día
definitivamente y con Cloud lo logramos hacer
en menos de diez minutos.
Obviamente la teníamos cocinada de antemano.
Son demos en vivo, pero este fue un poco como
el dashboard que nos generó Cloud al usarlo
en Excel.
Cloud es capaz de identificar.
>> Cuál es la mejor forma de visualización de
datos.
Entonces automáticamente dice Estas son las
cards o las tarjetas que voy a poner arriba
con los indicadores de negocio más
importantes.
En la parte inferior también se tomó la
libertad, porque la verdad es que lo hizo
basado en el análisis que él decidió de
generar.
Cuáles son los movimientos más importantes en
el mercado entonces?
Y con nuestros datos, obviamente.
Entonces lo que hace es principalmente poner
estos semáforos que nos van a dar
visibilidad.
A nosotros también nos está marcando las
tendencias que tiene cada uno, que va a la
alza, que va a la baja o que se está
manteniendo y la funcionalidad más poderosa
que tiene también es la de las
visualizaciones.
Cloud puede ayudarnos a entender cuál es la
mejor visualización que podemos utilizar para
los datos.
En este caso es una comparativa.
La primera gráfica que estamos viendo.
Entonces Cloud elige que utilicemos una
gráfica de barras porque nos va a permitir
que nosotros podamos comparar 222 tipos de
datos.
La siguiente es una gráfica de serie de
tiempo que nos va a permitir que nosotros
podamos hacer una comparativa de cómo se han
ido moviendo los datos de.
Con el paso del tiempo, como han ido
cambiando y como se van trazando.
Incluso comparar dos tipos de variables
diferentes.
>> Excelente, Bueno, con eso ya creo que estoy
listo para el comité de finanzas, pero
ustedes se acuerdan cuál era el último comité
que tenía que ir?
El comité de marketing.
Y ahí tengo una tarea también que me
asignaron.
Ok, tengo que preparar la campaña de
lanzamiento para tarjeta Jóvenes de Azteca.
Ok, número uno, Lo que tengo que hacer es
hacer un análisis competitivo.
Me gustaría entender qué está haciendo la
competencia número dos.
Necesito planear toda la campaña de
marketing.
Y número tres, necesito generar imágenes para
que yo las pueda poner en redes sociales,
ponerlas en Instagram, ponerlas en Twitter,
etcétera Entonces, qué es lo que vamos a
usar?
Vamos a usar Klout de nuevo y les voy a
mostrar esta funcionalidad que se llaman
los pluggins.
Alguien aquí ya ha usado los plugins o tiene
alguna idea más o menos de cómo funcionan los
plugins?
Son como estas extensiones que yo puedo
instalar dentro de Klout.
Lo van a encontrar ahí arriba, a la izquierda
de su desktop.
Si ustedes se van a la parte de Customize,
como nos están mostrando ahí y básicamente
busco lo que son los plugins, yo puedo
navegar y Anthropic ya me va a ofrecer varios
plugins que ya están listos para instalarse
dentro de Cloud.
Tengo plugins de marketing, plugins para
ingenieros, plugins para productividad,
plugins también para finanzas.
En este caso, a mí me interesa instalar lo
que es el plugin de marketing, Ok, entonces
voy a instalar el plugin de marketing y algo
que les puedo recomendar aquí es que busquen
plugins que tal vez se adecúen al rol o la
posición que ustedes tengan dentro de la
organización.
Vale, entonces listo, ya.
>> Cada uno de estos plugins también tiene
herramientas preconfiguradas internas,
entonces ustedes pueden entrar, revisarlos y
saber qué capacidades adicionales les van a
estar dando.
Vale?
Así pueden identificar qué podrían hacer con
cada uno de ellos.
>> Listo, instalamos el plugin de marketing y
vamos a usarlo.
Voy a decirle Cloth, me podrías hacer un
análisis competitivo y investigar un poquito
a mis competidores, sobre todo si yo estoy
lanzando como esta campaña.
Entonces vamos a decirle y esta es la manera
que nosotros activamos estos plugins con este
formato de usar como la barra lateral, vamos
a usar este que se llama el Competitive
Brief.
Qué es el Competitive Brief?
Me va, Lo que va a hacer Cloud es va a ser un
análisis competitivo.
Entonces yo le estoy diciendo por favor
podrías analizar a mis principales
competidores, a NU México, a Mercado Pago y
Astori.
Quiero que me des mensajes de valor que tal
vez ellos puedan tener campañas que ellos
hayan lanzado en los últimos 90 días y al
final quiero que me genere un brief y después
de hacer como toda esta, este research o esta
investigación con respecto a mis
competidores.
Qué está pasando aquí por detrás?
Y este es un poco lo que empezamos a ver en
la era Agéntica, en este caso Cowork va a
arrancar sus agentes que me van a hacer esta
investigación por detrás.
De hecho, él es capaz de hacerlos en paralelo
y ahí arriba a la derecha siempre me va a
mostrar los pasos que él va a tomar.
Los modelos hoy en día son bastante
inteligentes en el sentido de que se paran,
me hacen un paso a paso, parten un problema
mucho más grande, como en diferentes pasos, y
los va haciendo uno por uno.
Entonces, qué nos puso aquí?
Qué va a ser paso a paso?
Primero va a investigar a Nu México, va a ir
a las páginas relacionadas de mi competencia,
va a sacar información.
También va a buscar información sobre Mercado
Pago.
Ok, y finalmente sobre Story.
Y lo que está haciendo aquí no es ningún
secreto.
Está arrancando Subagentes por debajo para
que vayan a internet y me puedan sacar esa
información.
Entonces esta funcionalidad es muy poderosa.
No?
No solo siempre.
>> También nosotros podemos ver qué está
haciendo la gente y esta es una buena
práctica, Tiene un proceso de razonamiento,
de pensado.
Entonces nosotros podemos entrar aquí, saber
qué está haciendo, a qué páginas está
entrando, porque nosotros tenemos que
supervisar que el resultado sea el adecuado o
el que estamos buscando.
>> Vale, te puedo interrumpir un segundo?
De hecho, se me había olvidado.
Pero si no les molesta.
Creen que me pueda tomar una selfie?
No, les.
No.
Perdón.
Esta es una.
La vamos a usar más adelante.
Ok.
Nada más que la quería mostrar para una
actividad que vamos a hacer más adelante.
Vale.
Entonces.
Qué va a hacer aquí?
Cloud Cowork.
Ya está.
Ya terminó de hacer el análisis competitivo.
Ok.
Y lo último que me está haciendo es
redactando este brief, muy similar a los
casos de uso anteriores.
Y esto superpoderoso y yo les recomiendo y
los invito a que lo hagan es que me genere
este entregable, este documento con todo lo
que investigo.
Entonces como el paso final, como vieron ya
va tachando como el paso a paso y como paso
final me va a generar este brief ejecutivo y
de esta manera acabamos de hacer un análisis
competitivo en menos de qué tres cuatro
minutos, en donde analizó a mis competidores
principales fue a todos sus sitios, buscó
como toda esta información y finalmente me
generó un brief.
Me va a generar un brief ejecutivo, vale, Y
aquí miren, eso es como lo de story,
etcétera, etcétera.
Entonces qué sigue?
Ok, ya hice como el análisis
competitivo.
Ahora este plugin de marketing también me va
a permitir hacer una campaña de marketing.
Yo quiero lanzar el producto de tarjeta
Azteca Jóvenes para el viernes 13 de junio.
Tengo un presupuesto de 33 millones de pesos.
Ok?
Estos son los segmentos que voy a atacar y
quiero que me entregue, Como toda esta
campaña de marketing, lo que vamos a
aprovechar aquí justamente es este plugin que
ya habíamos instalado, algo que probablemente
necesitaba antes.
No sé, tal vez una agencia o un equipo muy
grande ya me lo está resolviendo en menos de
diez minutos.
Lo que vemos aquí definitivamente es este
poder que me va a ofrecer Cloud a través de
estos plugins.
Quiero repetir rápidamente si ustedes son
curiosos, que se metan a la sección de
plugins dentro de Cloud y vean algún plugin
que haga sentido o se adecúe a la posición o
a la unidad de negocio donde ustedes estén
trabajando.
>> En este prompt decidimos agregar más cosas y
ser un poco más ambiciosos.
Estamos pidiendo un arco narrativo.
El arco narrativo tiene que tener la
siguiente forma Tiene que tener un teaser, un
lanzamiento, un refuerzo y una conversión.
También estamos agregando canales por
segmento, un calendario editorial de 60 días
y necesitamos saber cuáles van a ser las
métricas de cada una de estas fases.
Adicionalmente, hay que considerar que
estamos utilizando tres tipos de EH de
usuarios diferentes, no?
María, 26 años, es una emprendedora que vive
en Guadalajara.
Luis, 31 años, es un chofer de Ciudad de
México y Ana, 22 años, es universitaria y
está en Puebla.
>> Igual al ejemplo anterior, nada más para que
se acuerden.
Cloud a la derecha me va a mostrar el paso a
paso y aquí lo que está haciendo es me
empieza a construir esta campaña.
De hecho esto va a ser bastante extenso, no
me voy a detener aquí a analizarlo, pero
miren todo lo que me está sacando el nombre
de la campaña.
Ok.
>> Tenemos la idea, tenemos los perfiles por la
audiencia en donde están enfocados, cada uno
de ellos.
Tenemos también cuál va a ser el arco
narrativo de estas cuatro semanas, cómo
empieza, cómo vamos a llevar esta campaña y
cuál es la historia que vamos a contar.
Y también tenemos la semana dos tres
y cuatro.
Adicionalmente, después de esto entramos al
canal por segmento, donde básicamente nos va
a decir, dependiendo del segmento del
usuario, cuál es el mejor lugar al que
podemos llegar a él.
Por ejemplo, María va a ser un buen lugar
llegar a través de TV abierta en otros lados.
Va a ser a través de Ads, TikTok, etcétera.
Y por último, vamos a tener el calendario
editorial de 60 piezas que básicamente nos va
a decir qué vamos a construir, qué día,
cuándo lo publicamos y por qué deberíamos de
estar publicando cada uno de estos y cada uno
de estos contenidos enfocados directamente a
cada uno de estos usuarios.
>> Excelente.
Y ya como último paso.
Ok, ya hice el análisis
competitivo.
Me está terminando de generar la campaña de
marketing bastante extensa.
Como vean, es capaz de hacerme un plan súper
elaborado y súper extenso.
Ya como último paso voy a hacer una
integración con una herramienta que se llama
Canvas.
También quiero que me genere mis imágenes
para esta campaña que yo pueda agregar
directamente a redes sociales.
Entonces le vamos a mandar un prompt que me
genere imágenes, esto es en vivo, vamos a ver
cómo salen, pero que me genere unas imágenes
que pueden estar listas para que yo pueda
subir a redes sociales.
Y lo que vamos a ver aquí es de nuevo el
poder que te va a ofrecer Klout de conectarlo
a otras herramientas.
Hacer estas integraciones y aquí lo que va a
hacer es conectarse, como les decía, con
Canvas para lo que es generación de imágenes.
Y estas imágenes las voy a poder subir si me
salen bien, Obviamente.
A lo que yo le recomendaría que yo no estoy
haciendo aquí también es refinen ese prompt.
La calidad de las imágenes que les va a dar
Klout también del resultado siempre va a
depender de la calidad del prompt.
Si estas herramientas son capaces de
ahorrarnos tanto tiempo, por favor tómense el
tiempo de escribir un buen prompt.
A veces nos gusta ser como perezosos, pero si
nos están ahorrando esta cantidad de tiempo,
por favor tómense.
Tómense más de cinco minutos en elaborar un
buen prompt y se van a dar cuenta que la
calidad de lo que les va a regresar va a ser
mucho mayor.
>> Tip Pueden utilizar a Cloud para construir
sus prompts.
Entonces, a partir del prompt que tienen, si
ustedes toman la respuesta, podrían decirle a
Cloud Sabes qué Cloud?
Esta es la respuesta que me entregaste.
Ayúdame a ajustar el prompt para que mi
respuesta sea de esta forma.
Vale, tampoco tienen que construirlo ustedes.
Aprovechen la inteligencia artificial
generativa para que les ayude a resolver
incluso ese tipo de trabajo.
Aquí lo que estamos haciendo es que estamos
generando tres tipos de perfiles uno para
cada uno de las personas que vamos, a que
vamos a enfocar o targetear esta campaña,
como se darán cuenta, está buscando si hay
algún tipo de branding.
Qué quiere decir?
Que si nosotros ya tenemos un branding
desarrollado y queremos seguir este branding,
podemos utilizarlo aquí.
Como no existe, lo va a generar, Está tomando
de hecho los los colores de Grupo Salinas,
específicamente ahora de Banco Azteca.
Por qué?
Porque los buscó en Internet.
Nosotros podemos también elegir y decirle
cuando podemos buscar en internet y cuando
no, y eso va a depender de las tareas que
estamos realizando.
Acá ya tenemos algunos resultados.
Exactamente, ya.
>> Nos empieza a generar algunas imágenes, digo,
puede que tengan áreas de oportunidad o
mejoras, pero ya me está creando como estas
imágenes que yo ya puedo agarrar y estar
listas para postear en redes sociales, no?
Y ese es el poder realmente.
Si yo uso cloud por si solo es bastante
poderoso, pero intégrenlo integren estas
herramientas de terceros para que?
Para realmente ver el poder que les puede
dar.
Entonces nada más para recapitular aquí qué
fue lo que hicimos?
Instalamos el plugin de marketing.
Si se acuerdan, le pedimos que me hiciera un
análisis competitivo, que me generara también
una campaña de marketing y finalmente que me
generara imágenes para mi tarjeta Azteca
Jóvenes, que esté lista para postearse a
redes sociales y con esto terminamos lo que
es los pendientes que tenía.
Si se acuerdan lo que les explicaba al
principio tenía el comité ejecutivo que lo
resolví creando un proyecto de cloud,
haciendo una consolidación de documentos y
que me diera el brief ejecutivo, el Comité de
Finanzas, le puse Cloud en Excel, le pedí que
me hiciera un dashboard ejecutivo y me lo
creó.
Y finalmente, para este comité de marketing
me hizo una campaña, me hizo esta campaña de
marketing y me dejó lista las imágenes para
yo postear a redes sociales.
Y con esto terminamos lo que es la primera
sección, que son las demos.
Pero ahora les toca a ustedes.
Estamos listos para empezar a jugar un poco
con Cloud.
Excelente, excelente.
Entonces vamos a empezar lo que es el taller
de Cloud.
Creo que todos aquí tienen laptops ya con
Cloud Desktop instalado, vamos a empezar a
hacer unas pequeñas pruebas y empezar a jugar
con él.
Ok?
>> Algo importante es que para el taller
contamos con personas del equipo de DSI y de
IT.
>> Me pueden ayudar a levantar la mano por favor
ayúdenme a ubicarlos.
Están las personas de DSI.
>> También está el equipo de AWS.
Equipo de AWS Me ayuda a levantar manita, por
favor.
Ellos dos los van a estar apoyando en las
mesas.
Entonces cualquier tipo de asistencia que
requieran durante este ejercicio, por favor
alcen la mano.
Ellos se van a acercar con ustedes y los van
a ayudar a resolver cualquier tipo de
eventualidad o tema que encuentren.
Vale, súper importante.
En el correo de Jalmo les mandaron las
instrucciones y el link de la carpeta que
tenían que haber descargado previamente.
Si no lo hicieron, no se preocupen, los
tenemos cubiertos.
Dentro del taller van a encontrar la carpeta
de descargas.
Ahí van a venir también las instrucciones.
Entonces permítanme abrirlas para que todos
las puedan ver.
>> Todo este taller está en una página web.
Entonces lo único que ustedes tienen que
hacer es ir a el sitio, al link que les
mandaron, el enlace que les mandaron, el
correr de Jalmo y caer a este landing page.
De nuevo tenemos la asistencia, como les
decíamos, pero vamos a También pueden acceder
a través de este link por si alguien no tiene
acceso al taller, lo puede.
Se puede meter desde aquí, Vale.
Estamos listos.
Un poquito de hands on.
Cambiar un poco ahora para que ustedes lo
hagan.
Entonces vámonos al landing page del
taller.
Ok, entonces este es un workshop con
laboratorios y prácticas para que ustedes la
puedan hacer.
El primer paso que necesitamos hacer es
descargar los materiales.
Ustedes van a ver que el taller tiene ese
botón rojo súper grande donde van a descargar
los materiales que vamos a usar en el taller.
Ustedes no se preocupen, todos los documentos
se los vamos a dar nosotros.
Ustedes no tienen que meter sus propios
documentos.
Entonces el primer paso que por favor quiero
que sigan es que descarguen los materiales
para el taller.
Vale?
Una vez que los materiales se descarguen,
vamos a darle aquí unos unos segundos para
que esto termine.
Nos vamos a cambiar a Cloud, pero de
hecho, muy importante, cuando ustedes
descarguen ese contenido, esa carpeta va a
estar comprimida.
Entonces lo único que tienen que hacer si
están en Mac es darle doble clic y eso en
automático va a descomprimir los archivos.
Ok, entonces asegúrense este
ya va a terminar, Ok?
Abren la carpeta donde descargaron los
archivos o los materiales para el taller y
les dan doble clic.
Para los que tengan Windows igual pueden
pedir apoyo, pero tienen que hacer un clic
derecho y tienen que seleccionar,
descomprimir o exportar.
Pero igual si necesitan ayuda, por favor
pueden levantar la mano y de esta manera los
pueden ayudar a descomprimir los archivos.
Vamos a analizar qué hay adentro porque son
bastante sencillos de usar.
>> Vamos a darles un minutito en lo que terminan
de descargar.
Todos recuerden que pueden levantar manita y
se va a acercar a alguien a apoyarlos.
Perfecto, Entonces vamos a empezar a analizar
lo que tenemos en las carpetas, ok?
>> Este el material es muy sencillo, nada más
para que se ubiquen.
Está dividido por laboratorio.
El día de hoy solo vamos a cubrir el
laboratorio uno que es los fundamentos de
Cloud Chat y la carpeta va a tener lo que es
el Lab uno y va a tener un documento de Word.
Ok?
Y esto es un dashboard ejecutivo donde tiene
datos sobre experiencia del cliente.
Ok, solo vamos a usar un documento para lo
que es este primer laboratorio, entonces
ubíquense ahí un poquito, vean los documentos
y aquí les voy a hacer una pequeña pausa
también para que se ubiquen y vamos a
continuar en unos segundos.
>> Algo también muy importante es que este
laboratorio cuenta con versión de inglés y
español, así que en la parte superior
izquierda van a encontrar un un botón, pueden
darle clic y con eso podrán cambiar el
idioma.
Es básicamente un espejo.
Podrán utilizar el idioma con el que se
sientan mucho más cómodos.
>> Yo estoy en English anybody here that would
rather do it in english. You could always
click on the
>> So we got you covered.
Okay.
>> Vamos a continuar de nuevo ayuda
Mano abajo en el landing page.
Nos vamos a mover al laboratorio.
Uno muy similar a las demos que yo les
quería mostrar, que yo les mostré perdón.
Todas estas laboratorios empiezan con un
caso de negocio.
Estamos tratando de que sea lo más real y lo
más apegado al día a día de ustedes.
De nuevo estoy cenando con mi familia un
domingo en la noche y me llega un
WhatsApp del CEO de Grupo Salinas.
Mañana en la sesión de comité inicias tú
tienes diez minutos para hablar acerca de
cómo vamos a mejorar la experiencia de
cliente en tu unidad de negocio.
Para la segunda mitad del 2026.
Enfócalo en un dolor específico con una
propuesta.
Para resolverlo y una petición de ayuda para
el comité.
Gracias.
Es domingo ocho 17 pm y esto lo tengo que
entregar para el lunes a las diez am.
Lo que vamos a hacer a continuación es que
vamos a usar Clot Chat para que me ayude de
nuevo para prepararme para el comité.
Ok, entonces, cuáles son los objetivos de
este taller y no igual este es el primer
taller para que ustedes tengan como esa
primera experiencia se quiten ese miedo de
empezar a interactuar con chat.
Ok, entonces en los siguientes minutos
ustedes van a aprender a hablarle, perdón, a
chat como si fuera un colega de trabajo, van
a aprender cómo cambiarle el estilo, en que
te responda.
Chat tiene una funcionalidad en la cual yo le
puedo ir cambiando, como los estilos, que me
hable en modo normal, modo explicativo,
razonamiento extendido y también estilo
formal.
Entonces vamos a ver cómo también podemos
hacer eso.
Y finalmente vamos a subirle un documento y
decirle que me dé insights o me dé
información acerca de ese documento que le
vamos a subir.
Muy importante, ok?
Y esto lo vamos a se los voy a explicar a
continuación.
Para todos estos ejercicios y se acuerdan esa
diapositiva que tenía el doctor Luis Caro
donde nos mostraba los diferentes modelos de
antrópico?
Para este ejercicio vamos a usar Cloud
High Q 4.5 y enseguida les voy a
enseñar cómo cambiar esto, ok?
Entonces, antes de copiar el primer prompt
les voy a dar un tour de Cloud Desktop.
Por favor píquenle a Cloud Desktop. Ahí
Les voy a dar un pequeño tour para que
ustedes ubiquen Arriba a la izquierda.
Tienen las tres diferentes modalidades de
Clock Desktop.
Tienen Clock Chat que está más
especializado en preguntas y respuestas.
Vamos a tener cowork que tiene también
funcionalidades más auténticas.
Y finalmente, aunque no se preocupen por
esto, también tenemos Clock Code, que está
más enfocado a lo que es el desarrollo de
software.
Para este primer laboratorio nos vamos a
enfocar en Cloud Chat.
Sí sabían que Cloud Chat.
Ustedes lo pueden correr desde la aplicación
nativa de desktop, lo pueden correr en sus
celulares y también lo pueden correr en el
navegador y aquí a la izquierda les aparece
como un resumen de lo que podemos hacer.
Pero para mí lo más importante es irnos al
centro de la pantalla.
Les voy a dar como una guía de lo que tenemos
aquí lo más importante de lo más importante
es la opción para hacer selección de modelo.
Si nosotros le damos clic aquí nos aparecen
los modelos disponibles.
El Opus 4.7 es el modelo más inteligente, más
capaz y más inteligente de Anthropic.
Honestamente, para las tareas que vamos a
hacer el día de hoy no lo requerimos.
Este es un modelo mucho más enfocado a, por
ejemplo, el desarrollo de software o tareas
de ese nivel de complejidad.
Tenemos el Sonet 4.6, que es un modelo
un poquito que está abajo del 4.7.
También está muy enfocada a lo que es tareas
como el desarrollo de software, no tan capaz
como el 4.7 y finalmente el High 4.5.
Es aquí donde ustedes tienen que seleccionar
la opción para usar High 4.5, unas
recomendaciones y unos tips que yo les voy a
dar.
El High 4.5 es un modelo mucho más rápido y
mucho más eficiente y menos costoso que los
demás.
Si ustedes ponen Cloud chat en lo que es Opus
4.7, probablemente se van a quemar sus tokens
súper rápido y no van a.
No lo va a ameritar porque no estamos
usándolo para tareas tan complicadas.
Entonces por favor elijan la opción que es
High 4.5 y muy muy importante, apaguen el
razonamiento extendido.
Probablemente ustedes lo tienen prendido en
su aplicación de cloud, pero vamos a pagar el
razonamiento extendido más adelante.
Vamos a ver de qué trata esta funcionalidad.
Vale?
Y aquí abajo, para los más curiosos, vamos a
encontrar modelos más legados de antrópico.
Vamos a encontrar el Opus 4.6, el
Opus tres y el 4.5.
Si ustedes también quieren jugar y explorar
un poco los modelos, un poco más legados,
vale en el símbolo de más.
Este también es súper importante.
También me va a dar ciertas funcionalidades.
Es aquí donde yo le puedo picar y puedo
agregar archivos como las demos que yo hice.
Puedo ver mis habilidades, ver los
conectores, por ejemplo.
Se acuerdan de ese conector que yo tenía de
TripAdvisor de Expedia?
Pues bueno, lo vamos a ver aquí.
Es aquí donde vemos para los más curiosos.
Bueno, aquí es donde ustedes ya pueden hacer
esas, esas integraciones y realmente sacarle
el poder a Cloud.
Tenemos modo investigación.
De hecho vimos en la demo que en modo
investigación es parecido a ese análisis
competitivo que hicimos de marketing.
Y finalmente tenemos una opción para
cambiarle el estilo y esto va a ser muy
importante para este primer laboratorio.
Vale?
Este es como el el overview general de
cómo está la interfaz gráfica de
Cloud.
Les voy a dar aquí unos unos segundos menos
de un minuto también para que ustedes se
familiaricen con la interfaz gráfica de
Cloud, porque a continuación vamos a empezar
a mandarle unos prompts.
Recuerden súper importante cuál va a
ser el modelo haiku 4.5.
En el.
>> Laboratorio van a encontrar botoncitos de
copiar, así que ustedes pueden darle clic.
Les va a salir que fue copiado el prompt y
podrían pegarlo directamente en el chat.
>> Vale ya si nos familiarizamos con la
interfaz, vamos a regresar a nuestro
navegador y efectivamente vamos a copiar el
prompt.
Se acuerdan que nosotros, el caso de negocio
que estábamos resolviendo aquí es que
teníamos que abrir en comité, Entonces vamos
a copiar ese primer prompt.
Como decía René, nada más le damos clic al
botón de copiar.
Pero ojo, aquí vamos a hacer algo importante.
Primero denle copiar de nuevo.
Ustedes no tienen que escribir ningún prompt
para este laboratorio.
Todo es copy paste.
Nosotros ya hicimos el trabajo por ustedes.
Entonces vamos a copiar.
Regresamos a Cloud Desktop, pero no manden el
prompt todavía, vamos a pegarlo aquí en el
centro y vamos a reemplazar los corchetes que
tenemos ahí.
Y por favor, los invito a que ustedes lo
reemplacen con base a lo que ustedes hacen
aquí en la organización en Grupo Salinas.
Ok, yo reemplacé los corchetes, obviamente
esto es falso.
Yo dije soy el director de producto de Banco
Azteca como parte de Grupo Salinas y mi
principal sector son jóvenes de 18 a 25 años
que están buscando acceder a su primer
crédito.
El CEO me acaba de pedir que abra el comité
de mañana con un plan de cómo vamos a mejorar
la experiencia de cliente para la segunda
mitad del 2026.
Cómo podrías estructurar tú los primeros diez
minutos?
Ok, entonces acuérdense, reemplacen los
corchetes de acuerdo a la posición que
ustedes tienen aquí en el grupo y vamos a
mandarle el prompt importante.
>> Para esta tarea no vamos a utilizar
razonamiento extendido.
>> Entonces asegúrense de que esté apagado.
Excelente, Ya que reemplazamos los corchetes
y excelente, Veo que ahí todos ya están
empezando a jugar.
Le vamos a mandar este primer prompt entonces
vámonos.
Ok, entonces le mandamos aquí el primer
prompt, un tip que yo les voy a decir.
Ven el logo de Anthropic como
moviéndose?
Esa es la señal que está haciendo la
inferencia o tomó mi prompt.
Entonces aquí me empieza a dar una respuesta
y me empieza a dar recomendaciones de cómo yo
podría estructurar los primeros diez minutos
de este comité.
Me dice arranca por la apertura de un minuto.
Luego en los.
En los siguientes dos minutos, eh?
Empieza por el problema.
Ok.
Y vean un poquito cómo nos responde.
Y aquí les voy a dejar un poquito de tiempo
para que ustedes también lo hagan.
>> Importante A veces la inteligencia artificial
generativa puede demorarse o no responder
inmediatamente.
Si ustedes ven que justo el logo de Cloud no
está moviéndose, pueden hacerle una siguiente
pregunta para decirle cómo BAZ?
En qué te atoraste?
Qué necesitas?
Podría ser que esté esperando también un
input de ustedes para continuar con el
análisis.
>> Si aquí le damos un poquito de tiempo para
que ustedes también lo puedan hacer y obtener
su primera respuesta.
>> Otra cosa importante es que, como ven, Cloud
tiene un proceso de razonamiento.
Entonces lo que está haciendo es que nos está
haciendo preguntas para que nosotros podamos
hacer o agregar más información.
Por ejemplo, cuál es hoy el mayor abandono
en el journey de estos jóvenes?
Entonces nos va a ayudar a robustecer y a
entregar una mejor respuesta.
Dentro de Cloud.
>> Excelente.
Aquí también damos un poquito de tiempo
también para que ustedes vean que ya varios
lo completaron.
Felicidades para los que no habían mandado su
primer prompt.
Ya, ya.
Después de esto logramos mandar nuestro
primer prompt a Cloud.
Súper!
Vamos a pasar al segundo paso, entonces
acuérdense, todas las instrucciones están en
la página web, en el workshop y vamos a ir
al paso número dos.
Vamos a hacer un pequeño cambio.
Vamos a copiar este prompt que nos dice
Dame los tres factores más importantes o
más que están influyendo más la
experiencia de cliente en mi industria en
2026 describe cada uno de ellos.
Sustenta tus respuestas con datos, explicando
su importancia en mi unidad de negocios y al
final dime cuál es el más relevante para
atender.
No manden el prompt todavía y no pasa nada si
ya lo mandaron.
Lo que vamos a hacer a continuación es que
vamos a cambiar el tono o la manera en que
nos contesta Cloud.
Cómo vamos a hacer esto?
Si te regresas un poquito René, le vamos a
dar clic al símbolo de más.
Se acuerdan que les había dicho que ahí
podemos cambiar el modo en que me responde
Cloud?
Vamos a darle clic aquí en el símbolo de más
y nos vamos a ir a la opción que se llama
Usar estilo.
Vamos a usar Modo
explicativo Cloud.
Por defecto siempre está en modo normal.
Entonces si por favor pudieran elegir modo
explicativo.
Si ven la hojita abajo en el chat, eso
significa que lo que estamos activando
modo explicativo y le vamos a mandar el
prompt.
Entonces por favor, si lo pudieran hacer.
Qué es el modo explicativo Cloud?
Me va a dar respuesta mucho más elaboradas,
mucho más largas de lo que me haría
normalmente y lo que estamos tratando aquí de
explicar es que ustedes, con esta
configuración pueden cambiar el modo en el
que les contesta Cloud volumen más rápido.
Okay, entonces vamos a.
Vamos a continuar con el taller.
Asegúrense que hagan esta parte y
vamos a pasar al siguiente paso,
que es el paso tres.
Acuérdense, siempre pueden regresar a la
página web, verlo por números y ver dónde se
quedaron ustedes.
Paso número tres Vamos a activar
el razonamiento extendido.
Ok, entonces, muy importante, vamos a
activar el razonamiento extendido y le
vamos a mandar un prompt de seguimiento
con base en el factor más relevante del
paso anterior.
Esto va siendo como una mención al prompt
anterior que yo le mandé.
Dame tres propuestas para mejorar la
experiencia de cliente para la segunda mitad
del 2026.
Para cada una dame los principales riesgos.
Y finalmente recomiéndame cuál debo
tomar, Ok, Entonces vamos a copiar el
prompt muy similar, muy importante.
Por favor desactiven el modo explicativo
que fue el que activamos en el paso
anterior.
Entonces vamos a quitar el modo explicativo y
vamos a Vamos a encender Razonamiento
extendido.
Qué es el razonamiento extendido?
Es una funcionalidad que cuando yo la prendo,
el modelo va a razonar, se va a detener un
segundo, va a analizar todos los pasos que él
necesita tomar y lo va a partir en diferentes
pasos y los va a atacar.
Muy similar a como el ejemplo que les
mostraba anteriormente, donde él mostraba el
progreso de ejemplo cuando yo le pedía como
el análisis competitivo.
Entonces nada más acuérdense, apaguen
el modo explicativo, prendan modo
razonamiento extendido y le vamos a
mandar ese prompt a Cloud.
Adelante René, y por favor analicen
cómo responde distinto él.
Cuando encendemos el razonamiento extendido.
Ojo, cuando nosotros encendemos razonamiento
extendido.
Cloud va a consumir más tokens.
Entonces cada inferencia o cada prompt que
nosotros le estemos mandando va a resultar un
poco más costoso.
Ok.
Finalmente.
Analicen un poco la respuesta.
Sé que puede llegar a ser un poco larga, pero
aquí me da toda esta respuesta que puede ser
súper útil para usar en el comité que me
estoy preparando.
Y recuerden que también pueden pedirle.
>> A Cloud que les ayude a resumir esa respuesta
o darle los puntos más importantes.
Entonces tienen que empezar a interactuar con
Cloud para sentirse más cómodos con él y para
acotarse o acercarse más al resultado que
están buscando.
Siéntanse con la confianza de preguntarle y
ajustar lo que quieran.
Cloud lo va a tratar de resolver de la mejor
forma y pueden siempre analizar cómo está
razonando, cómo está tratando de resolver
este problema.
>> Excelente y felicidades!
Acabamos de aprender cómo encender lo que es
razonamiento extendido dentro de Cloud.
Ok.
Por último, vamos a vamos a continuar y vamos
a ir al siguiente paso.
Lo último que vamos a hacer de laboratorio
guiado es Les voy a enseñar cómo subir un
archivo y pedirle a Cloud que me analice ese
archivo.
Entonces le voy a decir Te voy a adjuntar el
Dashboard de Experiencia de Cliente de Banco
Azteca de Q4 2025.
Esto es ficticio, esto no es real.
Y dame la apertura de 60 segundos que yo
debería usar para mi comité de mañana, sobre
todo en la experiencia del cliente.
Es una cifra un cliente del Dashboard como
referencia, y esto es una súper
recomendación.
No les ha pasado y seguro ahorita de que las
respuestas son súper extensas en el prompt
ustedes pueden limitar la respuesta de cloud
diciéndole utiliza máximo 130 palabras.
Entonces de cierta manera estamos limitando,
estamos siendo más económico con el consumo
de tokens y cloud va a ser mucho más breve.
Entonces, qué vamos a hacer?
Vamos a copiar este prompt que ya es el
último del último paso de este taller
inicial.
Pero lo primero, se acuerdan que descargamos
la carpeta con todos los archivos de los
laboratorios?
Ok, vamos a subirle el documento de Word que
se encuentra en la primera carpeta ok?
Entonces abran de nuevo.
Vamos a darle en el símbolo de más y
aquí vamos a seleccionar Agregar un
archivo o foto.
Seleccionen el documento de Word que
está en el laboratorio uno.
Lo vamos a ver ahí.
Se llama Lab uno Cloud Chat y este
documento se llama Dashboard Experiencia
de Cliente Q4 2025.
Vale, vamos a subirselo a Cloud y
le vamos a mandar el prompt ok?
Y lo que estamos haciendo aquí al final de
cuentas es esto de poderle subir documentos a
cloud y que me haga un análisis súper
importante antes de que mandemos el prompt,
apaguen el razonamiento extendido.
Si se acuerdan en el paso anterior yo había
aprendido el razonamiento extendido.
Entonces asegúrense de que lo apaguen.
Acuérdense que esto va a generar más tokens y
va a terminar siendo más costoso también para
ustedes.
Ok, entonces le adjuntamos el documento.
Y él va a analizar el documento y me va a dar
esta apertura de 60 segundos que yo debería
usar en mi comité de mañana.
Por favor, esto los invito a que lo hagan si
tienen documentos que quieren analizar con
Cloud, ustedes se lo pegan, le cambian el
modo de respuestas.
Y efectivamente lo que estamos viendo aquí es
que me genera la apertura para el comité de
mañana, una súper buena práctica, una
recomendación.
Esto es un proceso iterativo.
Obviamente como estamos en un taller, es muy
probable que la primera no me da el resultado
esperado.
Entonces, a lo que yo les podría recomendar
es que le manden un prompt de seguimiento
para que ustedes puedan corregir, ver cosas
que tal vez no les gustó y que refine este
este inicio o esta apertura que me generó
para este comité.
Vale.
>> Y vamos a adjuntar una.
Donde descargaste el golpe.
>> Último paso y ya con esto terminamos lo
que es la introducción a Cloud Chat.
Ahora es su turno en esa misma carpeta que
ustedes descargaron hay del laboratorio uno,
hay una carpeta que se llama Materiales.
Si no las quieres enseñar.
René esa carpeta tiene tres reportes,
uno de McKinsey sobre la adopción de
inteligencia artificial.
Se llama Documentos de prueba.
Ahí van a encontrar algunos reportes.
Va a ser In Finance, el estado de la IA para
capturar valor y el rendimiento.
Ok, lo que quiero que ustedes hagan y ya lo
hagan por su propia cuenta.
Suban algunos de estos reportes y pídanle un
resumen.
Pídanle que les dé los puntos más
importantes, pídanle que les genere algo con
base pues, a este documento.
Y ahora, si ustedes ya están un poco, eh, van
a usar como todas estas técnicas que
aprendimos en el taller y vamos a ver qué
podemos generar a partir de subir estos
documentos.
Entonces, por favor, adelante.
>> Te lo pones y dice haz un resumen de de ese
documento y le puedes decir.
Bueno, es que ahorita vamos a.
Al ratito vamos a ir a la carpeta donde ya no
un libro, un libro.
Yo ligas de internet y una cuenta de.
NFTS.
>> Pónganse creativos, cámbiele el modo en que
les responde y si quieren cambiar el modelo,
digo pueden probarlo también.
No pasa nada, obviamente.
>> Recomendación menos costoso usen AIC 4.5 para
este tipo de tareas, principalmente.
Porque es una tarea sencilla.
Si fuera un análisis muy complicado, entonces
ahí hace mucho sentido que cambiemos,
utilicemos un modelo mucho más poderoso
mientras ustedes están probando, nosotros nos
tomamos la libertad de hacer un prompt con
muchos esteroides.
Por qué?
Porque queremos enseñarles un poco el arte de
lo posible, qué se puede hacer y hasta dónde
podrían empezar a a llegar con este tipo de
análisis o de ideas.
Muchas veces lo que pasa es que a partir de
un documento tenemos que hacer una
presentación al siguiente día.
Entonces yo lo que estoy haciendo es pedirle
que me cree una presentación de tres slides,
que sea muy impactante, que se enfoque en el
estudio del rendimiento de la IA de PwC, que
esté dirigida al CEO y que tenga cierta
estructura.
Por ejemplo, el slide uno se va a llamar La
Brecha, que fue separada a los ganadores.
Por qué?
Porque previamente le pedí que analizara el
documento para decirme cuál es el contenido
que este tiene.
El siguiente va a ser Insights
clave.
Va a analizar también la inteligencia de la
IA y quiero que también se enfoque en las
estadísticas más impactantes.
Vale.
Entonces acá es.
>> Que logro hacerlo grande.
>> Acá les vamos a enseñar un poco el
resultado, obviamente de.
De un prompt con esteroides, pero para que
ustedes sepan cuál es el arte de lo posible,
es una presentación.
La amplitud y el mapa de la ruta, Algo muy
sencillo a partir del análisis completo que
está haciendo sobre un documento, ustedes
pueden iterar con el estilo que quieran.
Pueden traer los colores que ustedes
necesiten y pueden decirle que construya
basado en lo que necesiten o en o en los
estilos, colores e motivo de la reunión,
etcétera.
>> Exacto.
O sea, esto ya se lo pueden llevar ustedes.
Acuérdense que Cloud es capaz de hacerles
entregables.
Entonces ustedes le piden que le haga una
presentación de Power Point, él va a ser
capaz y eso fue lo que nos acabó.
Digo, eso no fue en PowerPoint exactamente,
pero fue exactamente lo que nos acabó de
mostrar.
René.
Por último, ya vamos a cerrar y de verdad
quiero agradecer muchísimo pues todo este
tiempo las demos que mostramos, el hecho de
que se hayan tomado el tiempo de probar el
taller, tener como esta introducción general
a Cloud Chat.
Se acuerdan que yo me tomé una selfie?
No sé si por ahí se acuerdan que yo me tomé
una selfie.
Pues bueno, ese era un pequeño, una pequeña
funcionalidad que les quiero mostrar en Cloud
Code y se llama Dispatch Dispatch.
Es una funcionalidad avanzada que me permite
controlar mi computadora desde mi celular.
En lo que René hablaba, seguro algunos
dijeron es porque está mandando un whatsapp.
Me estaba mandando un WhatsApp, no agarré la
selfie que me tomé y le mandé una petición a
Cloud y le dije mira, a mí me.
Yo estoy aquí en un evento en Jalmolonga 28.
Quiero que usando esta foto me generes un
blog y me escribas una entrada para mi blog
personal.
A mí me encanta escribir blogs y básicamente
lo que le dije a Cloud es que me generara una
página web con esta foto y me escribiera este
blog por mí.
Entonces lo que hizo Cloud en por detrás en
todo esto es que me generó una con la imagen
que yo me tomé un blog en HTML y eso es lo
que vamos a hacer a continuación.
Lo que podemos ver aquí es que le puedes
decir que te lo descargue y lo que hizo
aquí Cloud por detrás fue generarme como
este blog en HTML que puedo estar listo
para publicar.
Entonces dale, si quieres descargame el HTML
a mi escritorio a donde quieras, porque él me
hizo como esta página web y me la hizo todo
como en el en el en el fondo no?
Mientras yo estaba dando como toda esta
charla.
Entonces vamos a decirle por favor describe
Descargame esta imagen a mi escritorio.
Entonces nos vamos a mi escritorio y vamos a
ver si lo logro.
Una demo en vivo.
Vamos a ver si vamos a mi escritorio.
Vamos a encontrar la imagen.
Workshop Guide. Puedes abrir a No, ese no
Quieres descargar
Pedirle cosas extras aquí a a
Claude.
Entonces le va a decir Por favor descargame
este blog.
Vamos a ver si fue capaz.
Demo en vivo.
Vamos a ver.
Ok, ahora sí, después de pedirle un poco
Chicago l h tml. Y ahi tienen la
Que me que me generó Clot acerca de mi
asistencia aquí a Jalmo 28.
Soy pésimo tomando selfies.
Dios mío, no debería dedicarme a eso, pero
bueno, me generó como una entrada de blog.
Todo esto lo hizo como en el fondo,
entendiendo un poquito la audiencia,
escribiendo.
Ojo, esto no, esto no está real, no lo voy a
publicar.
Todo es aquí.
Pero bueno, aquí pueden ver realmente el
poder de usar esta funcionalidad de dispatch,
donde yo puedo mandarle comandos a mi
computadora o a cloud en específico para que
haga tareas por mí.
Casos de uso Para esto tengo un archivo en mi
computadora que quiero accesar y hay algo en
mi computadora que no tengo acceso.
Lo lo contactos de mi celular y esto lo hacen
nada más.
Para cerrar quisiera decir que mañana vamos a
continuar con el taller.
Espero que les haya gustado porque mañana
vamos a ver funcionalidades un poco más
avanzadas de cómo crear proyectos, por
ejemplo, y también cómo hacer investigaciones
usando Cloth.
De mi parte es todo.
De verdad que muchísimas gracias por la
atención durante estas dos horas.
Yo soy Manuel Quijano y este es René.
Gracias, se los agradezco.
>> Muchas gracias don Luis.
Muchas gracias Manuel.
Muy interesante la verdad.
Mucha tarea eh.
Ahorita viene la comida eh?
Los esperamos en la actividad mágica cultural
de las 19:00 de la noche en el Caracol.
Se lo recomiendo.
Viene el maestro Paolo Bortolameolli, que ya
estuvo en el Festival de las Ideas y creo que
les va a gustar.
Vale la pena.
Muchas gracias y disfruten su tarde y sus
actividades.
A comer!